Agnies panier runaché. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Sinkerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Je m'appelle Agnè Pag Runaché. J'ai 51
ans. Je suis originaire de Marseille.
J'ai fait une grosse partie de ma vie à
Paris. Euh, j'ai ensuite pour des
raisons familiales déménagé dans le Pas
de Calé. Je suis devenue députée il y a
18 mois après avoir été 7 ans ministre
sur différents portefeuilles et pourtant
j'ai rien à voir avec la politique
puisque moi j'ai passé plus de 40 ans de
ma vie en dehors de la politique et sans
famille politique. Je suis euh diplômée
de différentes écoles très intéressée
par les politiques publiques. J'ai
démarré au ministère des finances. J'ai
ensuite été 3 ans à l'assistance
publique hôpitaux de Paris et euh
ensuite à la Caisse des dépôts et si je
dois faire un fil rouge de mon parcours
professionnel avec le recul, c'est
politique publique et gestion des
crises. politique publique, donc
assistance publique hôpitaux de Paris,
c'est l'hôpital public au moment où il y
a eu les grandes réformes mais aussi la
crise de la canicule et on a réussi à
rétablir
2000 2003 la crise de la canicule
20032006
toutes les réformes maté et
rétablissement des comptes de la PHP
mais avec une un mantra qui était la
qualité des soins pour les patients. La
PHP, c'est l'un des plus grands hôpitals
du monde, le plus grand hôpital
européen. 100000 personnes, 6 millions
de consultations, enfin à l'époque, ça
encore grandi, j'imagine.
La Caisse des dépôts et consignation
puisquil a été le premier fond souverain
français à l'initiative
de Nicolas Sarkozy. Et là, j'arrive en
pleine crise des subprimees, donc
sauvetage dexia, investissement dans des
entreprises qui voit leur valorisation
s'effondrer dans les marchés, enfin et
redémarrage de l'économie,
accompagnement de ces entreprises.
Et en fait, ce passage dans
l'investissement, dans l'accompagnement
des entreprises m'a donné envie de
passer de l'autre côté du miroir et
d'aller vers l'entreprise
avec un une feuille de route qui était
je vais faire de l'opérationnel, je vais
faire de l'industrie parce que ça me
plaisait comme univers et je vais faire
de l'international puisque j'avais été
parcours ultra franco-français.
J'ai trouvé ça chez Forestia. Je suis
devenue euh euh j'ai dirigé une business
unit qui euh faisait de la recherche et
développement euh pour euh en
sous-traitance automobile. Alors, c'est
très pompeux mais en réalité c'est tout
simplement le développement de pièces
pour des lancements de nouveaux
véhicules. En l'occurrence panneau de
porte et planche de bord pour trois
clients européens mais sous domination
sous actionnariat
américains, chinois et indien. Donc
c'est la découverte de la mondialisation
et là encore dans une période de crise
puisque c'est euh l'effondrement des
volumes de de 2011. Alors le
l'automobile est cyclique donc c'était
pas la pire des crises qu'elles avaient
affronté.
Et puis un de mes anciens patrons est
revenu me chercher pour diriger
une entreprise de taille intermédiaire,
800 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires à l'époque, 4800 salariés
dans les loisirs, pire année de
d'exercice, première premier résultat
négatif depuis les 25 ans d'existence et
c'est mon dernier poste avant de devenir
ministre. Je fais la partie un peu
désagréable, restructuration, recentrage
du groupe, puis redémarrage,
réinvestissement,
croissance et avec au bout de 6 ans bah
dans mon parc de cœur qui est le parc
Astérix, un doublement de la
fréquentation et croissance voilà
croissance, investissement et croissance
internationale.
Et puis je me suis intéressée à la
politique ou plutôt je me suis toujours
intéressée à la politique en allant
mettre mon bulletin de vote. Et quand
Emmanuel Macron se lance dans
la candidature à la présidentielle,
je me dis ben je vais quand même essayer
de me mobiliser parce que c'est très
facile de critiquer, d'avoir
Vous avez rencontré Henriemment ?
Henrièmement ? Je je l'ai rencontré mais
pas de manière suffisamment proche pour
qu'il me raconte sa relation avec le
président. Si c'est ça la question.
Il avait son Youala
pardon.
euh je sais je pense que c'était dans
des moments très institutionnels. Donc
j'ai pas de j'ai pas eu d'interaction
très directe avec lui. Ce qui est clair
c'est que j'ai fait la campagne du
président en faisant du militantisme de
base he rien d'extraordinaire. J'ai
distribué des tractes, organisé des
mobilisations, des réunions publiques et
euh quand il a été él, j'ai repris mes
activités habituelles et j'ai lâché
toutes mes responsabilités chez Enarche.
Et 15 mois plus tard, j'ai été appelée
pour rentrer au gouvernement. J'étais en
Chine pour le travail. Je suis un peu
tombée de l'armoire. J'ai eu quelques
heures pour réfléchir. Je me suis dit ou
plutôt on m'a dit écoute, c'est une fois
dans une vie, ça vaut le coup de tenter.
Effectivement, j'ai tenté. Je pensais
que ça allait pas durer longtemps.
On dit pas non à la France.
Oui, puis surtout on dit pas non à
passer du rôle d'observateur au rôle
d'acteur. On est finalement souvent très
critique quand on est dirigeant
d'entreprise des politiques publiques,
des politiques et ben à un moment on te
donne l'occasion de de jouer ce rôle-là,
ben faut prendre le défi et voir si on y
arrive mieux que les autres au fond.
ministère
secrétaire d'État l'économie euh
secrétaire d'état faut avoir en tête que
c'est vraiment l'umpen prolétariat d'un
gouvernement j'en avais pas du tout
d'ailleurs
c'était Bruno
c'était Bruno le maire et mon
portefeuille qui n'était pas défini
comme tel c'était en gros consommation
commerce artisanat industri
et ensuite de fil en aiguille les choses
se sont enchaînées et là aussi je dirais
avec une un double fil rouge
la production. Je suis passé secrétaire
d'État et l'économie à ministre délégué
à l'industrie, puis ministre de
l'énergie et du climat puis ministre
délégué à l'agriculteur puis j'ai
retrouvé l'énergie de moi avec
l'écologie et je suis enfin basculé sur
l'écologie mais avec la forêt et la
pêche et la mer. Donc je pense que j'ai
fait à peu près tous les secteurs
d'activité en production. Et deuxième
fil rouge, les crises. J'ai eu crise des
gilets jaunes vu du point de de vue des
commerçants qui perdaient du chiffre
d'affaires ou qui étaient sur les
parcours des manifestations et qui se
faisaient casser leur vitrine.
puis crise Covid évidemment, donc toutes
les mesures qu'on a déployé
au fil de l'eau
et accompagnement notamment des
commerçants artisans et des industriels.
relance
avec le plan de relance relance
industrielle
crise énergétique suite à l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie crise agricole
janvier 2024 et puis je dirais crise de
la pêche puisque quand j'ai pris le
portefeuille de la pêche je suis
retrouvée enfin face à une profession
très fragilisée avec des négociations
assez dures au niveau européen. passer
le premier deuxième fil rouge et puis
beaucoup de négociations européennes et
si j'ai peut-être deux signatures dont
les gens se se souviennent au sein du
gouvernement, je pense que c'est la
réindustrialisation
plan de relance que que j'ai porté d'un
côté et de l'autre côté euh la
réhabilitation du nucléaire
au cours d'une suite de négociation
assez épique où on a réussi à renverser
C'est la majorité qu'avait l'Allemagne
et obtenir de la Commission européenne
cette reconnaissance et égalité des
autres énergies pas carbone.
Vous faites quoi maintenant ?
Je suis député de la deuxème
circonscription du Pas de Calé.
Parlei.
Oh je
comprends quelques mots et
euh et je commence à prendre dans dans
ma manière de parler quelques
expressions sans m'en rendre compte. Ça
c'est le fait d'y d'y être sur place et
d'y habiter.
On est très content de vous recevoir. On
vous trouve tout courageuse d'être venu
chez nous parce que c'est pas facile,
c'est en direct. On travaille des sujets
très arides et en général on essaie de
rentrer en profondeur sur les choses. On
parle de gestion de crise, d'ailleurs il
y a mon ingénieur du son qui va se faire
engueuler parce qu'on voit votre
chatterton qui colle le micro et que et
que et que je trouve voilà, c'est
beaucoup mieux comme ça. Désolé. Non,
moi j'ai un truc, c'est ça que je
C'est le tissu c'est c'est
c'est la faute du tissu.
On rentre tout de suite dans le vif du
sujet. Euh madame la ministre, déjà mes
compliments, vous avez pas d'escorte,
vous venez par vos propres moyens et euh
c'est suffisamment rare pour le le dire.
gestion de crise,
on compare toujours le gouvernement
qui agit toujours de façon
symptomatique,
toujours à courir plutôt qu'anticiper.
Si vous êtes issu du milieu de
l'entreprise, vous savez qu'un bon chef
d'entreprise, il anticipe. Il anticipe
grâce à des grandes oreilles, des
grandes moustaches et des grands yeux
bien ouverts et des grandes antennes un
peu partout. Il fait du renseignement
économique, il va sur le terrain avec
des oreilles et des yeux de confiance
pour prendre la température et naviguer
plutôt que de se faire naviguer ou de se
faire chauter.
Est-ce que vous trouvez que le
gouvernement Macron ou que monsieur
Macron ou que la France à l'heure
actuelle a perdu ses capacités à sentir
le vent, à sentir le soleil, à prévoir
les gros grains ? Et est-ce que on n'est
pas devenu un pays qui ne fait que de
l'événementiel, de la com, agite les
bras, fait du bruit avec la bouche et
n'anticipe plus rien du tout ?
Alors je pense pas qu'on soit devenu ça.
Je voulais la la balance commerciale.
Vous voulez le fait que il y ait la
guerre en Ukraine qu'on a pas su être la
troisème voie et apaiser tout le monde.
Vous voulez qu'on vous parle de l'Iran ?
Oui, mais mais je suis pas sûr que enfin
par exemple sur la crise au
Moyen-Orient, je pense que moi je
faisais partie des gens qui disaient
attention nous sommes dépendants à 99 %
dans notre fourniture du gaz et du
pétrole. Ça pèse 60 % de notre mix
énergétique. Il est urgent d'accélérer
la décarbonation pas seulement pour des
raisons climatique, ce qui est très
important, mais également pour des
raisons de dépendance intrinsèque
majeure vis-à-vis de géographique qui
sont pas animés des meilleurs sentiments
à notre égard. la Russie évidemment, le
Moyen-Orient et euh et les États-Unis
états
euh et c'est une politique qu'on a qu'on
apporté. Alors euh la rapidité
d'exécution, la capacité à euh rester
sur euh une ligne d'eau dans une
démocratie où euh la part euh enfin
d'abord euh on n pas on n'avait pas euh
la majorité absolue. Ça c'est des
éléments qui vont créer de la
perturbation dans la mise en œuvre des
politiques publiques. Et je pense que si
je prends le cas précis de la crise au
Moyen-Orient, j'enlève les aspects, on
va dire affaires étrangère que j'ai pas
la prétention de de connaître.
Qui savait à quel moment est-ce que il y
a eu une note qui a été écrite au
président de la République pour dire
attention le président Trump pourrait
envisager d'intervenir et voilà les
scénarios qui pourraient se passer. Je
sais que j'ai été la voisine de euh
Sébastien Lecornu en conseil des
ministres et que je le voyais manger des
tonnes de notes qui remontai des
services. Je regardais parfois au-dessus
de son épaule pour savoir ce qu'on ce
qu'on lui racontait. Donc je pense qu'il
y a une grosse alimentation au niveau de
l'intelligence économique mais il y a
aussi quelle est notre capacité à
poursuivre ces politiques par rapport à
des pays qui n'ont pas le même mode de
de réflexion. Je m'explique. La
décarbonation, moi qui est porté cette
politique, se sortir du ou diminuer
notre utilisation du gaz et du pétrole.
Euh une stratégie qui a été présentée
euh euh partagée publiquement qui a fait
l'objet de débat de débat public mais en
réalité il y avait très peu de gens qui
venaient à ces débats publics. Stratégie
française énergie climat, elle sort en
novembre 2023. Il faut 2 ans pour
permettre de la transformer dans la
fameuse programmation pluriéannuelle de
l'énergie
et avec euh énormément de d'aller-retour
et de et de difficultés à poser ce débat
de manière euh comment euh sereine avec
des chiffres, avec des discussions.
Est-ce que tu mets plus de nucléaire,
moins de nucléaire ? Est-ce que tu mets
plus de sobriété, moins de sobriété ? et
en fait toujours prise par euh un débat
politique polarisé qui va dire "Moi, je
déteste ce nucléaire, il doit pas avoir
de nucléaire, moi je déteste les
énergies renouvelables, il doit pas y
avoir d'énergie renouvelable". Et donc
on arrive difficilement à porter ce
débat démocratique et et donc on retarde
la prise de décision. Maintenant, cette
politique, cette stratégie, elle est
assez simple, elle est écrite et on est
considéré en Europe quand même ayant les
idées plutôt plus claires que les
autres. On a dit, il faut de la
sobriété, faut de l'efficacité
énergétique, faut des énergies
renouvelables, faut du nucléaire. On a
essayé de poser assez sobrement les
choses. Comment dans chacun des domaines
quels sont les leviers d'action,
qu'est-ce qui est facile à faire,
qu'est-ce qui est un peu plus dur à
faire et quels sont pour chacun de ces
leviers euh les problèmes à anticiper ?
et avec une dimension très agnostique.
C'estàd que moi, il se trouve que je
soutiens le nucléaire comme je soutiens
les énergies renouvelables mais de
manière agnostique, j'ai une idée assez
précise des limites de chacune des
énergies en terme de coût de
consommation de fonciers, en terme
de soit de manque de puissance, soit de
fragilité, de vulnérabilité par rapport
euh opérationnel, par rapport à des
événements climatiques. Tout ça va
les adhérences sur le adhérences sur le
nucléaire
quand on voit Emmanuel Macron fermer
Fenheim parce que son prédécesseur
l'avait dit que et donc Macron part pour
fermer Fenheim et puis quelques années
après il fait la girhouette, il repart
dans l'autre sens puis ensuite il avoue
que l'Union européenne s'est trompé ou
ils ont été mauvais
euh elle est où la Molépinière
le système nerveux la Molépinière de de
tout ça ?
Je rentre dans le gouvernement le 18
octobre. Non, le 16 octobre.
Sache.
Je rentre dans le gouvernement le 16
octobre 2018.
Moi, j'ai eu je suis prononcléaire, j'ai
toujours porté le nucléaire. J'ai jamais
eu aucune difficulté, jamais.
Jamais eu d'arbitrage négatif sur le
nucléaire. Jamais.
Euh, Fenheim. Alors, c'est un dossier
dont que j'ai pas vécu en direct puisque
j'étais pas dans les enfin dans dans les
bureaux où les mise en œuvre ont été
faites, mais Fenheim, la réalité c'est
que quand vous prenez une décision de
fermeture d'une centrale, vous commencez
par ça s'est pris en 2012, vous
commencez par euh
diminuer toute la partie maintenance,
pas la maintenance courante,
mais la préparation des grands caragas.
et de toutes les opérations au long
cours. Et en fait, vous avez un effet
d'inertie sur le nucléaire qui est
considérable. Donc une décision que vous
affichez en 2013, elle a un effet de
traîne qui dépasse effectivement votre
quinquena. Donc ça se ça se pilote pas
comme ça. Et moi quand j'arrive en 2022
Fena, il m'est arrêté. Bon, je repose la
question, on est en pleine crise
énergétique, je préfère je préfère en
avoir le cœur net. Donc j'arrive, je dis
à EDF, bon mais question euh question
qui se pose, on sait redémarrer Fenheim.
En combien de temps saiton le redémarrer
? Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire de
redémarrer Fenim ? Et effectivement EDF
me fait une démonstration assez
implacable pour m'expliquer que je suis
bien gentille, mais ce n'est pas
redémarrable.
Et moi je comprends que en 2018 on avait
en fait vraiment réduit la possibilité
de poursuivre Fenheim enfin de prolonger
Fenim facilement. Peut-être on aurait pu
renverser la décision, mais elle ça
supposait un réinvestissement assez
massif et une reprogrammation euh des
investissements. Alors encore une fois,
les investissements de maintenance
courant étaient fait, c'est pas le
sujet. La question c'est la préparation
des visites décennales.
Ben mon sujet en fait c'est la clé de
lecture.
La clé de lecture le cap de la France
dans un milieu où vous avez pu remarquer
comme moi que on n pas des copains qui
souhaitent que du bien à la France
confirme
y compris en Europe avec l'Allemagne qui
nous met des couteaux dans le dos
régulièrement.
La question que je me pose c'est quand
on est ministre d'un gouvernement. Alors
on en a croisé avant vous des ministres
du gouvernement français. On a discuté,
on a même été invité à visiter le bureau
de Macron du temps qu'il était à Beril.
On a même visité les Liport où ils ont
tourné Mission Impossible. Magnifique,
magnifique.
La question que je vous pose, c'est la
France, le navire France, l'histoire
France, la clé de lecture, la le laser
de de de pour comprendre où le pays va
avec des fondamentaux, les basiques
énergie, nourriture.
Je vous parle même pas infrastructure de
transport. Vous devriez rajouter
infrastructure bien sûr.
Donc la clé de lecture c'est la
suivante. On a l'impression que Emmanuel
Macron c'est un chef de BDE de
l'événementiel
qui fait de l'ambigué stratégique comme
un mec de BDE en fin de soirée.
Et la question qu'on se pose, c'est le
parc nucléaire que mes grands-parents,
mes parents ont payé, la lecture
géopolitique
de nos anciens ministres des affaires
étrangères, la troisième voix qui était
la France, je vais être très abrupte.
La France, plus personne ne l'écoute. La
France n'est même pas prévenue quand il
y a tonton
Donald Trump qui va faire ses
expéditions punitives au Moyen-Orient.
La France se retrouve avec une balance
commerciale dans les chaussettes, une
balance alimentaire dans les chaussettes
et une balance énergétique compliqué.
Comment on est dans un gouvernement et
qu'on est issu du milieu de
l'entreprise, qu'on a cette fibre de il
faut être sur le pont, le nez au vent,
voir les embrins qui se pointent parce
que sinon tout le monde va être malade,
on va perdre la la cargaison et puis on
arrivera pas à bon port. Quand vous êtes
dans ce gouvernement-là, vous si vous
êtes prenucléaire, vous savez l'inertie
de cette industrie.
Quand on vous a entendu dire il faut
engager 100000 personnes
dans le nucléaire, on a pris nos
papiers, nos crayons, on a dit ils vont
même embaucher le weekend parce que la
date butoire, ils vont c'est pas
possible. Donc la question
100000 sur 10 ans, hein.
Oui. Oui. Bah ça fait combien par
ça fait 10000 par an.
Ça fait 10000 par an.
Oui.
Ça fait combien par semaine ?
Bah 10000 par an divisé par 52 semaines.
Il y a combien de zé ? Il y a combien de
zéro un milliard ?
Il y en a neuf.
Pas mal. C'est un running qui vient chez
nous. Arrêtez de me déconcentrer madame
serait bien aimable.
Quand on a la France chevillée au cœur
et qu'on voit un président de BDE,
qu'on est aussi connecté avec
l'intelligence économique, le
renseignement, la prospective et que
l'histoire nous a absus.
On est relativement dubitatif quant à sa
façon de gérer le truc avec son
gouvernement. Bruno le mer avec tout ce
qui on pourra pouvoir en parler si vous
voulez. Mais nous on vous a vu, on s'est
dit quand même mince, qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait dans le gouvernement ? Issu de
l'entreprise, elle voit bien qu'elle va
elle va se prendre l'iceberg.
Bah en fait, moi je renverserai la
question.
Non, ça ça pas le droit de faire ça. Il
y a que les politiques de faire je
m'explique. Euh d'abord, je je valide
pas BDE.
Le gars qui le gars qui pose la vision,
il
quelle vision ?
Le gars qui pose la vision de l'Europe
dans son discours de la Sorbon de 2018
et je vous y renvoie. sur l'autonomie
stratégique qui nomme les problèmes de
défense qu'il nomme les problèmes
d'énergie tout y est dans ce discours.
L'Europe
écoute ce discours, se dit "Ça y est,
c'est encore parce que faut quand même
savoir que nous quand on va dans les
conseils des ministres européens, on est
regardé au mieux comme des colbertistes,
au pire comme des communistes. On n'est
pas forcément aligné avec la culture
moyenne européenne et notamment avec
l'ordolibéralisme
qui est toute la partie plus
protestante, Allemagne, Scandinavie,
Netherlands et cetera. euh
français, Niderlands,
euh Pays-Bas et euh vous le saviez euh
mais euh
le le cette vision là, c'est celle qui
aujourd'hui
est portée par l'Europe. Alors avec un
certain nombre de sacrifices, je veux
dire l'Europe,
il faut
détraiter sans contrôle de libre
échange. l'Europe qui explique que les
consolidations d'acteurs européens,
c'est dangereux pour la concurrence et
que ou là là faut surtout pas avoir des
grands acteurs alors que la Chine se
consolide, alors que les États-Unis se
consolident. Tous ces éléments-l qui
font partie de la doxa européenne,
le fait d'investir dans l'industrie qui
au niveau de la Doxa européenne était
quelque chose, l'innovation, c'est bien,
la recherche et développement c'est
bien, mais l'industrialisation
non, ça c'est aux entreprises de le
faire. Alors que euh les États-Unis et
et plein d'autres pays, Singapour et
cetera, investissent et et
subventionnent massivement
l'industrialisation. La Chine,
évidemment, ça c'est nous qui avons posé
cette vision. La France, hein, moi je je
renvoie ce discours de la Sorbonne en
2018 et quand vous regardez ensuite les
bougés européens, ils ont été énormément
pilotés par la la France.
On lance au moment de du Covid un
emprunt européen commun, c'est du jamais
vu quand même dans la Doxa européenne
pour financer une relance qui est censée
être industrielle. On lance des projets,
les fameux PIC ou IPCAI, sont projets
d'importance européenne commun euh qui
permettent de lancer une industrie de la
batterie électrique, de lancer une
industrie de l'hydrogène, de lancer une
industrie du médicament. Tout ça, ça
vient de la France quand même. Alors
après, vous allez me dire l'exécution,
on a le temps, on a le temps. Ou
euh qui est les médicaments recentrer la
production en Europe ? 2018 on n pas
attendu le covid pour nous on n pas on n
pas attendu le discours de la sorbonne
pour tirer l'alerte sur les médicaments,
les stocks et les chaînes
d'approvisionnement. Revenons, revenons.
Je suis d'accord, mais qu'il porte au
niveau européen et qui obtient des
bougies au niveau européen alors que la
doxa européenne encore une fois c'était
le marché unique, l'intégration, la
concurrence
ouverte qui va permettre de baisser les
prix et de rendre heureux le
consommateur européen, tout ça a été
quand même assez profondément revisité
et c'est beaucoup la France qui a porté
le drapeau. Et si je prends l'exemple du
nucléaire, pas de France, pas de
réhabilitation du nucléaire, pas
d'alliance du nucléaire, pas de
neutralité technologique dans la loi
climat 2040 qui vient d'être approuvée.
OK, on passe du postulat. Vous vous le
Macron qui n'est pas un président de BDE
qui est mon président un peu plus que ça
fait
la France et et qu'il n'a une vision
encore heureux. Encore heureux, je vous
dirais. Bon alors OK l'Europe l'Europe
OK là vous êtes en train de me décrire
une Europe
qui ne comprend rien qui a pas de
trajectoire on est obligé de débarquer à
l'Europe pour faire changer les lignes
OK
ouais l'Europe il faut un peu
Ouais il faut peut-être il faut
peut-être en sortir non parce que là là
on a là on a Attendez on a on a vraiment
l'impression de se trimballer avec un un
boulet qui nous coûte beaucoup de pognon
qui nous protège de pas grand-chose
parce que dans le meilleur des cas, elle
est borgne dans le pire, elle est
aveugle
et je vous entends madame ma ministre
débarquer là-bas, essayer de ruer dans
les brancards pour essayer de faire
bouger les choses parce que vous avez un
temps soit peu pris correctement la
température de il faut faut faire bouger
les choses.
Les les batteries,
sont où les usines de super méga
batterie ? Compliqué. Attendez,
les batteries, vous connaissez le pic du
cuivre, vous connaissez le pic
d'uranium, vous connaissez le goulot
d'étranglement de l'uranium ? Vous
voulez peut-être faire des power bank
avec une smart grid, avec des petites
voitures avec batterie permettant
d'équilibrer notre grid, ça a pas l'air
de fonctionner.
J'ai l'impression que ça lance des
grands projets mais la lecture concrète
de l'opérabilité de la chose, de
l'implémentation de la chose, ça reste
un petit peu nébuleux.
Alors on va prendre
on va prendre on pourra parler de
l'Europe parce que ça vaut le coup quand
même de parler de l'Europe tout notre
temps, madame ministre.
Mais mais prenons les batteries
électriques parce que je trouve que
c'est un sujet intéressant.
Connaissez des batteries autre chose
qu'électriques ?
Oui, pardon. C'est facilité. Euh
quand on lance le projet batterie
électrique en 2018, est-ce qu'on le
lance en 2018, euh effectivement on a
pas le savoir-faire.
Euh on a comme concurrent la Corée et la
Chine euh et euh on fait l'analyse et on
est un pays enfin moi quand j'étais dans
l'industrie automobile, on avait les
high cost countries et les low cost
countries. Évidemment, on est du côté
des high cost countries. Donc en règle
générale, c'est pas là où on essaie de
mettre le maximum des sites de
production.
Donc sur le papier, c'est pas gagné.
Euh ACC démarre sa production en 2022.
En Nvision, je veux pas dire de bêtises
mais je crois que c'est 2023. Vercor a
démarré sa production.
Aujourd'hui, j'étais à encore cessé
mardi euh dernier euh 23 mars euh 24
mars. Euh on a des montés en
compétences qui qui ont vraiment
fonctionné. Alors c'est pas complètement
plié le jeu, mais on a réussi à créer
une vallée européenne de la batterie
avec des milliers d'emplois à la clé.
On a un amont qui commence à se
structurer autour du projet XTC Orano
qui est un Dunkerc. Donc XTC Oran
Dunkerc,
un projet prologium qui est pas encore
sorti de terre mais qui a été confirmé
donc on creuse les doigts pour qu'il
avance. le projet Vercor qui monte en
cadence euh DU and Vision qui est plutôt
bien lancé et plutôt euh comment on dit
dans le business on time on budget et le
projet ACC qui est le plus ancien qui
lui monte progressivement en cadence le
recyclage de la la Black Mass à
Saint-Laurent Blangi donc à quelques
kilomètres de d'ouvrain Billy Berclot
qui démarre aussi là depuis quelques
semaines Ça c'est le résultat d'un
boulot qui a été porté par le ministre
de le ministère de l'économie qui a été
porté avec les grands industriels he cc
c'est c'est
donc c'est Total Energie c'est Mercedes
qui sont pas des rigolos en
industrialisation en tout cas nous dans
l'automobile c'était quand même la
référence avec Audi et c'est
et c'est c'était lentiste d'un côté
Renault envion avec une vision où on
importe la technologie chinoise, les
techniciens, les ingés qui sont
dans l'usine et qui aident à faire les
réglages parce que c'est vraiment de la
belle chimie et c'est pas des choses,
c'est pas de l'assemblage basique
où les compétences ont pas besoin d'être
exceptionnel. Là, on est sur des sujets
un peu compliqués.
Combien la France a mis sur la table
pour les faire venir ?
Alors, les Chinois et les euh les
Chinois et les Coréens, ça c'est les
c'est les entreprises qui les gèrent.
Nous, on a payé personne
pour l'emploi de facilité de terrain.
Par contre, les usines, oui, on les a
accompagné et les usines, on les a
accompagné avec euh suivant les usines
plus de 500 millions d'euros en moyenne,
hein. Le ticket, il est supérieur à
500000.
Création, combien d'emplois ? création
ou sécurisation de l'emploi parce que
euh ACC, il est sur le site, le plus
gros site industriel avec Arc du Pas de
Calé qui est l'ancienne française de
mécanique de Stellantis qui était en
train de descendre en emploi. 6000
emplois il y a euh 40 ans, aujourd'hui
un peu plus de 1000. Donc là on a
sécurisé, c'est un peu plus de 1000
emplois. C'est un peu près la même
histoire sur sur doué et euh Vercor là,
on est en démarrage, on est à quelques
quelques centaines d'emplois. Au total,
avec la sous-traitance euh on est euh du
côté de 10000 emplois quand même. Ce qui
est pas
500 millions 10000 emplois.
Non, 500 millions par site, hein, on
n'est pas Oui, 500 millions par site.
Euh,
les retombées économiques, la
structuration du tissu industriel pour
les Hautron. C'est un territoire que je
connais bien, j'ai encore une fois, j'y
habite. Euh aujourd'hui, il y a une
utile du CNRS qui nous dit "Votre tour
sur investissement, vous l'avez eu. Au
moins, vous avez remboursé ce que vous
avez mis et donc on tire le fil pour
faire monter en cadence cette cette
industrie euh sur la carte européenne,
on est les seuls qui tenont.
L'Allemagne, c'est compliqué.
Pourquoi ? Nurse Volt,
je vais pas parler de parce que je
connais pas exactement leur situation,
mais une négociation très euh euh nous
on avait essayé de négocier avec Tesla.
Moi, j'étais pas enthousiaste parce que
je pense queon négocie pas d'égal à égal
avec quelqu'un comme Elon Musk et
effectivement les conditions qui
posaient étaient totalement léonines. Je
pense que l'Allemagne a commencé à
signer avec lui et à force de
communication et puis bah finalement il
fait pas le projet. Je sais pas
exactement quel argent public a été
donné, pas donné ou pas. Faut savoir
quand même que l'argent public, il est
sécurisé au début du projet, mais il est
versé au fur et à mesure des
investissements et il est netté avec une
réalité d'investissement. Parce que
j'entends beaucoup de gens qui imaginent
qu'on arrive avec un chèque et puis
basta coszi. Non, euh c'est euh euh la
machine machin qui a coûté temps et on
en prend charge x % de la machine machin
et il y a même des clauses de clobac
dans euh les aides que nous faisons qui
sont
Vous avez vous avez étudié la robustesse
des filières d'approvisionnement de ces
industries ? Alors oui, ça fait partie
euh effectivement des sujets et je suis
pas la seule à les avoir étudiés,
c'est-à-dire qu'on a demandé aussi euh
aux actionnaires qui sont des
industriels euh assez euh euh sérieux de
nous faire euh la démonstration qu'ils
étaient confiants sur euh leur capacité
de sourcing, où y sourcer et comment. On
sait que sur Cam et préc, on est
extraordinairement
dépendant de la Chine, hein. Je je suis
pas naïve. Donc
le stress test, ça a considéré ça
consistait en quoi ?
C'est-à-dire
bah vous avez dit à ces entreprises vos
filières d'approvisionnement vous êtes
dépendant de qui ? Si je vous impose ça,
ça
met qu'est-ce que vous mettez en place ?
Quels sont plus que quels sont vos
stocks ? C'est quels sont vos contrats ?
Comment vous comptez raffiner la matière
? C'est pour ça aussi qu'on a soutenu le
projet XTC Orano qui est un qui est un
Dakerc et oui, il y a une prise de
risque. Ah mais je vais pas vous dire
que tout est sécurisé. Moi, j'ai fait du
business euh quand euh je fais le choix
de réinvestir sur un site alors que mes
prédécesseurs ont jamais eu pris ce
risque euh une somme qui est
l'équivalent de euh plus de 2 ans de
chiffre d'affaires du site. Euh c'est un
paris.
Quelle est votre clé de lecture pour
accompagner ce risque ?
Je je vais le formuler d'une en fait à
un moment face à la Chine qui a euh 20
ans de politique posée écrite et qui
déroule très systématiquement cette
politique. Elle a fait ses secteurs
d'activité, ses technologies. Elle s'est
fixé une part de marché domestique, une
part de marché international et elle
passe ses jalons en règle générale avec
un peu d'avance. Donc elle a une clé de
lecture.
Donc elle a un plan. Euh
pour avoir un plan, il faut une clé de
lecture.
Oui.
Stratégie.
Stratégique.
Euh et nous notre clé de lecture,
elle sait où elle va.
Elle sait la Chine sait parfaitement où
elle va et elle déroule. Je pense que
nous on a des bonnes clés de lecture
mais que notre difficulté se dérouler.
C'est la constance dans la mise en œuvre
des projets que nous portons. Et ça
c'est assez profondément lié aussi à
notre modèle. euh à notre modèle
politique lecture votre clé de lecture.
Moi, ma clé de lecture c'est si tu veux
pas être effacé industriellement
à partir du moment où le thermique va
très probablement s'effondrer, pas par
pas pour des raisons climatiques mais
pour des raisons d'adhésion du
consommateur.
Alors, je vois que vous levez les yeux
au ciel. Moi aujourd'hui les données
de consommateur sur l'électrique, c'est
95 % de nos retours. Parce qu'en fait,
et on le voit pas mal en Chine quand on
y va, une voiture sur deux à une base
électrique, le bruit, la facilité de
conduite.
Vous me dites le prix c'est moins cher
aujourd'hui. Alors
le prix de l'électricité
ouais, on va y venir.
Attention, faites pas de casquette
aujourd'hui. Déjà, je vous ai évité de
vous faire écraser. J'ai j'ai euh parce
que je sais que vous aimez bien les
données. Il se trouve que j'ai reçu ce
matin, enfin c'est pas ce matin, cet
après-midi. Attz agè si vous la ministre
pourquoi la voiture électrique est moins
chère que la voiture votre clé de
lecture
à vous parce que moi ce que font les
Chinois, on comprend ce que font les
Chinois. Et
moi ma lecture c'est que je veux pas que
l'industrie française s'efface. Et donc,
j'investis dans des euh dans des
solutions industrielles qui seront là
dans 20 ans, dans 30 ans. Et si je
prends pas ce virage là, on est mort.
Juste on est mort. Et donc
juste un peu avant parce que là là vous
mettez la charrue avant les bœrue
production énergétique. Ouais.
Vous comme vous êtes passé par quelques
petits ministères qui sont sympas, vous
savez forcément depuis quand la Chine a
fait décoller sa production énergétique
tant en consommation qu'en production.
Vous savez comparativement à ce que fait
l'Europe où on est la Chine ? Oui, elle
est loin,
elle est très avancée. Oui.
Vous mettez les bœ.
Bah nous, attendez,
elle est où la charrue ?
Bah la charrue énergétique, c'est euh
les 30 % d'augmentation de production
euh d'électricité sur baseouvelable et
nucléaire depuis euh 2022 par exemple.
OK. Euh disponible, pilotable.
Disponible et dont la pilotabilité est
en train d'augmenter. 30 % de nucléaire.
Non mais attendez 30 % de nucléaire en
plus qui en a parlé. L'augmentation de
la production nucléaire de 2022 par
rapport à 2025 c'est plus de 30 %. On
passe de 280 TW.
On dit merci EDF.
Oui, on c'est pas on dit merci à EDF,
c'est un plan excellence
2025 qui a été demandé par le
gouvernement. Une mission qui a été
demandée par la ministre de l'énergie
avec autour de la table euh des euh
ingénieurs, enfin des bureaux d'études
euh pour remettre de la qualité de
maintenance industrielle chez EDF,
réduire les temps de maintenance, faire
des chargements combustibles où on
respecte
les délais, faire des maintenances
basiques où on respecte les délais, pas
prendre à chaque fois une semaine, un
mois, plusieurs jours et Tout ça, ça
fait une capacité
de charge des réacteurs nucléaires qui
augmentent et on n pas encore arrivé au
bout. Et aujourd'hui, on parle de 280
TW. Alors, année noire,
problème de corrosion sous contrainte et
cetera. OK. Mais moi quand je mets 360
TW à horizon 2030, on me dit ils y
arriveront jamais. Moi je dis écoute,
j'ai été dans l'industrie euh 360 TW,
c'est quand même une performance ultra
moyenne, mais mettons qu'ils arrivent
pas, on le met en 2030, ils le font en 2
ans. Donc c'est un truc qu'on apprend
aussi dans l'industrie. Lorsque vous
mettez un objectif à une boîte et que
vous êtes son actionnaire et que j'ai
pas réussi à obtenir ça, vous mettez les
variables dux sur l'objectif. En règle
générale, vous savez quoi ? On finit par
y arriver.
Ça tombe bien que je vous ai sous la
main. l'uranium avec la montée en charge
du monde entier.
Vraie question. Vraie question.
Alors, je finis ma question.
Je vous vois finir.
On voit les Chinois, les Indiens un peu
tout le monde veut qui veut faire des
des bébés réacteurs, des gros réactis
l'Europe.
La disponibilité du minerai compliqué.
Euh le Kazakhstan qui dit qu'il va pas
réussir à fournir. Euh on a vu Emmanuel
Macron euh qui a fait un bon truc pour
une fois aller se balader en Mongolie
pour essayer de sécuriser de trois truc.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer ? On a
combien de stocks pour nos euh 50 tu
réacteurs et nos crayons de combustible
qui vont avec ?
Combien ? 56. Oui, merci.
Il y en a six qui sont prévus là. Ils
ont mis des boulons du béton. Ils ont
commencé ou c'était juste encore des
paroles en l'air ?
Non, ils sont posés ils ont posé les
dalles et cetera. Mais on est quand même
à une phase qui est pas du tout
qui est Ouais. qui est pas monté qui il
faudrait pas qui dans le qui est dans le
timing mais la disponibilité de la
ressource. Quand on va avoir notre ami
Trump qui va dire au Canada bon tu es
mon voisin, l'uranium il reste ici.
Quand on va voir l'Australie
qui va voir qui va devenir de plus en
plus copain avec les Chinois qui va dire
"Bon bah mon uranium c'est pour le
Japon, la Chine,
l'Europe qui n'est plus aimée que par
elle-même.
On va se retrouver avec plein de petits
réacteurs mais pas de quoi mettre
dedans.
Alors, plusieurs choses. Donc un,
effectivement, la disponibilité uranium,
il faut la regarder. On a des stocks,
évidemment, je donnerai pas les
quantités,
désolé parce que j'aime mon pays.
Ça fait partie du secret des affaires ou
ça fait partie du secret des fonces ?
Ça fait partie des choses qui ne se
partagent pas, surtout quand on a
fréquenté un tout petit peu un certain
nombre de d'ingérences étrangères.
Plutôt américaine ou russe.
Les deux. Ah, vraiment les deux. ou
plutôt allemande.
Non, les Allemands c'est pas pareil.
C'est c'est en plus les Allemands, je
pense que intrinsèquement enfin moi j'ai
j'ai négocié
on est presque devenu comme tellement on
se tapait dessus avec un secrétaire
d'état qui s'appelait Sven Gigold et je
pense que il détestait profondément le
nucléaire, c'est-à-dire il était
intimement persuadé. C'était clair,
c'était sa conviction que ce truc était
trop cher, dangereux, inacceptable et
profondément
allemand. allemand.
Mais je veux dire c'était pas c'était
pas un il ne négociait pas par cynisme
ou volonté de nous écraser, il négociait
par conviction. C'est ce qui le rendait
d'ailleurs terriblement efficace dans la
négociation parce qu'il ne lâchait rien.
C'est l'impression qu'on lui arrachait
le cœur avec l'idée que le nucléaire
soit reconnu et minoriser l'Allemagne
sur ce sujet-là, ça a été quand même un
un sacré un sacré combat. Mais revenons
sur nos stocks. Donc stock d'uranium, on
a des stocks 10 ans,
on a des partenariats. Je réponds pas à
cette question et vraiment sérieusement
euh on a des partenariats. Ça
au moins vous êtes au courant du stock.
Je suis au courant du stock, enfin
pardon, je suis au courant du stock à
janvier 2024 puisque j'ai quitté le
ministère de l'énergie à janvier 2024 et
les deux mois où j'ai été
remis sur l'énergie et avec une ministre
déléguée, j'ai pas eu le temps de
refaire les les quand vous a quand on
vous a emmené le chiffre, ça vous avait
froid dans le dos ?
Je réponds pas à cette question, je suis
désolé hein, mais
ça nous a fait froid dans le dos. Et
deuxième sujet, c'est donc les
partenariats que l'on conclut, hein.
Moi, j'ai lancé à Lance en 2022 le
partenariat sur les matières premières
critiques. Euh c'est ça qui a été à
l'origine de Critical Raw Matérial Act
européen, donc de toute la politique qui
a démarré de ou là, il faut quand même
qu'on se préoccupe de nos matériaux
critiques qui a
quelle année ça rapidement
? 22
ou sacrée clé de lecture perforante.
Moi je suis ministre en 2022. Je voilà
euh 2021 rapport Varin, c'est moi qui le
commande. 2020 dans le plan de relance
français il y a la question des
matériaux critiques. Donc nous 2020 2021
2022. Moi, je suis ministre à
l'industrie 2020. Euh et 2022 donc on
lance l'Europe sur le sujet. Ça se
traduit en critical rematérial act avec
trois piliers. Premier pilier, comment
on sécurise des partenariats avec un
certain nombre de pays. On a aujourd'hui
au niveau français 15 accords qu'il faut
qui sont plus ou moins gazeux. Enfin,
c'est-à-dire que vous en avez qui sont
très déclaration d'intention. Il y en a
d'autres qui sont un peu plus euh euh
enfin avec des gisements, des des
accords contractuels. Euh mais ça c'est
la politique euh diplomatique du de la
matière première qu'il faut absolument
continuer à développer.
Deè
axe
réutilisation recyclage.
Vous faites de la voltige aérienne ?
Non absolument pas.
Et troisème axe.
Et pourquoi je vous pose la question ?
Parce que
on dirait on dirait que vous déroulez
avec vos mains un programme de voltige
aérienne.
Non mais je suis originaire de Marseille
donc on a un peu c'est un mélange je dis
marseillais. Euh et 3e 3e axe, c'est euh
le le fait de regarder si nous on a au
niveau européen en intégrant l'outre mer
euh quelles sont nos ressources et
comment on peut les utiliser et les
remettre et les remettre au travail.
Donc l'inventaire
euh qu'on a lancé avec le BRGM sur la
France et l'Autreem et euh le même
regard qu'on porte au niveau du
territoire européen et avec euh un
intérêt particulier pour des pays non UE
mais qui euh ont des ressources
importantes. Je pense à la Norvège, on a
signé un accord mardi avec la ministre
norvégienne et
euh tout tout minéraux
et et la Serbie.
Euh donc ça c'est la ça c'est la vision.
Encore une fois, je dis pas qu'elle est
facile à exécuter, mais elle existe,
elle se déroule. Moi, j'adorerais qu'on
aille plus vite, qu'on soit euh plus euh
sur la bête tout le temps. Euh mais euh
je pense que dans les pays européens que
je fréquente, on est probablement
ceux qui sont pas très loin d'avoir la
vision la plus la plus construite et
surtout qui ont à peu près réussi à
enlever la chappe d'idéologie autour de
la politique énergétique. parce que si
vous prenez l'Allemagne, il y a quand
même ce refus d'obstacle sur le
nucléaire. Et puis il y a cette espèce
de
de stratégie qui a consisté à remplacer
le mot gaz par le mot hydrogène pour la
rendre
bable.
Bable exactement sauf que ça marche pas.
Enfin, je truc n'existe pas. Bah parce
que on
pas les platinoïdes.
Voilà parce que on n pas ce qu'il faut.
l'hydrogène vert, ça coûte quand même un
bras et les quantités astronomiques
qu'il faudrait développer pour répondre
à la demande sont dingue. Et puis je
veux dire, il y a un sujet physique que
quand vous produisez l'hydrogène sur
base électrique, bah les rendements sont
quand même pas terribles. Donc nous, on
a investi par exemple dans Genvia qui
aujourd'hui a l'air aussi d'être d'un
point de vue innovation quelque chose
d'assez solide. Ça avance bien pour le
moment. Les premiers volumes de
production sont rendez-vous plutôt
meilleurs en terme de rendement. Si
réussissent, c'est super. Mais on est
quand même dans une zone d'incertitude
et moi je peux pas enfin je serai
l'Allemagne, je ne fondrai pas toute ma
politique climatique et énergétique sur
une espèce de de fantasme. Et c'est un
peu ce qu'on fait. Est-ce que la France
peut dire à l'Allemagne tu "Tu es
devenue complètement schizophrène,
complètement timbré, on va te laisser
jouer toute seule et puis si tu nous
embêtes, on va te couper le courant ?"
Alors, c'est quelque chose qui nous a
traversé l'esprit et euh qui a été qu'on
a commencé à apporter au niveau de
l'alliance. Alors, en tout bien tout
honneur puisque nous sommes dans des
diplomates, mais enfin, il faut savoir
lire ce que disent les diplomates dans
les salles de négociation.
Un bon coup de boule de diplomates, ça
passe.
Vous avez vu la déclaration des
Babouches récemment ? et Babouche,
vice-première ministre suédoise,
co-leader de l'Alliance du nucléaire,
ministre de l'énergie et de l'industrie
suédoise
suédoise. Euh et ben
on peut passer un petit bonjour ? On
passe le bonjour à l'ambassadrice de
Suède en Allemagne qui était aussi
ambassadrice de Suède en France juste
avant et comme je sais qu'elle écoute,
on lui passe le coucou. et ben on lui
dit bonjour et elle a à une vice premier
ministre absolument formidable qui a dit
au dernier conseil des ministres Robert
Linergy euh I have been euh Sweden have
been a good little girl euh mais en gros
maintenant ça suffit maintenant ça
suffit
français ça donne quoi parce que vous
avez le
c'est une gentille petite on a été
toujours la gentille petite fille on a
tout fait bien on a toujours été le bon
élève mais maintenant ça suffit et elle
le dit clairement dans sa déclaration
vous savez on a un doorstep Donc une
déclaration sur à l'arrivée et ensuite
elle l'a dit en salle. Voilà. Et c'est
dans le droit fil de ce que moi je
portais en octobre et en décembre 2023
où je dis en fait on veut une énergie
qui soit l'eau carbone. Donc l'eau
carbone c'est
on s'enfin peu importe la techno, on est
agnostique mais ça peut être du
renouvelable, ça peut être du nucléaire,
c'est la géothermie. Moi je l'eau
carbone. Euh il faut que ce soit
dispatchable. Donc pilotable et il faut
que ce soit affordable sinon ça marche
pas. Et l'énergie c'est pas que
l'électricité.
Euh affordable c'est-à-dire un quel coût
?
C'est-à-dire au coût le plus compétitif
possible.
C'est combien ?
Il faudrait converger probablement.
Enfin moi je je serais euh
je renverserai à chaque fois. Euh ce que
je propose aujourd'hui euh puisqu'on a
une mission à l'vituo sur euh les
énergies renouvelables et les soutiens
publics aux énergie renouvelable qui a
été initié euh par euh le premier
ministre et euh je leur ai fait une note
de proposition euh mais qu'on avait
commencé à mettre en œuvre, c'était euh
l'idée de faire plutôt que de faire
technologie par technologie, de
reprendre les plus compétitifs
technologie par technologie, de le faire
à l'envers et de dire qu'est-ce que vous
sortez à 50 € ? Qu'est-ce que vous
sortez à 60 € du MWh ? Qu'est-ce que
vous sortez quand je dis à 50 60 et
cetera, c'est coût du pilotage et coût
de raccordement intégré. Le PV, le
photovoltaïque chez Oriseo, ça sort à 55
€ pilotage et raccordement intégré.
Euh par contre, vous avez des projets
photovoltaïques qui peuvent sortir à 250
€
et ça c'est pas raisonnable. Et en fait
la vraie question qu'il faut se poser,
c'est comment dans chaque technologie on
obtient le meilleur et les énergies
renouvelables peuvent être pilotable. Il
faut d'abord définir ce qu'est la
pilotabilité. Est-ce que ce n'est pas
simplement les phases ? Il y a deux
choses. Il y a effectivement tenir les
variations de tension. Ça c'est un
cahier des charges. Les Français ont
fait la preuve au moment de l'incident
en Espagne qui tenait ça et on a été le
coupe-feu. On a réussi à gérer la crise.
Heureusement qu'on était là pour le
reste de l'Europe et qu' RTE était là
parce que nous on a les quand même un
haut niveau de sécurité sur notre réseau
et les Espagnols ont pas tenu leur
cahier des charges. Ils ont pas respecté
leur cahier des charges. C'est ce qui
est maintenant clairement établi dans le
rapport qui vient d'être publié sur le
blackout espagnol. Et le deuxième
élément, c'est comment vous êtes capable
de déplacer de la production pour la
restituer au moment où vous faites des
pics de consommation. Et déplacer de la
production, c'est pas forcément le
déplacer d'une semaine. En réalité,
parfois le déplacer de quelques minutes
ou de quelques heures. Si vous le
déplacer 2h, donc si vous avez juste une
un buffer de 2h, donc un stockage de 2h
euh ou que vous acceptez dans votre
modèle économique de vous effacer, donc
vous n'êtes pas porteur mais à minima
vous vous effacez, vous déstabilisez pas
le réseau, c'est OK. Donc il faut
définir ce qu'est cette pilotabilité et
les énergies renouvelables savent le
faire. C'est quoi ma question ?
Ça incrémente euh ça incrémente euh leur
coût. J'ai perdu euh la question. Ben je
Madame ma ministre, c'est quoi votre clé
de lecture pour l'industrie, l'énergie,
la géopolitique ? La clé de lecture
ultime,
ce qui vous permet de
la clé de lecture ultime, c'est la
France robuste.
Attends, je j'explique.
On a
euh avec les économies mondialisées,
privilégier la performance et le prix le
plus bas et l'optimisation absolue.
Ça ça marche quand on est dans un pack
beau qui trace sa route et d'autres
avec de l'essence gratuite
qui non pas avec de l'essence gratuite
avec de l'essence qui coûte cher
simplement on va prendre le meilleur la
meilleure essence là où c'est le moins
cher puis le meilleur
le meilleur bateau, la meilleure bouée,
le meilleur siège du capitaine et
cetera. On considère que la logistique
est une commodity sécurisée, que ça
marche tout le temps et on considère que
les gars n'existent pas. Bon, c'est très
sympa mais si on a voulait la preuve que
c'est terminé, la crise de Couvin nous
l'a montré et on a eu une deuxème lame
avec euh l'Ukraine et une trè lame
aujourd'hui avec euh l'Iran.
Qu'est-ce que ça nous a
la France robuste ? La France robuste,
c'est de dire que tu as ton plan A, tu
as ton plan A, tu as ton plan B, tu as
ton plan C. C'est-à-dire que tu acceptes
de payer un peu plus cher,
mais tu as face à chaque risque des
plans B et des plans C. Alors, je mets
une faille spatiotemporelle dans cette
discussion là.
Mon dieu.
D'accord.
On va prendre
C'est oliviarement hein. Je veux dire,
c'est pas un truc que j'ai sorti de ma
tête et qui a un gimic pour la
communication. Un truc étayé par un
chercheur du CNRS.
D'accord. Il y en a beaucoup qui
cherchent, des fois ils trouvent jamais.
Ouais. Mais moi je trouve que ça marche
assez bien en fait. Donc
ça marche à l'entreprise, ça marche sur
un pays.
D'accord.
On prend une faille spatiotemporelle. la
crise du Covid, toutes ces crises
d'Ukraine,
qu'est-ce que ça a montré ? Ça a montré
que la robustesse pour la crise du
Covid, ça se terminait sur les tarmac je
ça montrait que quand on avait optimisé
à mort les chaînes de production et les
chaînes d'approvisionnement, vous avez
un PET dans la chaîne et c'est la
désorganisation totale.
Les seuls qui étaient organisés pendant
le Covid, c'était qui ? Vous avez le
droit qu'à un seul essai
qui était organisé pendant le Covid,
qui était prêt, robuste, qui a d'une
façon froide, discipliné de qualité
militaire.
Ça m'a pas sauté aux yeux hein.
Alors qui ?
He ça m'a pas sauté aux yeux d'avoir un
pays. Alors dites-moi EDF.
Ah oui, d'accord. Vous pensiez à une
entreprise en particulier ?
Se qui ne ressemblait pas à un canard
sans tête, c'était EDF.
Alors je partage pas, il y avait pas mal
de boîtes industrielles qui était ou
quand vous gérez un réacteur nucléaire,
vous avez intérêt à agir d'une façon
mais EDF était très bon mais on avait
des boîtes industrielles qui étaient
ben euh
dans la chimie
non en fait beaucoup de boîtes qui
étaient en Chine toutes les boîtes qui
étaient en Chine en sous-traitance
automobile et cetera, les Vololi et
cetera, elles se sont adoptées super
rapidement parce qu'elles avaient une
avance de phase sur la crise.
Donc qu'est-ce que
Et les boîtes industrielles nativement
se sont plus vite adaptées que d'autres
et celles aussi qui ont été assez
remarquables, pourtant c'est pas des
gentils, mais c'est peut-être pour ça
aussi, c'est la grande distribution.
Ils sont
la grande distribution. Euh moi quand le
président de la République me demande
euh de euh alors qu'on manquait de
masque, je pense que c'est apparu, il
annonce zéro.
Oui, mais c'est ce que je vous dis.
C'est-à-dire, il faut passer
l'optimisation, c'est-à-dire tout est
open et on a toujours les chaînes
d'approvisionnement qui fonctionnent à
euh qu'est-ce qui se passe et comment on
prévoit euh les plans B et les plans C
en cas de et on fait une liste de
risque. Euh demain, les gafames
s'arrêtent pendant 48 heures, il se
passe quoi ? Demain, il y a une crise en
au Moyen-Orient, cit un peu ce que
j'avais porté moi. Il se passe quoi
demain ? Enfin, voilà, vous faites votre
truc et vous vous dites "C'est quoi les
plans B dépenser et on a pas mal
progressé par rapport à ça.
Quand madame ma ministre arrive dans son
ministère, dans mon ministère,
ouais.
Madame ma ministre qui découvre bah ils
sont un peu en short et bretelles les
gars, il y a pas de masque. Le protocole
sanitaire c'est des affiches à 4 Charles
de Gaulle correspondance direct one.
C'est un petit peu vamos à la playa. Non
non euh non. Alors
euh en 2000û parce que là si vous
commencez pardon à votre phrase, je
derrière.
Euh non mais j'explique. En 2000, moi
j'ai j'étais donc à la PHP entre 2003 et
2006.
Euh entre 2003 et 2006, on a eu un
épisode de Gripe Avière qui avait
commencé à prendre des proportions
importantes. Si vous vous souvenez bien,
Roseline Bachelou était ministre de la
santé. On a commencé à faire exactement
et nous on stockait du des on a stocké
des stocks de Tamifou. ça nous coûtait
cher, c'était du BFR et tout. On était
en première ligne. Euh et je me rappelle
qu'à l'époque le directeur de la
politique médicale Didier Houssin qui de
la PHP m'avait dit "En fait la question
n'est pas de savoir si cette crise va
arriver, la question est de savoir quand
cette crise va arriver et je peux te
dire que ça arrivera dans les 20 ans qui
viennent." Donc cette connaissance là,
elle était présente et des plans
existent.
Ce qui est assez intéressant et c'est
l'histoire des masques en particulier,
c'est que le coût de la robustesse et
donc le coût du plan d'avoir des stocks,
de passer vérifier que les stocks sont
en état, de les renouveler au fil de
l'eau, au fur et à mesure le risque par
essence éloigné. On a démonté ça pour
des raisons de
des raisons de de bonne gestion
budgétaire. Et rappelez-vous euh comment
euh Rosmin Bachelot s'était fait moquer
par euh les journalistes, les
commentateurs, les opposition. Elle
avait juste raison 20 ans trop tôt. Et
c'est ça un des points importants, c'est
que nous nous sommes dans une
démocratie. Et dans une démocratie,
on a pas tout à fait la façon la même
façon de tenir les les les caps et on a
la place à des gens qui vont contredire
et c'est à la fois extrêmement fort en
terme de liberté publique et je remets
pas du tout en cause les démocraties
mais ça fait partie du système d'avoir
ces variations et c'est un des prix à
payer et un des sujets que nous avons à
encoder aujourd'hui c'est comment
effectivement on arrive à garder de la
constance dans le temps. Moi quand je
vais en Arabie Saoudite pour
avec ou sans le voile ?
Sans le voile. Quand je vais en Arabie
Saoudite pour
le sommet des artifications,
vous essayez de serrer des mains là-bas,
aucun problème. Strictement aucun
problème. Euh et j'assiste à un dîner
avec le président de la République et
son homologue
MBS.
Il il réfléchit comme s'il est là
toujours en 2050. La question pour ceux
qui savent pas,
la question ne se pose pas dans sa tête
de savoir s'il sera là ou pas en 2050.
Pour lui, c'est une évidence
et nous notre temps de réflex notre je
dirais même durée de vie, notre date
limite de consommation en tant que
politique est beaucoup plus resserrée.
C'est 5 ans quand ça se passe bien.
Moi mes derniers mandats de ministre,
j'ai eu une durée moyenne. Alors, je
suis restée 7 ans mais j'ai eu des
durées moyennes qui étaient plus proches
de 7 mois que de 2 ans. On reparlera de
comment s'emparer d'un
et donc ça c'est vachement important
dans la et comment une démocratie arrive
à cranter des politiques de t. Je pense
que c'est ça le le vrai challenge tout
en gardant cette capacité à avoir de la
critique, à avoir de la liberté, à avoir
euh des opinions qui discutent, des gens
qui racontent tout et n'importe quoi et
à l'accepter.
Revenons à ma faille espatiotemporelle.
Donc sur votre faille spatiotemporelle
Ouais,
je suis dure.
Non, pas encore.
Mais sur votre faille spati. Euh non, je
veux pas. Sur votre faille
spatiotemporelle.
Euh oui, vous avez raison. On arrive, on
a pas de masque parce que les stocks ont
pas été entretenus et que et cetera et
euh par contre, on a des plans blancs
dans les hôpitaux. Ça, j'ai donné, je
sais que ça existe et je peux vous dire
qu'on s'est déménagé très vite dans les
hôpitaux et passé en mode hôpital de
campagne. Moi, je l'ai fait en 2003 au
moment de la canicule et on a vraiment
répété ces exercices là. Pour le coup,
ça ça existe. On est capable euh de euh
de gérer euh avec euh les euh avec les
distributeurs, avec euh les
énergéticiens parce qu'on tous les jours
on avait euh des euh des points de
gestion et et en fait nos gammes se sont
pas si mal passées que ça. Comment
approvisionner
en énergie ? Comment approvisionner en
alimentation ? Comment gérer la
circulation des professions absolument
essentielles ? Comment protéger les les
les professions essentielles ? Ça s'est
déroulé. Et quand moi je demande euh je
suis en charge de du déconfinement le 11
mai et que on annonce ça je sais plus
début avril et qu'on a quelques semaines
pour trouver des millions de masques.
Bah la solution que je trouve c'est
d'aller voir les meilleurs dans en
France pour aller sourcer
une marchandise assez simple à sourcer.
Enfin je veux dire assez pas pas
complexe pas sophistiqué. C'est ça que
je veux dire. Pas sophistiqué. Et c'est
la grande distribution. La grande
distribution en 4 semaines en étant les
mettant un peu en compétition avec de
l'émulation me sort 100 millions de
masques comme ça et et ils sont capables
de les fournir à tous les Français sur
le territoire. Donc oui, on est capable
de fonctionner y compris dans
l'administration y compris dans des
ministères en mode crise avec une très
grande efficacité. Ce que je trouve un
peu dommage, c'est que cette
Vous avez déjà essayé de vendre une
voiture ?
Euh jamais, j'ai une trépiètre
commercial.
Ah bah là là, vous me vendez bien le
truc.
Non mais parce que ça s'est passé comme
ça.
Ça s'est passé comme ça. Alors moi ça
s'est passé différemment. Moi, j'ai vu
CBTI
raconter n'importe quoi. N'importe quoi.
Moi, je sais pas mettre le masque. En
plus, le masque ça sert à rien. Et puis
si les pharmaciens ils vendent des
masques, c'est 10000 € d'amende. Moi,
j'ai vu surtout une stratégie. Vous avez
envoyé au CASPIP la porte-parole pour
raconter n'importe quoi. Toutes les
professions médicales
et on connaît bien la chose dans la
famille.
vous ont regardé comme si vous étiez des
extraterrestres
et ils sont dit ils nous prennent pour
des débiles. Alors le côté médecin, ils
avaient compris dès le départ que vous
étiez en stratégie de panique et ils
vous ont laissé faire comme vous voulez
avec votre conseil de défense.
Ça c'est pas vrai. C'est les médecins
qui ont piloté énormément la crise. Moi,
je suis sur Attendez, moi j'ai j'ai un
souvenir assez précis. Je suis sur un
plateau début mars. J'ai à côté de moi.
C'était avant ou après que notre leader
charismatique président de BDE Emmanuel
Macron nous demander d'aller au théâtre
ou avant ?
Ça, j'ai plus du tout le souvenir. Alors
je vous rappelle le souvenir. Moi, je
vois mon leader charismatique président,
mon président à moi, de ma France à moi,
dire sa femme "Allez-y les gars, la vie
continue, on va au théâtre." Et genre 3
4 jours plus tard, tout le monde
confiné. Elle est où la moelle épinière
là-dedans ?
Alors ça c'est là
moi j'ai mon parrain feu mon parin qui
était plus jeune professeur en médecine
en maladie infectieuse et tropicale
premier dans la recherche de la maladie
de l'ime. Pas une petite merde. Ouais je
vous dirai ça plus tard. Éric je son
petit prénom.
Je vois mon leader charismatique me
balancer ça alors que nous on avait de
l'information provenant de Chine depuis
le mois de décembre avec des gars de la
tech sur place àan nous dire ou là là ça
craint ça craint du boudin
et nous on voit notre leader
charismatique Emmanuel 1er nous dire
vous inquiétez pas les gars on y va
alors moi je vais vous donner deux
points de deux choses que j'ai
non la première chose que vous allez me
donner c'est vous en tant que ministre
quand vous voyez la tête
penser comme ça et que derrière vous
avez des informations complètement à
l'opposé
et que vous envoyez au cas pip si bête,
elle est où la cohérence ? La question
que je me pose, c'est est-ce que ça fait
ça fait faire des économies de prendre
les Français pour des cons ?
Non, certainement pas. C'est en règle
générale, vous payez l'addition cash.
Euh alors moi je je vais vous dire ce
qu'on a parce que moi j'ai je vous dis
début mars sur un plateau de télévision
un pont des maladies infectieuses et des
maladies c'est pour ça que je vous
posais mais c'est pas le même pas le
même prénom qui m'ex et je lui dis et je
lui dis et je lui dis au moment de la
pause euh publicitaire. Bon mais alors
vous en pensez quoi vous euh un gars de
la PHP avec qui j'avais travaillé des
années avant ? Vous en pensez quoi vous
? Il me répond c'est une gripette.
C'est une gripette. Et l'OMS
nous avait communiqué donc début du mois
de de février, on nous dit c'est
peut-être aéroporté
et je sais plus. Donc le en gros
aéroporté ça veut dire masque. Euh le
virus se transmet dans l'atmosphère. Ce
qui était effectivement
sur le avec radence sur les surfaces.
Voilà. ce qui était effectivement assez
avéré. Et euh à un moment, on a une
communication euh de l'OMC piloté par la
Chine euh qui nous dit "Non, non,
finalement c'est pas reportter."
Donc moi, j'ai jamais refait le fil. Ce
que je sais c'est qu'Anè Busin
non mais chargez pas sur la Non non non
je me décharge surtout pas parce que je
je veux le dire et elle me dit fin
janvier
quand elle essayé d'appeler Emmanuel
Macron c'est
il y a un truc qui se passe et je suis
très inquiète à Tati elle me le dit et
elle se prend un carteron de médecin
pardon d'être de faire un peu de
féminisme à deux balles homme féminisme
à de balles blanc très sur deux qui dit
"Ouais, attends, elle est spécialiste de
la leucémie chez les enfants, ça va
bien, on les connaît rien. Bien sûr,
c'est pas du tout ça." Donc c'est ça
aussi dans la dans le processus de
décision qui s'arrête 2 minutes.
C'est c'est très intéressant ce que vous
me racontez.
Euh 17 mars 2020, 2 jours après le
premier tour des élections municipales,
Agnè Busin affirmeront avoir alerté
l'exécutif de la gravité du CO.
Ouais.
OK.
C'est vrai, elle l'a fait.
Enfin, moi je l'ai entendu.
Nous, on a eu son cabinet au téléphone
juste à ce même moment là. Ils nous ont
pris pour des extraterrestres. On
voulait la faire venir et déjà ils
étaient sous l'eau, ils étaient déjà en
train de boire la tasse. Bon,
vous êtes un service d'état. Certes,
vous connaissez peut-être Pierre Paul
Jacques Toubibines
de renseignement pour vous aider à à
réfléchir.
Nous, on a développé notre propre
service de renseignement, c'est-à-dire
qu'on a capacité d'ubiquité.
Allez, en une heure, on peut se projeter
à peu près n'importe quel pays dans le
monde, avoir des yeux et des horaires
quelque part. On avait des gars en
Chine, des gars nous, des mecs un peu
tête brûlé qui vont aller voir les
checkpoints, qui vont essayer de passer
les checkpoints la nuit, des mecs qui
essayent d'aller dans les quartiers
pauvres pour savoir comment les Chinois
il fermaient les portes, ils soudaient
les portes, juste l'espace d'un on les
voyait pulvériser en haut en en long, en
large enant travers avec des camions
dans les roues, dans les rues, des mecs
qui se faisaient pulvériser à la sortie
des avions, les analyses d'eau, on avait
ça. Vous vous avez pas de service de
renseignement à la tête de l'État ?
Alors, on a des services, on a des
grandes oreilles. Jordi, jeudi euh
l'ambassadeur de France euh en Chine,
jeudi peut-être.
Ouais. Et
euh il vous faire remonter le truc le 24
ou le le 29 décembre. Euh
oui, ça il y a eu une alerte
de coupe de champagne.
Non non, le les le truc coupe de
champagne, c'est quand même pas la plus
pratiquée dans les ministères hein,
contrairement. Non, c'est chard
peut-être.
encore moins
c'est plutôt le sandwich entre deux
portes.
Donc j'ai on a vu comment vous avez géré
la crise Covid. On a trouvé ça si on
devait mettre une note, on aurait mis 4/
20 plus que passable. Mais les
encouragements parce queon les a vu
s'agiter et envoyer si bête au CASPI
Pip.
Quand vous me présentez ça, on a essayé,
on a claqué des doigts, les industriels.
Non, non, mais moi alors
je je le dis parce que moi cette crise
là,
je l'ai vécu en plus de manière très
enfin pas très traumatisante, mais moi
si vous voulez, c'était mes copains qui
étaient en première ligne à la PHP.
Ils ont choisi leur nom. Donc oui oui
mais euh moi je les avais au téléphone
euh parce que justement je n'ai aux
informations pour et je peux vous dire
euh le procès en incompéten et en
négligence en fait c'est pas la réalité.
Quand vous avez quand vous avez quand
vous avez une infecteiologue qui fait
tous les plateaux télé et qui a 25
bagouses et qui est infecteiologue qui a
mis sa blouche blanche de pour passer
devant les caméras, nous on a toujours
appris que les médecins qui portaient
des bagues dans les services
d'infecteiologie, c'est les mecs qui
avaient rien à enin
infectionologie.
Mais c'est pas 25 bagou, c'est le type
qui a un index pummède comme ça et qui
est un des spécialistes des maladies
infectieuses en France. Et à un moment
quand vous êtes euh comme moi administr
enfin je veux dire sans compétences
spécifiques médicales ou que euh on vous
renvoie effectivement euh euh que bah
c'est pas sa spécialité donc elle sait
moins bien que nous, bah vous avez cette
dimension là. Et c'est vachement facile
rétrospectivement
de euh faire le scénario euh du Covid.
Moi, je me suis retrouvée face euh à la
Cour de justice de la République comme
témoin. Comme témoin. Et euh les gars me
disent, "Vous dites euh début mars que
euh on n' pas besoin de de masque, ce
qui est effectivement, j'ai dit, en
communication parce que c'est les
éléments que j'avais à date et c'était
ma connaissance du sujet à moi ministre,
non médecin et lisant les
recommandations qu'on m'a donné. et vous
dites en mai que il faut des masques. Et
je dis et il me dit qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé entre les deux dates ? Je lui
réponds 30000 morts. Est-ce que ça vous
va comme réponse ? Je veux dire c'est
tellement facile rétrospectivement
de refaire le le match. Et c'est ce que
j'ai fait pendant des années quand
j'étais en dehors de la politique. Et à
un moment en fait et c'est pour ça que
je suis rentrée enfin c'est pour ça
qu'au moment où on m'a mis le truc en
main, j'ai dit "OK, je prends pour voir
pour voir si si on sait faire." Et en
fait votre niveau d'information alors
peut-être il faudrait améliorer
justement cette dimension d'intelligence
économique et et d'intelligence tout
court d'ailleurs parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui là ça ressemble plus à de
l'économie de l'intelligence plutôt
qu'autre chose. Je sais pas mais ce qui
est clair c'est que euh ce qu'on a fait
nous en tant que gouvernement on l'a
fait en sincérité sur la base des
éléments dont on disposait et avec
pourquoi avoir fait classer conseil de
défense secret défense
pourquoi avoir fait changer
la mise au secret des réunions
concernant le covid et en plus Sarkozy
avait mis le secret défense de 100 à 150
ans juste avant donc pourquoi avoir
décrété
Mais
le secret défense pour la gestion du
Covid.
Mais en fait toutes les décisions qui
ont été prises sur le Covid, elles
avaient une traduction publique. C'estàd
qu'à partir du moment vous avez Non mais
si vous avez une
la traduction avec Sibet la pauvre.
Non non non, je parle pas de
communication là. C'est il y a pas une
décision dans un pays comme la France
qui ne passe pas sous les fourches
codines de notre état de droit. Donc on
a créé une espèce de de fantasme autour
des conseils de défense. Moi, j'en ai
fait des conseils de défense. Conseils
de défense, c'est une réunion de
travail. C'est une réunion de travail.
Il y a machin qui dit ça, il y a truc
qui dit ça. Il y a Delfressi, il y a
Verran, il y a
même eu Roseline qui revenait, reprenait
du service un peu avec la vision de la
précédente crise qu'elle avait qu'elle
avait géré.
on prend des décisions et après elles se
traduisent, c'est-à-dire que soit elles
se traduisent par une proposition de loi
en urgence pour faire telle et telle
chose, soit par un décret qui doit être
soumis à telle et telle consultation,
soit par un protocole qui est diffusé.
Tout ça est parfaitement public. Madame
ministre,
quand vous voyez notre leader
charismatique Solaire Emmanuel Macron
aller au théâtre et ensuite décréter le
confinement, vous êtes maman ou pas
maman ? Et je suis maman de trois plus
un enfants, donc j'en ai quatre au total
là.
Quatre au total. Euh quand vous voyez
une moelle épinière aussi euh pas
droite,
ouais mais
c'est ça pose problème.
Non, ça c'est votre version des choses
et c'est pas la mienne et c'est pas mon
vécu. Et après, je comprends que vous
soyez pas d'accord avec ça mais c'est
pas mon vécu.
Accordonsnous sur ce désaccord.
On va pas refaire la crise du Covid
toute la journée. On va refaire
maintenant la crise énergétique
ukrainienne.
OK.
Donc vous voyez Popov prier Poutine
numéro 1 commencer à masser des troupes.
C'était censé être un exercice parce que
nos militaires avaient dit vous
inquiétez pas, ils vont pas taper parce
que comme ils ont pas les hôpitaux de
campagne, ils vont pas
C'est pas ce qu'on a dit. Nous, on dit
depuis janvier, il y a un risque. On
nous accuse même d'utiliser cette menace
janvier 2024.
On nous accuse
euh 2022 pardon. Janvier 2022. Vous
étiez encore bien en retard. Bah en tout
cas, quand le président le dit
publiquement, on l'accuse de vouloir
utiliser cette menace pour écraser la
campagne présidentielle et il se prend
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et Marine Le Pen
expliquant que ça n'existe pas, vous
n'avez rien compris, c'est scandaleux et
c'est un propos politique.
C'est vous dire comme c'est pas si
simple en fait 2022 janvier 2022
janvier, ça a commencé quoi ? Au mois de
février.
24 février ?
Ouais. Euh donc janvier. OK. Nous, on a
commencé à anticiper la guerre avec les
popof à partir de 2015 2016.
Je pense que les services avaient des
des informations dans ce sens bien avant
janvier 2022. Évidemment, ils font quoi
les services ? Ils sont pas écoutés, ils
font pas remonter les notes. Comment ça
se passe ? Euh je que ce risque-là
existe. Je veux pas encore une fois moi
j'ai pas été ministre de la défense. Il
y a plein d'éléments auxquels je n'avais
pas accéindustrie.
Pour moi, le ministre de la défense, je
je demande à tous nos nos amis
militaires qui peuvent nous suivre et à
tous les généraux qu'on a pu recevoir,
ministre de la défense, c'est ministre,
c'est technicien de surface des
conneries des politiciens. C'estd que en
gros, on l'a dit ici, un général Wat
étoile, on lui a dit "Bon, vous faites
le ménage des conneries des politiciens,
c'est close vz la politique, la guerre,
l'extension de la politique.
Comment ça se fait que nous la France,
on est censé être la troisème voix, la
voix d'apaisement, faire dialoguer les
peuples, essayer de
mettre un peu de
On est les derniers hein, avoir eu les
contacts avec Poutine.
Oui. Mais c'est vous avez vu le contact.
Attendez,
on est les derniers à l'avoir et et on
est les seuls à avoir toujours dit en
fait il faut garder une ligne
diplomatique. Quoi qu'on
pense juste terminer ministre de
l'industrie personne.
Ministre de l'industrie, c'est c'est
c'est hématologue c'est c'est c'est
celui qui a le sang qui vacculariser le
tissu du pays. Oui, vous êtes d'accord
avec moi ?
Oui.
C'est le ministère le plus important.
C'est un ministère important parmi
d'autres. Non, l'éducation nationale,
c'est hyper important.
La santé, c'est hyper important. Les
armées, c'est hyper important. Les
affaires étrangères, c'est hyper
important. C'est important. Ils ont pas
l'air de de comprendre bien leur place
de leur ministère. Et depuis, comment il
s'appelait ? Le dormeur du quai là, ça
va me revenir.
Revenons, revenons au ministre de
l'industrie,
le sang de la France. Parce que si vous
avez pas de sang, votre système éducatif
vous essayez dessus. Si vous avez pas de
sang, votre système de santé, vous
essayez dessus. Bon, quand vous voyez
que votre ministère, c'est-à-dire vos
oilles consommatrices d'énergie pour
pouvoir produire,
elles vont se retrouver sans gaz, sans
pétrole, sans titane.
Ça vous fait quoi ? Vous appelez la
DGSion en leur disant bon, scénario 1,
scénario 2, scénario 3. Vous appelez le
Kedoré en leur disant "Bon les gars,
comment ça se passe ?" Vous appelez la
DRM, ceux qui ont pas vu venir le coup
parce qu'il y avait pas les poches de
sang qui étaient derrière la ligne de
front. Vous vous réagissez comment quand
vous voyez le truc débarqué ?
24 février, moi je suis à Bruxelles. On
est en conseil des ministres de
l'énergie.
On nous Ouais, tout à fait.
Comment elle s'appelle l'histienne à
Bruxelles là qui a dégagé la la grande
blonde qui a l'air un peu pas très futée
là qui nous a dit "C'est une guerre
énergétique mais vous inquiétez pas, il
y a un plan B."
Vous la voyez ? Vous voyez ? Elle elle
est pas très futée elle. Non,
moi je me fais pas de d'ennemis chez les
européens, j'ai d'autres raisons d'en
faire. Donc
on est d'accord.
Mais non, donc 24 février, on nous dit
il y a les grandes personnes qui vont
prendre la salle parce qu'il se passe un
truc important en ce moment. Donc vous
êtes privé de faire votre conseil très
rapidement. Effectivement, on plie notre
conseil en en 2 heures dans une ambiance
de de fin du monde et particulièrement
pour tous les ministres qui viennent du
bloc de l'Est hein, parce que beaucoup
sont nés euh sous l'air soviétique.
Je peux vous dire que
March Sevkovic qui est
le commissaire européen
Slovaque,
les ministres polonais, roumains,
c'est un moment très violent pour eux.
Ils sont blem et effectivement
son bl pourquoi ? Parce qu'ils savent la
dégelée qu'ils vont se prendre.
Parce que non, je je plus profond que
ça. C'est parce que la la menace russe
pour eux, c'est quelque chose de
sensible. C'est un vécu, c'est une
histoire familiale. La menace russe pour
nous, c'est une abstraction.
Je dire
moi je suis pas née sous l'air
soviétique. Moi j'ai pas eu à choisir au
moment de la chute du mur de Berlin
entre la nationalité slovaque et la
nationalité tchèque et et des collègues
comme ça, j'en avais plein qui
d'ailleurs me racontent leur histoire à
ce moment-là. C'était assez assez
émouvant, assez et je peux c'est là où
vous dites que l'Europe c'est c'est
quand même un vrai truc et que avec tous
ces défauts, c'est aussi euh une
formidable capacité à rassembler 450
millions de personnes qui sont en
réalité, désolé, parmi les plus formés,
parmi les plus riches avec l'innovation
qui est peut-être pas aussi
active que la Chine, mais quand même il
y a beaucoup de choses qu'on vient nous
chercher, donc on doit pas être si
mauvais que ça dans les labos
d'innovation et et donc on est quelque
chose et moi je crois profondément à ça.
Donc je reviens et on se met en mode
crise, c'est-à-dire que nous ministres
de l'énergie, on s'est réuni tous les
mois et on a passé je pense en 6 mois
autant de textes probablement
que on en a passé en 20 ans euh sous mon
pilotage puis sous le pilotage du Tchè
puis sous le pilotage de l'Espagnol puis
la Suédoise, la fameuse suédoise. Et
effectivement,
c'est là où on a commencé à ça m'aid
Faut jamais se comparer au derniers de
la classe qui vaut jamais rien arriver.
Nous, on est les Français.
Ouais.
On a quand même quand même montrer le
chemin. Vous vous êtes ministre
française, vous êtes à Bruxelles, vous
voyez Popov débarquer en Ukraine ?
Ouais.
Vous êtes surprise ?
Non, parce qu'on l'avait euh
au mois de janvier,
on l'avait quand même un peu près.
Là, vous dites quoi ? Vous êtes premier
réflexe, vous vous dites "OK, il va
commencer à nous ennuyer, il va nous
couper le gaz, il va nous couper le
pétrole, même si ça lui rapporte du
pognon, il peut nous avoir avec un un
levier."
Là, je pense Nordstream.
Donc Nordstream tout de suite.
Ouais.
Pourquoi Nordstream ? parce que c'est
une infrastructure dimensionnante et que
c'est facile à piloter.
Et vous connaissiez déjà
l'infrastructure, comment elle avait été
construite, qui l'avait financé, quel
Non, ça j'avais pas le l'historique.
Quel volume passait à travers.
Grosso modo euh je savais que c'était
suffisamment gros pour être un problème.
Non, c'était assez basique moi. C'est
euh qu'est-ce qui est le Quel est le
truc qui est le plus facile
à bloquer et qui nous coûte le plus de
points de vie ? Si je me mets à la place
de Poutine, c'est comme ça qu'il faut
raisonner. Et ben parce que vous
connaissez pas les Russes. Les Russes le
russe est procédurier comme dans Obélix
et Astérix. Vous imaginez pas la lenteur
administrative de de ce bousin. Ça ça
nous fait penser un peu à nous mais en
mode russe pas très agile. Revenons à
votre raisonnement à ce moment-là. Vous
êtes avec vos vos petits copains de
l'Europe.
Est-ce que vous avez une note des
services en disant voilà il va se passer
ça s'il nous bloque ? Il va se passer ça
s'il nous bloque ça, il va se passer ça
si on l'attaque là, il va se passer ça.
Non,
vous avez le premier réflexe, c'est
Nordstream tout de suite
toute seule comme une grande.
Non, c'est collectif.
Collectif
h c'est alors je sais pas mais c'est
dans les discussions de de
comment dire de café avant le démarrage
du conseil. Oui, c'est une
préoccupation.
Qui a sa voté Norstream ?
Euh
les Russes
et ben non.
Oui mais je si vous voulez moi ma
version c'est que c'est plus tolérus
encore une fois moi j'ai il y a une
partie des notes il y a une partie des
notes
c'est pour ça que je vous dis e parce
que j'ai pas la version sourcée. J'ai
pas triangulé cette information.
D'accord. Qui est-ce qui empêche
l'extradition d'Ukrainien en Allemagne ?
Dites-moi.
Les Polonais.
Ouais.
Stratford, ça vous parle ?
Non,
le sing tank américain 2015. Je vous
conseille l'analyse de son président.
C'était très bien. Revenons à vous.
Vous vous rappelez l'onienne, celle qui
a les grands cheveux blonds qui est
ministre de l'Europe de l'énergie
commissaire commissaire européenne.
Quand vous voyez cette personne là
s'exprimer,
vous dites "C'est Sibet
qu'on a envoyé au CASPIP.
Vous vous dites c'est une nana qui
comprend rien de rien. C'est une nana
qui a pas idée de l'intrication des
chaînes logistiques qu'on peut avoir
chez les popof et vous vous dites "Ma
pauvre petite Agnè, tu t'es mis dans une
merde noire. tu vas être obligé de de
gérer la crise du siècle.
Euh je me dis parce que là moi je suis
donc 24 février, moi je suis ministre de
l'industrie encore. Je passe à l'énergie
le 22 mai.
Les deux principaux ministères de
dingue.
Voilà. Et donc euh j'ai pas
l'estonienne, je la découvre quand je
passe à l'énergie encore à ce moment-là.
Euh moi j'ai Thierry Breton. Euh,
ça c'est comparable à l'estonienne.
Ah non non non, rien à voir. Non non,
c'est beaucoup plus sophistiqué et et
beaucoup plus
sensible justement aux enjeux
géopolitiques. Et pour le coup euh
sur pas mal de dossiers, il a été assez
euh euh
ouais très aidant et euh très capable de
faire bouger les lignes de la Commission
européenne vraiment. Euh et donc à ce
moment-là, moi je pense à mes petites
industries euh c'est-à-dire les gaz
intensifs
euh et puis euh on commence à passer en
revue tout ce qui est euh problème
d'approvisionnement et notamment le
titane
euh avec euh la
euh le évidemment les problèmes de
l'aéronautique
en première ligne.
On réunit, enfin moi je réunis Conseil
national de l'industrie, les conseils
stratégiques de filière, filière par
filière pour repérer quels étaient leur
stock alternative d'approvisionnement
contractuel, qu'est-ce qui existait,
qu'est-ce qui existait pas, quelles
étaient les routes, par où ça passait et
cetera. on regarde ce qu'on peut
éventuellement
euh augmenter euh ou où où on a des
stocks, où on peut passer. Le titane,
c'est assez complexe parce qu'on regarde
aussi les les possibilités de
relocalisation entre guillemets de
traitement. Donc le titane, il y a il y
a une phase avec une espèce de euh
comment de d'éponge de titane qui est en
fait un processus absolument odieux d'un
point de vue environnemental et et
chimique. Et je crois qu'il y a que un
pays qui le fait et là on se dit h la
route est très compliquée et ça c'est le
point nodal qui risque de bloquer tout
notre approvisionnement en titane. Et
donc on fait ça de manière systématique
et on a des plans de contingence qu'on
qu'on essaie de déployer mais vraiment
main dans la main avec les entreprises.
Moi j'ai pas la partie énergétique. La
partie énergétique est est au ministère
de la transition écologique venir après.
Euh et ça c'est qui est en fait le
ministère de l'équipement hein euh
Cologie un packaging mais c'est le
ministère de l'équipement et euh et donc
eux sécurisent enfin regardent tout ce
qui est production effectivement
essayent pareil de sécuriser, de se
représenter les enjeux. On va taper chez
nos copains norvégiens qui sont des gros
producteurs
de euh de gaz et qui ont un euh
un un
comment un pipeline qui Ouais. qui vient
chez nous. C'est assez heureux. et on
commence à regarder tout le renversement
des routes euh puisque théoriquement euh
le le
fonctionnement de l'approvisionnement
était d'est en ouest et on regarde
comment remonter tout de d'ouest en est.
Alors si je peux synthétis synthétiser
ça trivialement. Donc vous faites
l'inventaire avant de partir en camping
alors qu'on va se faire le K2. Vous
connaissez le K2 ?
Ouais, c'est un sommet de l'Himalaya.
Ouais. Donc là, je vous vois euh
m'énoncer euh
une pr une préparation de camping.
Ah non, c'est pas une préparation de
camping. Non, c'est très sérieux. On a
euh
Pourquoi ça a pas été fait ?
Comment ça ça a pas été fait ?
Ben pourquoi il y a pas quelqu'un qui va
venir vous voir, par exemple quelqu'un
des services qui a étudié la guerre
froide et les dynamiques de guerre
froide et qui vous dit voilà madame ma
ministre, il peut se passer ça, ça le
cas de dans 3 semaines. C'est-à-dire à
peu près ce qu'on vit en ce moment.
C'est des contraintes de guerre froide.
C'estd qu'ils vont s'amuser à nous
allumer des conflits à gauche et à
droite. Ils vont s'amuser à nous faire
des croques en jambes à gauche et à
droite. Nous, on va essayer de leur
faire des croques en jambes. Mais comme
on chose du 32, ça va être compliqué.
Donc, madame ma ministre, préparez-vous
sur ça. Faites une filière plus robuste
sur ça. Peut-être plus robuste sur ça,
peut-être plus robuste sur ça. Est-ce
qu'il y a quelqu'un qui vous qui est
venu vous voir ?
Mais en fait, on l'a construit ça. Moi,
j'ai effectivement pas eu.
Comment ça se fait que vous avez vous
avez été obligé de construire ça ? Mais
moi, j'ai pas les services qu'on
débarqué avec une note prête à l'emp euh
euh pardon. Mais alors pour le coup,
s'il y a un truc que j'ai appris en
étant ministre, faut pas leur faire
confiance.
Non, c'est pas ça. Ah,
ça va. Non,
c'est que les les gars qui connaissent
le mieux leur chaîne de production,
c'est quand même les industriels,
les gars qui ont le plus de
Vous êtes en train de me dire qu'il y a
pas un mec, une grande oreille, une
petite moustache qui se balade pour
notre état, qui connaît les filières de
logistique
touchy
et qui vous fait pas des petites fiches.
Il y a bien des Il y a bien des mecs de
la DGSE dans les salles de trading.
Il y a bien des mecs de la DGSE qui se
baladent dans les mines.
Oui, mais je reviens du
moi, j'espère
sur l'approvisionnement
en matière première. Vous avez nos
industriels qui ont des des stocks, des
contrats, des routes alternatives. Moi,
quand j'étais à la tête d'une entreprise
côté, je dire, j'étais dans les loisirs,
j'ai toute une partie de mon rapport
d'activité qui est le risque management.
Quels sont les risques que vous repérez
? Quels sont les euh les mesures de
contingement de contingent ? Mais euh si
enfin je veux dire si vous voulez, on va
pas faire une couche supplémentaire
par rapport à ce que font les
entreprises. On va pas faire le boulot à
la place des entreprises alors que c'est
elles qui sont compétentes pour le
faire. Il y a quelque chose d'un peu
paradoxal dans ça. C'est-à-dire qu'on
nous dit à la fois l'État se mêle de
tout, l'État est partout, euh l'État
fait des choses qui ne relèvent pas de
ses compétences. Nous, on a mis euh y
compris dans le en terme de de droits
financier l'obligation pour chaque
entreprise d'aller faire son risque
management et d'être capable d'avoir ses
mesures de mitigation. On a tout un
travail sur les plans de continuité euh
et moi j'avais des plans de continuité
en entreprise mais je fais pas
l'inspection des travaux fini sur la
plan de continuité de Dasso puisque
c'était avec Dasso qu'on discutait hein
très clairement bus et compagnie
bah oui il boss
ils bossent ils sont prêts.
OK je une parenthèse.
Non non mais je pense que c'est
vachement important parce que sinon là
on est en train de tout mélanger. C'est
pas le job d'un ministre de remplacer le
patron d'assaut il le fera mal.
On mélange pas du tout. H
on dit qu'un ministre doit être un
minimum affuté pour prendre un
ministère.
Donc, j'ouvre une parenthèse,
l'industrie bancaire parce que c'est une
industrie
tout à fait.
La crise de 2008, tout allait bien. Les
agences de notation, disaient tout
allait bien.
Il fallait les croire ou il fallait
avoir un ministre avec un peu de nez qui
se disait
"Vaz, moi en 2008, je fais remonter une
note à la direction du trésor sur les
risques sur Dexia au mois de juillet."
Voilà.
Et vous êtes positionné sur les marchés
grâce à ça ? Avant ou après ? Non, moi
je suis pas positionnée sur les marchés.
Moi je je suis longue case des dépôts,
c'est-à-dire actionnaire stratégique et
cetera. Mais nous on
nous on a fait une alerte.
Maman de famille.
Nous on a fait une alerte et on a fait
une alerte sur la base de la lecture de
la fais quoi à l'époque
à LM ? J'étais directrice des finances
et la stratégie la directrice adjoint
des finances et la stratégie la case des
dépôts et on est action.
Vous avez senti le couvenir ? Vous avez
senti le couvenir ? Pourquoi ? parce que
l'ALIL était déséquilibrée entre
les engagements
en fait les bilans entre les engagements
d'un côté et les et les lignes si vous
voulez. C'était
la note, elle a terminé dans quelle
poubelle ?
La quoi ? Ça, j'en sais rien parce qu'à
l'époque, j'ai pas eu de réponse
effectivement de la direction du trésor
et et le management de Dexia était
extraordinairement peu transparent
sur la situation. Les comptes de 2007
ont été remis sur table le jour du
comité d'audit. Je veux dire, c'est une
manque. Donc les comptes sont pas remis
sur table, ils doivent être transmis
avant pour que les membres du comité
d'audit puissent puissent les lire. Et
euh quand Forti est tombé euh moi
j'avais dit bon bah c'est donc d'exel la
semaine prochaine et on sait très bien
que ça se passe au moment où les bourses
enfin voilà c'est c'est ça se passe sur
un weekend parce que c'est ça l'espace
de temp ça ferme lundi. Exactement,
c'est ça l'espace de temps où on a une
chance de monter un plan de sauvetage et
nous on avait très clairement dit très
tôt que c'était pas eu
je ferme ma parenthèse
pas une crise de liquidité donc non je
veux dire on a on a beau avoir l'airbête
et la vue bas nous arrive d'avoir
quelques
Ouais mais vous étiez pas ministre à
l'époque
non j'étais j'étais à la casé des dépôts
qui était
donc fut
oui mais je pense que
quand quand je dis il faut pas quand
vous me dites il faut pas tout mélanger
un ministre qui prend un poste Ouais,
il doit connaître par exemple,
imaginez-vous, je vous bombarde ministre
de l'agriculture.
Oui.
Ça fait quelle surface un hectare ?
10000 m².
Quand Bruno Lemè est à l'agriculture, il
est pas foutu de répondre à ça.
Ben maintenant, il sait.
Oui, maintenant il sait.
Sauf que les agriculteurs, ça laisser
des cicatrices.
Quand vous êtes un ministre, que vous
prenez un ministère et que vous n'êtes
pas affuté ou que vous n'avez pas
voyagé, vous n'avez pas une expérience
qui vous permettrait de mettre les
doigts un peu partout et de comprendre
si Pierre Paul Jacques vous raconte
n'importe quoi ou vous raconte ce que
vous voulez entendre ou à des angles
morts, c'est compliqué, non ? Ah bah
c'est sûr que moi ce qui m'a aidé, c'est
que je connaissais le monde de
l'entreprise
et c'est que euh j'ai euh toujours
veiller et avoir des cordes de rappel
qui étaient en dehors de
l'administration et en dehors des
interlocuteurs habituels qu'on avait
dans chaque ministère. C'est-à-dire,
j'ai fait rentrer euh les associations
environnementales dans le ministère de
l'industrie. J'ai fait rentrer les
entreprises dans le ministère de
l'écologie. Parce que si vous avez pas
le job d'un ministre, c'est euh de faire
sortir de sa zone de confort
l'écosystème et l'administration avec
lequel vous travaillez. Sinon, vous
n'avez pas de valeur ajoutée, vous êtes
un passepat. Et pour faire ça, il faut
arriver à avoir effectivement une
information à 360°. Et le fait d'avoir
été ministre ces temps est assez
intéressante parce que je me suis aperçu
à quel point et je pense avec une totale
sincérité des administration étit
tellement orienté et tendu vers leur
objectif de portefeuille qu'elle ne
qu'elle montait des notes orientées.
C'est-à-dire que sur un même sujet et
c'est particulièrement vrai sur le sujet
agriculture alimentation, si je mets
bord à bord la note du ministère de
l'économie sur le même sujet, la note du
ministère de l'agriculture et la note du
ministère de l'écologie qui sont trois
ministères que j'ai occupé, je n'ai pas
la même réalité. Et tout l'enjeu, c'est
effectivement d'arriver à à et c'est là
où un ministre n'a pas forcément besoin
d'être un virtuose de la matière, mais
il a besoin d'être quelqu'un qui est
capable de prendre de la hauteur et et
d'aller trianguler, vous aimez bien ce
terme-là, l'information et de sortir du
jeu de l'interministérialité où
forcément il faut qu'on se taille des
croupières parce qu'on doit remporter
une victoire
et montrer qu'on on a obtenu un truc
pour notre ministère ou pour notre pour
notre écosystème. C'est ça qui est
difficile dans le métier du ministre.
Mais je pense que on a enfin je pense je
l'ai vécu
être un virtuose de la matière peut
parfois vous entraîner justement à vous
enfermer et à pas prendre cette cette
hauteur de vue. Moi, ça a été des points
d'appui de venir de l'industrie, de
venir aussi d'avoir fait des
investissements au moment des
restructurations. J'en avais déjà fait
dans le monde privé. Donc quand je vais
à Oscoval, qu'on me dit c'est mon
premier dossier que je je vais dans le
train aller pour Valencienne qu'on me
dit il va falloir que tu annonces, qu'on
ferme la boîte parce qu'il y a pas de
solution que j'écoute pendant quand même
2h euh les représentants des salariés
que j'écoute euh le gars qui est
directeur de site et que je lui dis
"Attends, les gars, ils ont remonté la
productivité en 9 mois de 30 %. Ils
viennent de Valourek, ils font mieux de
30 % que ce qu'ils avaient chez Valourc.
Euh, ils ont l'air d'avoir une notion
assez précise de leur point mort et de
leur capacité à être compétitif en prix
et cetera. C'est quand même en plus ils
sont décarbonés hein. Euh, c'est quand
même malot. En plus, c'est pour fournir
une usine qui fait derrière des rails.
Donc, le client principal final, c'est
la SNCF. Donc, ça reste quand même un
peu en famille si je puis utiliser ce ce
terme là. Il y a peut-être quand même un
truc à faire. Et effectivement là, je
suis allée contre la recommandation que
j'avais parce que j'avais cette
intuition business. Il m'est arrivé
d'avoir des intuitions qui collaient pas
enfin qui se sont révélées fausses
derrière et et sur lequel effectivement
on a confronté avec l'administration. Et
ce qui est super important quand on est
ministre, c'est effectivement d'être
capable de s'extraire de l'information
de l'administration, mais aussi de se
remettre en question et et de de voir
enfin d'ajuster constamment sa position,
de voir où on est en zone d'erreur ou
pas en zone d'erreur. Mais c'est pas une
vérité révélée. Il y a pas un truc qui
vous dit là c'est blanc, là c'est noir,
c'est beaucoup plus sophistiqué et on
est dans des espaces de temps de
décision qui sont très courts avec des
informations qui sont pas à 100 %. Alors
peut-être vous avez un point sur la
qualité de l'intelligence économique.
Moi je j'ai une petite frustration quand
je suis passée à l'énergie. Quand
j'étais à Bery, j'avais toutes les notes
de Bercy et toutes les notes de
l'intelligence économique de Bery. Quand
je suis passée à Rlore, donc ministère
de la transition énergétique, j'ai plus
eu ces notes. Évidemment, je les ai
demandé parce que j'en connaissais
l'existence et euh en fait, je les ai
jamais eu.
Il y avait rien qui empêchait que je les
ai mais c'était bah voilà, je sentais
bien que
ce qui est à Bersier appartient à
Berier, qu'il y a parfois des petites
mesquineries territoriales dans le
fonctionnement de l'État. Et ça c'est un
des un des sujets sur lequels on a
effectivement des vous avez pas pris
votre téléphone en disant bon Emmanuel
il y a pépère à Ber il y a pépère à Beru
mais tu as complètement raison il passe
le truc mais c'est tellement vénel et
tellement anecdotique que si vous voulez
le gars il envoyé et puis à la 15e
demande vous abandonnez et c'est bien ce
pourquoi pourquoi vous prenez pas votre
voiture de fonction avec vos deux gories
vous pointez à Ber vous demandez le nom
du gars vous le faites descendre de
l'ascenseur vous le recevez dans la cour
intérieure de Bercy et vous lui dites
qui t'écoute Popol, tu vas me donner les
notes sinon je vais appeler Emmanuel
puis tu vas finir tes ton
Mais parce que vous avez une vision qui
est très romantique un ministre
tu vas finir ton contrat
il agit dans le cadre d'un état de droit
dans les îles carguelenes et puis tu vas
et effectivement vous mutez pas
quelqu'un dans les îles cargelenes comme
ça on n'est pas dans une dictature on
n'est pas dans un état autoritaire
on peut pas muter quelqu'un dans les
cargélines
pas du jour au lendemain non on peut
sortir quelqu'un lorsqu'il a fait une
faut il faut reconnaître la faut est-ce
que cette information finalement elle
était pas suff suffisamment sensible
pour être partagé avec le ministère.
Est-ce que nous avions un niveau de
sécurité suffisant au ministère ? Vous
savez, quand j'arrive à RoLore, je mets
euh des badges pour rentrer dans le
périmètre ministériel parce que moi je
venais de Bercy et qu'à Bercy pour le
coup, on était hyper carré sur ça. Et je
le fais parce que je dis bah je suis un
peu embêté, il y a quand même des
centrales nucléaires donc et et après je
pose la deuxième question qui est donc
qui fait le ménage dans les
dans les dans les bureaux parce qu'à
Bercy ça rigole pas. Bersi, c'est un
fonctionnaire. Il y a que les
fonctionnaires et encore ceux qui ont
énormément de bouteilles qui ont le
droit de rentrer dans les bureaux des
ministres, y compris pour euh passer le
parce que parce que on peut prendre de
l'information, on peut voilà. Dans
d'autres, bah c'est une société privée.
J'ai dit ça serait quand même ballot
qu'elle s'appelle Natacha, la la femme
de ménage. Ce serait mieux de
Polonie
hein
de Natacha Polonie. Euh non, Natacha euh
ou euh ou euh Ivanova ou voilà, vous
voyez ce que je veux dire ou euh
et si elle s'appelait si elle s'appelait
Fritz
ou si elle s'appelait euh
et si elle s'appelait Fritz, qu'elle
était à Ber et ou sinon que qu'elle
avait une email
energy ou
Oui. Alors ça, il y a je il y a une
espèce de légende sur ce truc-là.
Euh objectivement, moi je peux en faire
le témoignage, je n'ai jamais eu de
pression antinucléaire de mes équipe de
l'administration.
Alors dans un certain nombre de de
d'interlocuteurs que j'ai pris ce qui
vous fait réagir sur nucléaire tout de
suite, pourquoi ? parce que les
Allemands vous ont mis des
Non, parce que en fait ce qui euh moi
j'ai été attaqué en disant vous avez
dans votre administration des gens qui
sont financés par
une fondation et qui euh comment dire
ont des positions systématiquement
antinucléaires et qui quelque part
pilotent la politique énergétique du
pays. Moi, c'est pas ce que j'ai vu, je
veux dire, je le dis très très
directement, j'ai jamais eu de note qui
était de et je pouvais détecter quand
même qui était
orienté de manière biaisée pour dire
faut pas faire de nucléaire, c'est très
dangereux et cetera. jamais eu de note.
J'ai eu des notes hyper euh encore une
fois hyper agnostique, c'estàd que et
euh
de monsieur Dupont
de monsieur de monsieur madame française
et oui, ça m'est arrivé de screener des
personnes pour vérifier leurs attaches.
Pas screener, on dit faire le pédigré.
Faire le pédigré si vous voulez euh pour
vérifier des personnes qui avaient qui
étaient euh binationaux. Et oui, ça
m'est arrivé d'écarter des personnes de
ce fait-là. C'est des choses qu'on fait
et sur lequel on est devenu assez
sérieux ces dernières années. Donc oui,
on a une colonne vertébrale, le
président de la République, le premier.
Ouais. Ouais. Ça vous me le ramenez,
vous me le ramenez, on lui fait un
stress tous ceux qui sont très promptes
à critiquer, mais be my guest, rentrez
en politique.
Soyez mon ami.
Ouais. Non, c'est plus que soyez mon
ami. Bienvenue, soyez mon autre. Rentrez
en politique,
prenez la charge, faites le boulot,
affrontez les médias, faites les petites
phrases qui sont maladroites et qui vous
reviennent en en boomerang. Et
effectivement, on fait des maladresses
de communication dans le feu et cetera.
Et quand on retient que ça et on retient
pas le boulot derrière de la magie.
Moi, c'est ça a été affreux. Je mes
enfants se se se figent de moi depuis 5
ans.
Vous voulez pas nous le faire un coup
pour le ferait pas parce que ça a été
voilà une et en plus c'est un tweet
malheureux qu'on a pas suivi si sinon
elle ça serait jamais sortie parce que
vous pouvez faire des même sur Twitter
vous avez votre gif. Oui oui oui je sais
je je je vous dis au moins ça fait le
bonheur de mes enfants ils se leur
passent ils en rigolent
une haché et tout de suite qui sort et
vous voyez ce qu'on retient revenons
non mais ce qu'on retient d'un ministre
et il fallait faire un autre bou bou
fallait faire un autre boulot
mais c'est pas ça
qu'est-ce qu'on disait à Marie
ce qu'on retient ce qu'on retient c'est
ce gif là c'est pas l'alliance c'est pas
l'alliance du nucléaire
et pourtant l'alliance du nucléaire je
peux vous dire c'est beaucoup plus
dimensionnant pour le pays et pour son
avenir
quand vous avez pris votre ministère et
que vous avez quand même compris qu'il
fallait mettre des badges pour savoir
qui est-ce qui rentrait, qui est-ce qui
sortait, si c'était
Jean-Paul, Fritz, Madame Dupont,
Monsieur Dupont, Madame Natacha, Madame
Pop. Ouais. ou Vladimir ou je dirais
Mike.
Ouais. Ou Mike
ou J.
Ouais.
C'est un peu normal qu'on soit au 21e
siècle qu'une ministre, elle dise quand
même les gars, on n pas dans un moulin
là.
Non mais c'est bien de le faire et
maintenant c'est fait.
Au 21e siècle,
vous avez pas demandé le responsable de
la sécurité qui est-ce qui était
responsable du fait qu'il y avait
personne de responsable ?
Si un responsable de la sécurité, vous
avez un haut fonctionnaire de défense
et vous lui avez soufflé dans les
branches.
Je ne parle pas de mes affaires de
famille à l'extérieur de la famille.
Ah parce queil possède avec vous. Non,
c'est euh
c'est façon de dire euh
quand on est un patron, on prend la on
prend le la pression et on met pas ses
équipes devant. C'est une question de
principe.
On passe à une troisème gestion de
crise.
Ouais.
L'Iran,
vous en pensez quoi ?
On se fait entraîner, on n pas de clé de
lecture, on a plus d'influence dans la
région. Donald Trump nous chie dans les
bottes et il en a rien à faire. Je je ce
que je crains dans la crise en errance,
c'est que Donald Trump est pas forcément
une clé de lecture lui-même. Et ça, je
pense que c'est le pire des scénarios
euh
parce qu'il faut jamais mettre le bouton
du missile dans les mains qui est de
quelqu'un qui est pas complètement
enfin qui semble un peu volatile.
Vous parlez Emmanuel Macron là ? Non, je
parle de je le le président, on peut lui
reprocher beaucoup de choses,
certainement des maladresses et cetera,
de pas avoir tout bien fait, une
certaine verticalité,
mais pas d'être volatile. Pas d'être
volatile. B moi je partage pas ça. Il y
a des sujets, j'ai quitté le
gouvernement hein, donc je euh mais
d'abord je dirais pas du mal parce que
c'est pareil, on dit pas du mal de ces
coéquipiers quand on a travaillé 7 ans,
on prend la charge. Mais là pour le
coup, Donald Trump, on a bien compris
que il y a une dimension
générer de l'argent plutôt classique et
très forte.
Ça, on a bien compris. On a bien compris
les mouvements de marché qui sont comme
par hasard dans des sens avec des des
opérations la veille.
Voilà, le hasard qui fait bien les
choses et qui fait les bons profits. Euh
mais je suis pas sûre qu'on ait
complètement qu'il est complètement une
compréhension ou une clé de lecture
comme vous le dites. Et donc ça c'est un
scénario qui rend du coup les scénarios
très ouverts et par ailleurs quand vous
êtes l'Iran et que vous êtes un gardien
de la révolution de toute façon votre
alternative c'est soit mourir dans tr
sur France de manière certaine soit
d'avoir une chance minime de ne pas
mourir dans d'atroc souffrance bah vous
choisissez le scénario où vous avez des
chances minimes de pas mourir dans
d'atroc souffrance donc vous êtes
jusqu'au bouthiste.
Alors on va accorder à Donald Trump le
bénéfice du doute que ce ne soit pas un
débile profond.
et qui soit relativement bien conseillé
avec des services de renseignement qui
bossent et surtout une politique
étrangère, j'ai pas terminé, je pense.
Une politique étrangère euh qui a une
cohérence sur les 30 dernières années
sur la sécurisation des bassins
énergétiques, le croque en jambe sur le
collier de perle face à la Chine et j'en
passais des meilleurs.
C'est clair qu'il y a un agenda
antiinois derrière tout ça. Oui, ça
qui est totalement cohérent depuis Bush
Biden, au
complement. Moi, j'ai assisté à une
réunion lunaire euh pendant le
le c'est
le truc de la tech en janvier là.
Non, non, non. Aux États-Unis. Euh,
ouais, voilà.
Euh avec deux membres du gouvernement.
Euh c'était en 2020 donc Biden à
l'époque mais Biden 1, c'est-à-dire un
peu moins push grabat
2 moins grab à terre
euh des jeunes euh pas des pas des
ministres pas pas la première ligne mais
genre ministre délégué secrétaire d'état
qui nous ont demandé à moi et mon
homologue néerlandaise si on était
contre la démocratie parce qu'on
n'affirmait pas notre soutien plein et
entier notre adhésion totale aux
États-Unis contre la Chine.
C'est soit vous êtes contre nous, soit
vous êtes avec nous.
Exactement. Et si vous êtes pas
complètement aligné avec nous, contre la
Chine, alors vous n'aimez pas alors vous
aimez les dictateurs et vous n'aimez et
ça a été formulé comme ça.
Et vous avez répondu fort chour,
on a répondu nous on est l'Europe euh on
fait nos choix en voilà, on a une
alliance avec vous, on porte les mêmes
valeurs de démocratie. Euh mais c'est
pas pour ça qu'on va se laisser
entraîner dans la relation dans laquelle
vous voulez nous amener avec la Chine.
Et donc euh voilà et qu'ils ont fait
en
bah ce qui était surprenant c'est qu'ils
avaient l'air de croire ce qu'il
disaient
et et c'est vrai qu'on a été euh
stupéfaite. On était deux femmes.
J'avais une néerlandaise qui devait
faire 2 m à côté de moi. C'était bien,
c'était rassurant. Euh et il nous avait
pris à part littéralement portugaise
énervé. C'est aussi très rassurant,
je pense aussi. Euh mais c'est c'était
mais c'était assez intéressant à voir
et donc oui, c'est une continuité et
même enfin je veux dire Obama Biden, il
y a une continuité
sur la politique étrangère. Clairement,
on va laisser le bénéfice du doute à
Donald que ce ne soit pas un débile
profond. Donc si c'est pas un débile
profond, qu'est-ce qu'il est en train de
nous faire ? Et quel est le don de la
farce dans les deux conflits qu'on est
en train de vivre ?
Est-ce que lui-même sait quel est le
dindon de la Frce ? Sachant que il est
très transactionnel
et que je pense qu'il est capable de
d'avoir plusieurs fer au feu et de
Vous avez pas l'impression qu'il se
comporte un peu comme un macro avec
narratif
qui se comporte comme Macron avec
non comme un Macron avec l'Europe ?
Ah non, mais il se comporte très mal
avec l'Europe. Mais ça, il y a pas de
doute, mais euh c'est pas
ça fait enfin voilà, le sujet c'est
effectivement de de tenir tête et de
tenir le rapport de force. Je veux dire
le gars qui vous explique qu'on va
importer 750 milliards d'euros de
fossiles, ça n'existe pas. Non, mais ça
n'existe pas.
Ça a été signé. Non.
Oui, c'est signé. Mais c'est c'est ça
n'a aucune valeur juridique. Pas
ça n'a aucune valeur juridique. C'est de
la com.
Vous savez que dans la signature avec le
Japon, il avait mis d'abord 350
milliards et en conférence de presse, il
annonce 400 milliards. Et vous voyez
théoriquement à l'image, il y a un sorte
de ils sont pokerface quand même. Mais
mais enfin, il y a un petit il accuse un
peu le coup le le Premier ministre.
Vous avez vu la blague avec Perbord ?
Oui, c'est c'est d'une indescence en
plus avec le Japon qui est un pays euh
où il faut quand même enfin il y a il y
a une espèce d'éducation euh très
importante dans la relation si on veut
pas l'altérer euh de manière euh
durable.
Encore pire avec les Chinois. Euh
les Chinois, les les Japonais. Oui. Mais
mais euh pour le coup Oui, là on est
dans dans on abîme enfin je pense que
les États-Unis après je veux pas
m'élever au-dessus de ma condition.
Encore une fois, moi je suis pas
ministre des affaires étrangères, j'ai
pas cette expérience, j'ai pas été
ministre pas dans le misérabilisme de la
puissance Agnè. Encore une fois, je veux
dire, je juste remet d'où je parle. Là,
je parle comme député, je parle comme
ancienne ministre, mais je n'ai pas
touché les encore une fois les sujets de
puissance et comme vous l'avez compris,
on est assez compartimenté et donc des
informations secrées qui n'ont pas
vocation à venir à certains ministres ne
viennent pas à certains ministres. C'est
comme ça. Euh mais
comment ça se fait quand vous êtes
ministre de l'industrie, ministre de
l'énergie,
vous ayez pas accès à l'ensemble du
spectre
de toutes les notes, de toute source
d'information qui vous permettrait de
piloter le sang de la France ? Oui, mais
on pilote néanmoins puisque on a euh des
euh comment dire euh des orientations
qui sont très clair.
Vous en tant que prist de l'industrie,
vous n'êtes pas capable d'appeler à DGS
en disant "Écoute mon pote Nicolas là,
tu vas travailler un peu, tu vas
m'envoyer un gars dans cette bois-là,
cette boîte là parce que je veux de
l'info."
Nous sommes pas organisés comme ça.
Effectivement,
c'est une blague. Vous pouvez pas
appeler Nicolas pour que Nicolas
je peux appeler Tracfin.
Je peux appeler euh je peux évidemment
appeler nos ambassades et leur demander
de faire spécifiquement des suivis et
cetera. Je vais appeler nos entreprises
et celles avec lesquelles j'ai des
relations plus sérieuses. Et moi ça
m'est arrivé effectivement de de piloter
comme ça. Euh mais je n'ai pas euh je
n'avais pas la main directement sur tel
ou tel ou tel service.
Ça vous a démangé
en fait ? Euh
je pense que les informations enfin on
avait quand même un pilotage assez
resserré avec premier ministre
moi j'étais ministre de l'énergie sous
Ellisabeth Borne et Emmanuel Macron
c'est deux personnes qui mangent de la
note et de l'information dans des
quantités astronomiques. C'est dire que
Ellisabeth Born est capable de vous dire
la page 35 de ton document, il y a une
incohérence, je ne comprends pas. Donc
elle l'a lu.
Mais encore heureux. Non mais oui, enfin
c'est pas l'im c'est pas l'image qui du
politique en moyenne et ça je peux vous
dire que c'était deux enfin ce sont
d'ailleurs deux avions de chasse qui euh
qui ont une maîtrise technique euh des
sujets qui qui est assez
impressionnante. Donc
les priorités qu'on se donnait, elles
étaient très clairement formulées par
premier ministre, président de la
République,
qu'il quel qu'il soit d'ailleurs,
Philippe, Castex,
Born, Atal, après on a eu des cycles un
peu plus courts mais en gros ça c'était
très clair et et on perdait pas de temps
hein. C'estd que moi quand j'ai repris
donc le portefeuille de l'énergie,
on avait la gestion du de la correson
sous contrainte de DF où on essayait
d'accélérer avec la SN
les réparations.
On avait
le tout tout le plan sobriété qu'on a
démarré qui qui est un plan
commencez pas à repartir. L'Iran.
Ouais, pardon. L'Iran.
Nos boîtes, la stabilité de notre
agriculture, la stabilité du monde.
Quand vous voyez Donald qui a forcément
un jada dans la continuité de ce qui a
été annoncé après 2001,
qu'ils allaient faire tomber.
Il y a bien quelqu'un qui s'est penché
sur la situation. Si Hormous était
fermée, si minit tout le bordel, si en
comment vous dites en anglais
retaliation.
Ouais.
Ils allaient taper tous leurs petits
copains en face.
Nous, la France, elle voit ça. Elle voit
comme une vache qui regarde le TGV.
Elle voit ça avec des yeux et des
oreilles sur place. Elle se dit "Je suis
déjà sur les deux prochains coups pour
rendre mon industrie, ma production
énergétique agile ou je vais encore
faire de la gestion symptomatique
à grand coût de dette chèque énergie et
de blabla sur TF1 ? Ben, je pense que on
l'a très clairement dit, c'est-à-dire
que la stratégie de décarbonation de
défossilisation, elle a été publié
récemment. Non, non, mais je veux dire,
elle existe, elle est déployée. Et quels
sont ces deux principaux ?
Alors, elle est pas déployée.
Quels sont ces deux principaux ? Existe
que sur papier.
Non, non, elle est pas que sur le le
papier. Les appels d'offre, ils sortent.
la question de du pilotage et et fait
l'objet d'un travail et des cahiers des
charges. Vous avez encore une fois on a
100 TW d'avance sur l'électricité. On
nous explique qu'on en a trop, qu'on a
mal géré.
C'est qui trop ? Qui on
qui ont l'opinion publique, nos
oppositions au parlement et un certain
nombre de bons esprits.
Pourquoi pourquoi mon mégaw je le paye
une blinde ?
Vous le payez une blinde ? Vous avez
regardé le prix sur les marchés
aujourd'hui ?
Euh aujourd'hui à quelle heure ? Euh
hier, il était à 16 € du MW. Avant-hier,
il était à 50 € du MW.
Et pourquoi mon contrat, il a fait euh x
3 ? parce que vous êtes au tarif
réglementé et que vous prenez la fin de
traî de l'augmentation des tarifs 202 24
et là vous commencez à le voir baisser,
baisse de 15 % l'année dernière,
stabilité et théoriquement vous avez
encore une année qui devrait encoder une
baisse et qui va être enfin qui va être
comment dire mise en au regard de
l'année 2026, donc la baisse de 2025
fera la moitié de votre prix et la
l'année 2026 dira de combien sera votre
prix final en fonction de ce que ce sera
dans l'année. Mais aujourd'hui, ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit c'est que
on a énormément décorrélé avec le gaz
parce qu'on est large parce qu'on a
justement une
production de renouvelable et une
production de de nucléaire qui limite
les moments où on démarre le gaz.
Donc le le le prix c'est plus indexé sur
le prix du gaz. Et ça c'est une légende
cette indexation. Le prix de
l'électricité est indexé sur le prix de
la dernière facilité appelé. Et donc si
c'est du charbon, c'est le prix du
charbon. Si c'est du gaz, c'est le prix
du gaz. Si c'est euh du fioule, il y en
a quand même plus beaucoup en Europe.
C'est le prix du FU. Je le dis de
manière un peu. Si c'est le
renouvelable, c'est le prix du
renouvelable. Et si c'est le si c'est le
nucléaire, c'est le prix du
renouvelable. C'est le prix du
nucléaire. Et donc tout votre enjeu
c'est de faire en sorte d'empiler des
capacités décarbonées pas chères avant
d'appeler des capacités qui
effectivement vont taper le prix du gaz.
Donc on n'est pas indexé sur le gaz mais
c'est sûr que quand on a un pic de
consommation qu'on appelle du gaz et que
le gaz coûte cher, ben à un moment
effectivement ça se réindexe. Mais ça ça
c'est le c'est le c'est un marché, c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne
donc non mais juste pour aller jusqu'au
bout parce que ça c'est quand même
important. électricité,
si c'est important, je vous laisse aller
jusqu'au bout.
Électricité, vous avez vu les tarifs en
Italie ?
Oui.
Combien ?
En Belgique aussi.
Combien en Italie ?
Très cher.
137 135
exactement. Alors ça varie tous les
jours mais en gros c'est deux à trois
fois le tarif français. On en parle de
ça ? Ça c'est le résultat de la
politique énergétique qui a été menée
depuis.
Comment ça se fait qu'ils réduisent leur
déficit et pas nous ? Vous avez vu les
investissements qu'il font
parce que c'est pas le miracle
économique italien. Pas tout à fait.
Alors et et donc c'est une situation
économique entre employ après la France
elle a aussi un certain nombre de choses
à revoir. Nous on a un modèle social qui
est
est extrêmement important extrêmement
protect ministre Iran. On viendra, on vi
les retraites aussi, on parlera aussi de
tout ça.
Ouais. Et
et on a le temps.
L'Iran.
Ouais.
Scénario 1, scénario 2, scénario 3.
Comment nos boîtes vont souffrir ?
Comment nos agriculteurs vont souffrir ?
Comment l'inflation va revenir sur les
prix de la bouffe ?
Alors euh
est-ce que la France est prête à ça ?
Casquette député, pas casquette
ministre, pas casquette accès à
l'enfant.
Casquette Agnè là.
Casquette Agnè. Donc Casquette Agnè avec
son expérience de partout, sa lecture,
comment va se comment ça va se comporter
?
Bah donc premier premier élément, c'est
la diffusion du prix du carburant. Donc
prix du carburant, vous avez secteur de
la pêche, secteur de l'agriculture,
transport routier qui a la possibilité
de probablement plus passer ses prix euh
et mais avec un une diffusion du coût
dans les prix, l'économie de
l'inflation, c'est le premier élément
d'inflation probablement avec des
indexations qui vont se déclencher tous
les 15 jours. Et donc on va avoir un
effet de de traî dont il faut voir quel
est l'impact
sur sur les prix génériques. Après vous
avez le coût des matériaux tous ceux qui
sont liés au gaz, la terre cuite,
beaucoup de matériaux de de construction
qui supposent les
engrais les engrais.
Ça c'est le le point suivant. Les
engrais c'est un double double
problématique prix et fourniture
comme l'uranium. Non.
Ouais mais l'uranium c'est sur un effet
de traîne beaucoup plus long. On n'est
pas sur une une immédiaté
et une profondeur. Les engrais, c'est
ici et maintenant. Donc face à ça,
qu'est-ce qu'on a ? On a des ménages qui
ont un tarif réglementé gaz qui va
s'indexer progressivement parce que une
partie est fond enfin parce que le prix
est réactualisé
régulièrement sur la base de la réalité
du marché.
On a la reconstitution de notre stock de
gaz qui est en train de démarrer
maintenant puisqu'on est en fin de
période euh de d'hiver. Donc c'est pas
maintenant qu'on prend le l'impact du
gaz, mais il va se diffuser parce que
pour reconstituer nos stocks de gaz, on
les fait et et on a un délai minimum.
Enfin, je veux dire, on a on peut pas
jouer à l'accordéon en disant "J'attends
que le prix baisse puis j'en refais
beaucoup parce que il y a il y a une une
inerciible infrastructure." Donc, on va
prendre du prix qui va s'exprimer
ensuite à l'automne.
Je peux vous couper une seconde ?
Ouais.
Le gaz russe 2027, c'est terminé ou
c'est déjà terminé ? On est quoi ? Il
nous reste 12 % d'énergie qui vient de
chez Popof. Ouais. Ouais.
Là, le D3 Dormous compliqué là. Il reste
qui ? Les Américains, nos copains les
Suédois, les Norvégiens,
les Norvégiens,
pas beaucoup.
Les Norvégiens, ils ont de la puissance
de feu. Les Américains les Américains,
ils ont redémarré tarif à quel tarif ?
Parce que
tarif de marché,
on avait discuté avec les producteurs de
gaz de chistre euh américain, il nous
avit dit il y aura pas de plomb pour
l'Europe, hein. On a pas les capacités
de vous fournir. Vous avez pas les
capacités de décompresser. Compliqué.
Alors, on a beaucoup plus de terminaux
gazier maintenant. Ça c'est Ah non, au
niveau européen, on en a
sur bateau, c'est ça ?
Non, non, pas sur bateau. Je parle pas
du FCRU qui était au large du Havre. Je
parle des terminaux gaziers, on en a, je
crois euh un de plus au Pays-Bas, deux
de plus en Allemagne. Tout ça est
collectif.
Capacité de la totalité additionnée,
c'est combien de millions de barils ?
2 millions de de barils, pardon de
comment ? C
Ouais, 2 m C.
Oh là là ! Euh là, vous allez me
ressortir des euh je connaissais ces
chiffres par cœur il y a 4 ans, mais là
j'ai un peu plus un peu lointain pour
moi.
C'est c'est du domaine du cosmétique ou
c'est du domaine
Non non, c'est c'est dimensionné puisque
ça nous a permis de de gérer la crise
euh la crise gazière russe.
OK. Là, on a la crise gazière Qatari
saoudienne qui nous arrive. Ils ont des
capacités détruites de production.
Arabie Saoudite et notamment, ils
peuvent bouger un certain nombre de leur
routes, ils sont en train de le faire.
Il faut pas qu'il y a un drone qui tombe
dessus, hein.
Oui, ça dépend quels sont leurs. Euh
donc là, on doit refaire nos stocks de
gaz. J'ai
et ce qu'on avait en 2022 qu'on ne
devrait pas avoir maintenant, c'est
qu'on avait la plus grosse usine GNL
américaine qui avait bolé. C'est quand
même pas de chance. euh et qui était
censé redémarrer 2026.
Donc euh je pense que on a des plus et
des moins. La tension, aller au niveau
de l'Asie, ça c'est très clair. Euh
vous avez vu ce qui se passe euh en
Australie, en Thaïlande, au Cambodge,
euh dans tous ces coins-là, c'est
rationnement euh
AAustralie, ils ont quoi 3 jours encore
et après c'est Madma Max. Non, c'est pas
ça. C'est alors c'est qu'en fait on
passe en mode crise. Nous, on a vécu la
crise ukrainienne comme si c'était un
truc totalement européen.
Mais l'Asie avait déjà vécu les parce
que quand nous on appelait du gaz parce
qu'on avait de l'argent et qu'on pouvait
payer plus cher, eux sont retrouvés
rationnés en gaz. Ils ont dû repasser
pour une partie d'entre eux sur base
charbon. Pourquoi ? Pourquoi la Chine
pivote sur sa politique du charbon en
2023 alors qu'elle est championne du
climat ? Parce qu'elle est championne du
climat contrairement à ce qu'on raconte.
Elle est arrivée à son pic d'émission de
CO2. Elle a 5 ans d'avance sur le
déploiement de ses énergies
renouvelables. Elle pivote sur le
charbon et moi je l'ai eu parce que
j'étais j'ai vu tous les ministres
chinois de qui touchent de près de loin
au climat et à la biodiversité l'année
dernière au mois de mai où on essayait
de faire un accord avec la Chine sur le
climat et d'essayer d'entraîner l'Europe
dans ça en disant on n'est pas d'accord
sur plein de trucs mais sur ça on est
d'accord et on surtout on a un vrai
besoin de rapport de force inversé à
créer vis-à-vis de des États-Unis.
Pourquoi ils ont redémarré du charbon ?
parce qu'ils ont vu dans la crise
ukrainienne qu'ils étaient dépendants
pétrole et gaz et que c'est
insupportable et donc leur facilité
charbon, c'est des facilités qui sont
utilisées en picque qui sont des
facilités qui ne sont pas permanentes,
enfin qui mettent peu sur le réseau,
mais néanmoins qui les désensibilisent à
un risque de crise et c'est comme ça que
c'est pensé.
Quand on se pointe et qu'on discute avec
les chinois, ça se passe comment ?
C'est
en fait ça dépend.
Ce qui est difficile c'est d'arriver à
avoir un dialogue qui soit un dialogue
qui soit pas des EDL.
Il faut arriver à à rentrer en en
interaction et en confiance à un certain
niveau pour arriver à à sortir euh des
éléments préparés et et
chou
avec bah en fait moi sur la la
négociation climat
euh et je vais pas les citer
parce que mais effectivement on avait
des interlocuteurs qui nous permettez
d'avoir cette partie qui est essentielle
en diplomatie, qui est le moment où vous
passez les messages et vous donnez les
clés de lecture d'une partie de votre
jeu pour les amener dans votre terrain
et vous essayez de déclencher les clés
de lecture de leur jeu pour les amener
enfin voilà pour trouver l'accord. Mais
ça ça peut pas se faire avec les EDL
préparés par le ministère des affaires
étrangères ou le ministère
qui voilà ça ça marche pas.
La valeur ajoutée d'un ministre dans une
négociation diplomatique, c'est
justement de passer au
à l'intuit personnalé et et d'arriver à
à comprendre et à obtenir des choses
dans vraiment dans le rapport personnel.
Moi, avec le ministre de l'Arabie
Saoudite, j'ai changé sur WhatsApp avec
le patron euh Abdouazziz Ben Salman,
avec le patron de la COP 28 euh Sultan
Aljabert, j'ai changé sur WhatsApp euh à
toutes les failles de sécurité que ça
représente.
On s'en fout. B, je veux dire euh là,
c'est euh les gens peuvent lire, c'est
une relation qui qui va porter des
positions, qui vise évidemment, on
n'écrit pas de conneries sur WhatsApp,
on fait attention.
aux archives vos conversations WhatsApp
?
Euh c'est mon téléphone personnel,
monsieur.
Quand vous êtes ministre, est-ce qu'on
vous briefe sur les conditions de
sécurité
euh sur vos données, vos failles de
sécurité qui peuvent vous tamponner ?
J'ai bien aimé votre réflexion
concernant les femmes de ménage dans les
ministères.
On nous brief différemment. Je pense que
Ber
intérieur euh affaires étrangères et
défenses ont un niveau euh nativement
plus renforcé dans le la sécurité que
les autres ministères.
Et donc vous vous étiez pas renforcé du
tout avec votre propre téléphone. Il y a
pas sa gem qui vous a donné un téléphone
quand vous êtes arrivé ? La petite
valisette.
Si si, on a des valisettes et cetera
mais
j'utilisais jamais.
qu'on utilise quand on a vraiment besoin
de l'utiliser, c'est-à-dire sur non mais
sur des choses qui sont qui sont quand
vous faites du nucléaire, c'est
téléphone en dehors des salles et que
des humains qui se parlent entre eux,
hein. Un conseil de politique nucléaire,
c'est
avec ou sans montre connecté ?
Sans montre connecté et un brouilleur
allumé. Un conseil de politique
nucléaire, c'est téléphone à la porte,
brouilleur allumé, pas de montre
connecté.
C'est la seule c'est c'est la seule
situation de de sécurité et encore pass
la faille humaine. Vous
vous passez au détecteur de métau avant
?
Euh on passe pas au détecteur de métau
mais enfin on met très peu de cord
chinois ou russe ou allemand ou
américain vous met un micro dans vos
talons
brouille. Il y a le brouilleur
brouille
donc la transmission est pas possible.
l'enregistrement peut-être.
Euh mais il faut récupérer. On est très
méchant sur les cadeaux.
Ah parce qu'on vous a proposé des
cadeaux.
Ah mais non mais vous avez toujours un
petit machin euh machin
un petit machin. Ça va être euh
clé USB.
Non alors les clés USB certainement pas.
Non ça clé USB interdit. Ça c'est c'est
assez clair. Non mais vous pouvez avoir
une petite gravure une tasse de thé
enfin c'est tout le monde ayant à peu
près les mêmes politiques
anticorruption. Euh c'est dosé euh pour
650 € vaccin
650 € ouais. Euh et si c'est plus de Et
si c'est plus de 150 € de toute façon le
balance au mobilier national comme ça
ils en font leur leur miel.
Et donc vous quand on vous offre une
petite tasse à 10 balles, vous offrez
quoi en retour ? Euh nous on offre euh
une petite assiette euh du musée euh
non euh soit George Pompidou euh vous
savez il y a des ou ça peut être un
petit euh euh un petit stylo ou euh
voilà euh fait en prison
euh non toujours des trucs euh 100 %
made in France euh French Touch Touch
non French Touch un truc un peu comme ça
quand même. Un peu
bouteille de pinard un peu. Non
non jamais.
Oh bah
jamais
même pas
non. Bouteille de pinard ? Non, enfin
moi j'ai jamais offert de bouteille de
pinard. Bah
bah même un truc à 30 balles.
Oui, mais j'ai jamais offert de
bouteille de pinard. Je vous réponds. Je
je veux pas l'inventer.
Picoler un peu.
Euh moi, à titre personnel, ouais.
Et au ministère ? Non.
Euh au ministère, au dîner, oui, mais
pas avant.
On est en France quand même. Merde, on a
le droit de faire ça.
Ouais. Ouais. Mais je veux dire, quand
vous prenez une journée de 18h, faut pas
trop s'allumer à midi, sinon vous êtes
pas frais.
Ouais. Sauf quand on est ministre de
l'agriculture, on a le droit. Revenons à
l'Iran.
Si ça continue
déjà la l'inertie que énergétique que le
monde a pris est en train de se
matérialiser
sur les prix des dangers des matières
premières les marchés qui deviennent de
plus
c'est un choc symétrique hein
symétrique.
Un c'est un choc symétrique c'est-à-dire
tout le prend tout le monde le prend en
même temps. Non mais c'est important
dans l'industrie. C'est-à-dire que vous
avez pas
celui qui est producteur énergétique
quand même hein. Euh oui, mais enfin je
le sentiment que là en terme de
production, il y a pas euh dans la
compétition ce que dit France Industrie
hein, parce que j'ai évidemment euh un
peu mes réflexes et j'ai réuni toutes
les entreprises de mon territoire euh
vendredi dernier. On a fait une viso de
2h. J'avais eu avant France Industrie
qui me dit choc symétrique plus facile
que que l'Ukraine qui me dit nous comme
on a quand même travaillé bah notamment
avec vous
on est couvert assez largement alors les
couvertures on a toujours un débord qui
peut varier de 30 à 10 %
la couverture énergétique
ouais couverture
les les couvertures énergétiques des
transporteurs aériens euh là c'est c'est
ça j'ai pas vérifié mais je peux vous
dire sur la tête la couverture en tout
cas industrielle, il y en a beaucoup qui
sont couverts. Évidemment, la couverture
elle est euh
elle se elle diminue au fur et à mesure.
Réduire en pot de chagrin.
Non, mais c'est 27 28, certains 29, mais
vous êtes à mettons 80 % 27
% 28 pardon, c'est 26 27 28 donc vous
êtes à 80 % 26.
60 % 27 et 30 à 40 % 28 parce que vous
devez vous rouler vos couvertures. Euh
donc ça dépend le le temps et la durée
de la crise et évidemment la question de
la renégociation de vos contrats au
moment où où ils arrivent à maturité,
comment vous roulez vos vos couvertures
suivantes. C'est ça la question qui se
pose. Mais on a
un un temps de pour souffler et on a
derrière ensuite
combien de temps ? Combien de temps ?
6 mois.
sur l'industrie hein, sur l'industrie
couverte et après les signaux
d'inflation vont se propager. Ce qu'on
constate c'est une baisse de la
consommation et ça elle est plus marquée
que ce qui était attendu au sens où elle
n'est pas directement
attendue par qui ? Par
non par les par les chefs d'entreprise.
C'est elle est pas
il ne l'explique pas.
Et euh on a et on
il il explique pas parce qu'ils sont
quoi en catatonie informationnelle
émotionnelle.
Non non parce que il sont ils sont
tétanisés.
Ils constatent ils constatent que par
rapport à leur cycle habituel de prise
de commande euh ils ont vécu une période
scolaire et théoriquement après la
période scolaire, il y a une espèce de
de qui est plus calme et ensuite il ils
reprennent des commandes de manière
assez naturelle.
C'est ça.
Et là, ils sont en plat mais sur des sur
des métiers aussi euh variés que
tailleur de pierre, charpentier,
menuisier et cetera. Euh et donc et et
les enjeux qui se posent, c'est comment
on gère la diffusion dans l'économie de
cette inflation en faisant en sorte
qu'elle euh de l'amortir, mais il est
hors de question de sortir le chèque.
Moi, la mesure la plus
celle que je regrette le plus et que je
ne soutenais pas euh c'est la remise
l' avalé quand même.
Mais je l'ai avalé quand même. Euh je
l'ai avalé quand même. Tout à fait. Euh
parce que vous pouvez vous dire est-ce
que j'ai mis ça de machin ? Mais en fait
je l'ai avalé. Euh c'est la mesure
carburant euh de baisse de 15 centtimes
du carburant que nous avaient plus ou
moins impossé les républicains au Sénat
parce qu'ils avaient la majorité au
Sénat et qu'on était dans une tension en
terme de de gestion de enfin capacité à
faire une majorité. C'est 15 centimes,
c'était ça a été 9 milliards d'euros.
9 milliards d'euros euh c'est
18 ans du budget actuel de bonus
écologique, c'estàdire pour passer à la
voiture électrique.
Ce qui bonus écologique compte tenu du
prix aujourd'hui
des voitures électriques et du fait que
leur coût d'usage est moins élevé non
seulement carburant mais assurance et
entretien
fait que vous avez vraiment un un kicker
à acheter en tout cas des petites
citadines. Je connais la
quoi comme voiture ?
Moi j'ai une 5 minutes hybride. Enfin je
roule en 5 minutes hybride. C'est celle
de mon compagnon.
Hybride ça veut dire faire sauter le
malus.
Non, c'est pas faire sauter le malus,
c'est avoir quatre enfants de chat dans
une voiture. Donc, je suis obligé
d'avoir une se place moi.
Non, mais hybride, ça veut dire le côté
on a un bonus écologique.
Non, on n pas de bonus écologique. On a
plus de bonus écologique sur C'est
simplement d'avoir effectivement le
meilleur modèle en cette place
fabriquant en France. Évidemment,
vous avez de char
de chat.
Comment il s'appelle ?
Chamallo et Tessa.
L'Iran.
si ça dure plus longtemps que prévu.
Non, le vrai moi le le l'inquiétude
c'est vraiment le côté engrais
euh et effectivement quelles sont les
réponses qu'on peut déployer aujourd'hui
? Électrification, ça ça paraît très je
dira
mais oui mais à chaque fois que vous
mettez une voiture électrique, vous
mettez quelqu'un à l'abri hein déjà
méthanisation puisque là on est sur des
prix qui vont commencer à rendre la
méthanisation
compétitive. La métanisation, c'est 80 à
120 € du MWh. Donc c'est moins
compétitif que du gaz naturel à 30 € du
MWh. Mais quand on commence à tangenter
des des niveaux un peu élevés, ça
commence à devenir intéressant. Et puis
surtout ça fait du digest la
méthanisation, les digestas, ça remplace
les engrais. Donc ça si on peut pousser
toutes nos
attendez 10 % 15 % 20 % c'est les trucs
qu'on peut aller chercher. Moi je je
vous assure he le passage de la crise
énergétique de 2022 où on évite le
backout le blackout c'est de la sobriété
tout le monde rigolait on fait - 10 %
même - 12 % combiné - 17 % sur le gaz -
9 % sur l'électricité
c'est le contingendement des chauffaux
où on vous savez certainement qu'on peut
piloter les chauffaux et les horaires
auquels on les on les positionne. Alors
ça a l'air très bête mais ça efface plus
de d'un GW de puissance. On avait
centrale
Ouais, c'est une centrale. Donc une
centrale qui manquait à l'appel. Bim, ça
c'est fait.
C'est de l'effacement dans les
entreprises qu'on avait mis en place.
C'est les interconnexions sur lesquelles
on appelle un maximum d'électricité. Et
merci nos copains allemands parce que
là, ils nous ont fourni l'électricité
tout l'hiver. Donc ça sert à ça aussi
les les l'Europe euh et c'est euh le le
le travail qu'on a fait effectivement de
de remonter et de gestion de
l'hydroélectricité. En plus pas de peau,
on cumule
un incident sur nos centrales nucléaires
qui fait qu'on en arrête une grosse
partie et une année de sécheresse qui
fait que notre hydroélectricité est au
plus bas. Donc on a quand même appris à
gérer et malgré tout basse. Donc c'est
pareil, il faut regarder tous les
leviers qui sont à notre disposition
pour effacer, baisser, déplacer,
produire
et euh remettre des chaînes courtes.
C'est peut-être ici euh 5 MWh, là 10 MWh
et cetera, mais enfin à la fin vous fait
la quantité qui permet soit d'alléger la
facture, soit d'éviter des rationnements
pénibles. quand même une vraie valeur.
Comme dirait Bruno le faut débrancher sa
box wifi mettre un col roulé. C'est ça.
Ouais. Bah euh le 19° dans les maisons,
c'est 7 % de consommation au moins.
Mais là là
7 %
là c'est plutôt 16°gr maintenant chez
les gens 20%
la il y a les gens qui chauffent plus.
Ça c'est la précarité énergétique. On a
jamais dit qu'il fallait être à 16°gr.
Et quand ils sont en électrique, ils ont
pas ça. Ils ont pas ça quand ils font la
rénovation thermique.
Rénovation thermique, moi je l'ai fait
dans le bassin minier. Les maisons du
bassin minier en rénovation thermique,
c'est 40 % d'économie sur la facture. 40
% d'économie. Ça c'est des vraies
solutions. Je peux vous dire les gens
qui sont dans les maisons du du bassin
minier, c'est pas c'est pas bét en
cours, hein. C'est euh
c'est qui bét en cours ?
C'est l'actionnaire de l'Oréal.
C'est celle qui a un presse papier en or
massif.
Je sais pas, je connais pas son bureau.
Euh mais
c'est c'est Tati comment l'appel comment
il l'appelait Nicolas. C'est Tati. Non,
je sais pas. Euh mais c'est des dizaines
de milliers de personnes qui ont été
mises à l'abri ces opérations de
rénovation thermique. La rénovation
thermique c'est plus d'un million de
ménages qui ont été mises à l'abri. Euh
l'électrification des véhicules, c'est
plus d'un million de ménages ce qui est
passé à l'électrique. Donc le leasing
social, c'est 50000 personnes qui
basculent à l'électrique. Tout ça, on
les met à l'abri.
Entre 2017 et 2026, Emmanuel Macron a
fait 1300 milliards de dettes.
Don 500 milliards de dettes sur
250 Covid.
Non, non, pas sur le Covid, sur les
retraites.
Donc 500 milliards que sur les
Pourquoi ?
Je sais pas si vous êtes au courant
qu'on vit plus longtemps, qu'on fait
moins de gamins, qu'on a moins de de
personnes qui arrivent sur le marché du
travail et tout ça, ça fait un effet
ciseau et on a l'air de le découvrir. Et
nous avons passé une réforme sur les
retraites qui était très difficile, très
impopulaire. C'était peut-être pas la
meilleure réforme hein, il faut se dire
néanmoins, attendez et même en faisant
la réforme, on se retrouve à avoir un un
déséquilibre entre recettes et dépenses.
Et c'est pas parce que les retraités
sont méchants, c'est parce que on a
moins d'actifs et plus de retraités qui
vivent plus longtemps.
Et pourquoi on baisse pas les retraites
?
Parce que vous avez le sentiment que on
a une majorité pour faire ça parce que
nous on a fait beaucoup de propositions.
C'est que sociologiquement parlant, le
pays n'est plus gouvernable.
Je dis qu'aujourd'hui on n' pas une
majorité. C'est factuel. C'est ce qui
s'est passé. C'est ce qui s'est passé en
commission affaires sociale. Traduit je
traduit autrement quand mon groupe
il y a tellement de vieux retraités
qu'ils ont pris le contrôle du pays.
Quand je propose avec mon groupe
politique de pas indexer votre groupe
politique
ensemble pour la République,
ça fait EPR.
Et vous avez vu ? magnifique hein. On a
le sens du Moi, j'ai trouvé ça très bien
euh quand on propose avec mon groupe
politique euh de ne pas indexer les
retraites de plus de 3000 ou 4, on avait
fait tout un menu en disant 2005 3005 et
ben tous les autres groupes politiques
ont voté contre.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que c'est pas assumable vis-à-vis
de leur
socle électoral.
Socle électoral. Donc c'est ce que je
dis
et même les républicains qui nous
donnent des leçons de bonne gestion et
qui sont ceux qui font cette fichu
baisse du carburant il y a 4 ans de 15
centimes qui nous a coûté un bras de
vote.
Non, c'est pas la subordination de vote,
c'est du manque de courage, c'est de la
préférence pour le court terme.
C'est un taux d'actualisation
élevé en en bonne finance.
Dans ces casl dans ces cas-là, le pays
va où là ? Ben dans ces cas-là, il faut
à un moment effectivement faire preuve
de courage et essayer de de se battre
pour dire euh la réalité des faits.
Emuel Macron, il est à 20 % parce qu'il
est très courageux ou parce qu'il est
détesté par la terre entière.
Il est
Arrêtez de rigoler quand je vous dis ça.
Non, j'ai Il est très cour.
Vous avez été ministre de l'Emmanuel
Macron, vous êtes censé l'aider.
Oui. Oui. Ben, il est très courageux, ça
je vous le dis. Euh bah,
il est pas suffisamment courageux pour
mettre son petit derrière en face, hein.
Comment ça son petit derrière en face ?
Bah, en face de nous.
On l'a fait appeler à gauche, à droite
par des copains, pas des copains sur son
téléphone.
Ah écoute, c'est ça. Je je m'imise pas
dans les relations que vous avez.
Par contre, par contre, il va mettre son
petit popotin sur des trucs bien clean,
bien tout près que il va pas être
secoué.
Non, non, il a une capacité
d'improvisation à mon avis qui est qui
est qui est qui est très forte. Il a
montré pendant le grand débat. Euh et je
pense que tout le monde était un peu
impressionné et euh il est parfait.
Quel débat ? Quand il a dit bah tu es
qui me madame Le Pen là ?
Non non, le grand débat euh quand il
allait euh face à euh 500 ma que euh il
était capable de répondre pendant 4
heures à n'importe quelle question. Non,
donc ça euh là j'ai j'ai mon assistant
qui me met un commentaire qui me dit
"Vous avez fait 23 493 sous Macron, donc
vous pouviez faire passer ce que vous
vouliez."
Non, ça c'est faux.
Tu as compris ? Elle a dit la dame que
tu avais faux. Ouais, parce qu'en fait
on a fait euh un 493 qui était pas le
projet de loi de finance et le projet de
loi de finance de sécurité sociale parce
qu'en fait un 493 c'est partie le PLF à
lui seul c'est 1493 sur la partie
dépense puis93 sur la partie recette en
première lecture puis 493 sur l'article
d'équilibre puis 493 sur la partie
dépense puis93 sur la partie recette
puis93 sur l'article d'équilibre 2è
lecture donc vous êtes déjà à 6 puis
vous faites ça pareil sur le les FSS et
vous faites ça sur 2 ans, bah vous
arrivez assez vite au compte. Le seul
texte de loi non projet loi de finance
ou projet loi de finance de sécurité
sociale, c'est la loi sur les retraites.
C'est le seul.
Les gilets jaunes, ça a été géré comment
?
Ça a été euh
Moi, j'étais vraiment ça faisait un mois
que j'étais au gouvernement.
Donc Non, mais
non, mais me faites pas l'excuse de la
jeune station. Non non, c'est pas ça
mais je
Ouais enfin je je dis toujours d'où je
parle et quel est mon référentiel. Euh
donc recul assez limité euh et
secrétaire secrétaire d'état donc au
fond de la soute par rapport au gouver
secré d'état c'est ministre hein.
Non c'est pas ministre. Vous n'êtes pas
au conseil des ministres.
C'est
c'est ministre de chez Twitch.
C'est junior
de junior. Voilà. C'est junior minister
la traduction. Je pense que c'est assez
clair. Euh et
comment on l'a géré ? Euh
au pays du ti
ah ça c'est une facilité
vraiment facilité de présentation.
J'accepte facilité de présentation. Nous
on a étudié les mesures
contrainsurreactionnelles dans les pays
du tironde.
Vous savez à quoi ça consiste une mesure
contraints insurrectionnelle dans un
pays du tier monde ? Allez-y.
On fait des gros multil en plein milieu
de la rue comme ça les gens ça les
dissuadent d'aller manifester le
lendemain.
Bah je peux pas entendre ça. Moi j'y
suis allée hein sur les ronds-points. Je
suis allée à la rencontre des gilets
jaunes.
Vous avez vu des LBD40 en pleine tête ?
Euh j'ai vu cela. J'ai vu L237.
J'ai
L237. C'est quoi les CRS ? Non, c'est le
film sur les gilets jaunes qui est assez
documenté.
Euh mais c'est pas c'est pas des mesures
antinsurrectionnelles, hein. On est dans
un pays, on est dans un rare pays.
Donnez-moi un autre pays où vous avez
envie de vivre, où vous avez ce niveau
de liberté, vous avez ce niveau de
sécurité sociale, vous avez ce niveau de
de qualité de vie. Donnez-moi un pays
qui a mis autant d'argent dans ses
services publics ces sep dernières
années.
Vous voulez quoi ? Un pays communiste ?
Non, je vous demande, je vous pose la
question
parce que des des pays communistes qui
investissent autant dans leur système,
il y en a beaucoup des pays communistes
qui dépensent autant.
Ah ben il y en a même pas beaucoup je
pense.
Ouais.
Dans son dans sa santé, dans son
augmentation dans l'augmentation des
salaires des soignants. Qui en parle de
ça aujourd'hui ?
Quand on parle de quand on parle, je je
reprenais et d'ailleurs là aussi j'ai
pris ma petite note de synthèse pour
parce que quelles sont les sources de
l'augmentation ? J'ouvre une parenthèse
avant de venir vous étiez stressé ou
quoi ?
Ah oui oui, je suis je suis quelqu'un
qui bosse hein. J'ai l'air comme ça avec
mon air je travaille. J'avais regardé
euh je voulais sur le les grandes zones
de hausse depuis 2017 euh de la sécurité
sociale.
On a fini sur l'Iran.
Bon, on a dit beaucoup de choses.
Vous voulez qu'on finisse ?
Ben, on peut continuer mais je plus que
vous m'interrogez sur
sur les gilets jaunes
sur sur les services publics, on met
quand même plus 70 milliard.
Question sur les services publics ou
vous voulez que je vous la pose comme ça
?
Et ben non.
Euh voilà, le Sure de la santé, c'est 13
milliards d'euros par an. C'est de
l'augmentation des salaires des
soignants. Est-ce que on pense
sincèrement qu'il fallait pas les
augmenter ? Est-ce que les yeux dans les
yeux vous êtes capable de me dire ils
sont pas correctement une tête de
chirurgien qui fait des implants de
cheveux ? Je parle des aides soignantes,
hein.
Non, mais les yeux dans les yeux. Je
m'appelle pas Jérôme Kusac, hein.
Donc euh
comment vous expliquez la défiance des
Français envers les politicien ?
Euh
je pense qu'il y a une
J'ai regardé votre TEDX et je le dis à
tout le monde, j'ai trouvé ça très
touchant. On partait avec un certain a
priori avant de vous recevoir. Madame la
magie, madame les 100000 emplois dans le
nucléaire qui sortent du pied d'un
cheval ou de la cuisse de Jupiter.
Il y a des erreurs de com à de balles.
Et on a regardé votre TX et on l'a
trouvé très touchant.
C'est pour ça qu'on a dit on a aussi
tu donnes sa chance.
Non, c'est pas je lui donne sa chance,
c'est que avant de regarder votre TX, on
a eu un copain qui nous a parlé de vous.
Hm
hm. Et il me dit "Elle est prête à
venir." Et je lui dis "Mais est-ce
qu'elle sait où elle va mettre les pieds
?" Elle me dit "Oui, oui, elle connaît."
Et là, on s'est dit "lelle est
courageuse."
"Oui, je pense que je suis courageuse.
Ça fait partie des quelques qualités que
j'ai." Oui.
C'était quoi ma question ?
Vous étiez sur est-ce qu'on a fini sur
l'Iran, est-ce qu'on pose une question
sur les services publics ? Et
c'est un truc que vous avez du mal,
c'est un acte manqué. Pourquoi la
défiance avec les Français ?
Oui, la défiance vis-à-vis des
politiques ? Non, c'est
je pense
Emmanuel Macron,
notre président solaire, notre leader
charismatique
et son ministre Hermit. Je pense qu' un
président de la République quand il a un
président de la République qui dit
"Venez le chercher, il est dingue, il
est pas dingue, il fait des
provocations, il connaît pas son
peuple." Parce que quand il y a un
français, vous lui dites de nez me
chercher. Moi je sais qu'en Bourgogne et
je remprasse la Bourgogne autour de
Tournu.
Quand il y a un mec qui dit ça, on va le
chercher et puis on le lève et puis on
le monte en l'air.
C'était quoi ? C'était de la gaminerie,
de l'immaturité ? C'était quoi ? La
question de la confiance dans la
politique, ça date pas de la semaine
dernière.
De la minute facile facile. Je vais vous
dire le
faites attention parce que quand vous
quand je dis facile, vous avez votre
faussette donc on se comprend.
Ouais. Ouai. Mais euh
2017 il se trouve que j'étais dans la
commission nationale de l'investiture
parce que précisément je voulais surtout
pas devenir député. Essayez de pas de
m'enterrer ce coup-ci parce que après
non je vais pas vous enterrer. Euh on
prend des gens de la société civile qui
on des parcours incroyable qui sont
d'une très grande diversité euh sociale
sociétale le métier et cetera. On a des
agriculteurs, on a on n pas le truc
profession libéral et fonction publique
qui sont les gens qui nativement ont
plus de facilité à faire de la politique
parce que ils peuvent mieux organiser
leur temps et leur métier. C'est
vraiment pas euh une critique, c'est
simplement un constat. Et donc on va
chercher des gens hyper diverses qui ont
des beaux parcours de des beaux parcours
républicains parce que c'est ça qu'on
veut montrer de la minute où ces gens-là
de la société civile pour une grande
partie d'entre eux franchissent le seuil
de l'Assemblée nationale ils sont
devenus des politiques de la minute où
ils sont devenus des politiques dans le
regard des gens ils ont basculé dans une
autre catégorie et alors pas de peau
parce que eux ils avaient pas les codes.
Donc il secttinent à la fois d'être vu
comme des politicards alors que c'est
nouveau pour eux, ils ont pris leur
risque, c'est faire de la politique
autrement et cetera. Donc ils sont vus
comme des politicards et comme ils ne
sont pas ils ont pas 20 années de
politique dans les pattes, ils font des
erreurs de com. Ils font des erreurs de
com. Ce qui est normal, je fais des
erreurs de com. Le président fait des
erreurs de com. Et en fait, c'est assez
violent. Et moi, c'est vrai que
maintenant un peu ma réponse c'est ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure, mais
pas de problème, venez, faites mieux et
en fait plus on sera dedans, plus on a
une chance peut-être de régler les
problèmes.
Le général de Gaulle, il faisait de la
politique avant d'être politique.
Le général de Gaulle, il a fait de la
politique au sortir de la guerre quand
même, hein. Et puis, il a rongé son
frein pendant un certain temps. Il s'est
fait insulter au sortir de la guerre. Il
a été maltraité.
Euh il devait le Conseil national de la
résistance était formidable. Tout le
monde s'est mis d'accord et il s'est mis
d'accord avec les communistes alors
qu'ils se détestaient tous cordialement.
Ça c'était très bien. Mais après ils lui
ont fait la peau.
Nos boîtes elles sont prêtes à la
guerre.
Notre tissu industriel est-ce qu'il a
est-ce qu'il est prêt à la guerre ?
Est-ce que quand vous êtes ministre
d'accord ? Non. Je pense que vous avez
une il y a une partie des entreprises
qui sont plutôt PME les petites PME.
Non, les les PME, ça fait 5 ans qu'elles
se prennent des il y a il y a une forme
de lassitude et d'épuisement. Moi, c'est
ce que me disent c'est ce que me disent
mes entreprises et c'est plus une
question de motivation, de préparation
et cetera. C'est euh j'ai beaucoup on on
on
le point qui est remonté de manière
assez forte dès cette première réunion.
Ça faisait 10 jours hein qu'on avait la
crise en Iran et j'ai voulu la faire
très vite parce que j'ai un peu les
habitudes du Covid et de la crise
énergétique. Premier c'est santé mentale
des entrepreneurs
et sentiment que c'est pas possible, on
reprend pas encore un tour dans le
tourniqué. Donc ça, je pense que c'est
une dimension qu'il faut pas
sous-estimer. Après euh les ETI, elles
se sont quand même musclées avec les
deux premières crises. Euh les grandes
entreprises aussi, il y a eu un un gros
travail quand même collectif sur la
résilience. Euh on on a beaucoup passé
des messages hein sur préparez-vous
GDSN. Je je les gens l'ont pas
complètement euh peut-être pris au
sérieux quand le SCDSN euh a diffusé euh
le contenu du du pactage que nous
devrions tous avoir chez nous euh en cas
d'événement euh particulier qui
peut-être climatique petit fasicule qui
n'est jamais arrivé dans la boîte aux
lettres. Oui, je vous parle de ça. Je
vous parle de ça mais c'est euh c'est
une vraie communication et c'est une
vraie préparation. Et c'est vrai qu'on a
des organismes enfin des OIV comme on
dit donc euh
organisation d'infrastructure vitale qui
sont entraînés et qui ont leur feuille
de route. On a pourquoi EDF a sa feuille
de route parce que c'est un OIV et que
on a quand même passé beaucoup de temps
à monter le niveau de de robustesse ou
de résilience. Moi, je préfère le terme
de robustesse euh de nos entreprises,
mais il y a un tissu auquel il est plus
difficile d'accéder quand on est
ministre parce que il est plus diffus,
il est plus sur les territoires et qui
euh et puis qui est épuisé épuisé de ces
crises successives. C'est ça le risque
qu'on a aujourd'hui.
Le mercourd,
le mercourd,
plusieurs choses.
Est-ce que c'est pas une mesurette à
court terme des Européens
pour encaisser le choc énergétique qui
va forcément se traduire dans les dans
les gamelles et que ça va sacrifier
notre savoir-faire industriel agricole ?
Alors,
si vous écoutez filière par filière, les
intérêts sont extraordinairement
divergents dans l'agriculture.
Sans déconner,
Mercosour
euh vin et spiritueux, ils ont intérêt
au mercour.
Lait et transformation la litière, ils
ont intérêt au mercour. Euh bœuf, ils
ont pas intérêt au mercour. Avicol, ils
ont pas intérêt au mercour. Donc quand
on regarde euh le en tête à tête, ils
vous le disent en tête à tête, ils
savent très bien v spiritueux, le marché
chinois s'est fermé, le marché américain
s'est fermé,
le marché indien ils sont en train il
est prometteur mais enfin faut installer
les circuits de distribution, les
habitudes et les Indiens sont plutôt de
culture anglo-saxonne. Donc ils vont pas
naturellement vers le cognac, ils vont
plus naturellement vers le whisky ou
et la bière
et et la bière évidemment.
Euh donc le marché argentin brésilien en
plus ce sont des euh
des pays à forte population et avec des
classes moyennes et des classes qui
commencent à prendre de l'élan.
Bah c'est hyper intéressant pour pour
ces pour ces filières là. Et
effectivement il y a une tension en
réalité dans le monde agricole par
rapport au mercour. Donc nous, on a
remis énormément d'éléments sur le
contrôle, sur le les les contrôles aux
frontières et il faudrait aller encore
plus loin. Moi, je
combien de doigners ?
C'est pas tellement une question de
doigner, hein. Enfin, moi l'approche que
je préconiserai euh c'est d'avoir la
même approche que sur le médicament. sur
le médicament quand vous avez vous me
lancez une je l'ai vécu puisqu'on a fait
à un moment on a monté des des bouts de
filières de vaccins, on était partie
prenante de des des vaccins qui qui
notamment le
les ARN messagers et on avait des bouts
de de chaîne d'approvisionnement. Il
faut tamponner, il faut tamponner votre
site. C'est-à-dire que votre site, il
doit être agréé par le marché auquel
vous avez accès. Donc, vous voyez les
GAL de la FDA qui débarquent et qui font
du sol au plafond, euh une analyse de
vos process et cetera. Au passage, il y
a un petit peu d'intelligence économique
d'ailleurs et qui tamponne votre site.
Vous avez les Chinois, si vous voulez
avoir accès au marché, vous avez les
Chinois qui arrivent, qui font du sol
plafond votre site et qui tamponnent
aussi. Et nous, on fait la même chose
chez eux. Sinon, vous rentrez pas sur le
marché.
On pourrait imaginer que plutôt que de
euh
contrôler aléatoirement des container
qui débarque sur un port français,
sachant qu'on pourra pas contrôler les
containers qui arrivent à envers ou qui
arrivent à Rotterdam, c'est peut-être
plus malin euh de valider des
exploitations qui en plus ont le beau
goût d'être assez grosses. Donc si vous
voulez vous éparpillez pas, vous prenez
les 200 plus grosses exploitations
brésiliennes et vous allez vérifier
toute la chaîne de d'élevage, qu'est-ce
que mangent les animaux, quels sont les
médicaments qui sont utilisés et
votre savoir-faire agricole français et
européen accessoir
ça marche hein, je veux dire pardon
c'est pas le certificat véli
premier juré la bête n'a pas mangé d'ogm
sur le pas mangé d'antibio.
Notre savoir-faire français, notre
résilience alimentaire, notre robustesse
alimentaire, notre indépendance
alimentaire.
Première question, le dérèglement
climatique quand même, on en parle pas
beaucoup. Non non.
Alors si si
on va avoir des cigales à Paris. Non
mais c'est pas ça. Si c'est vous
regardez la remontée de la ligne de
production des céréales, ça fait
certainement les affaires de la Russie
mais ça fait pas nos affaires.
Et nous on va faire des l'huile d'olive.
Ouais. Enfin on ve pas en ayant que des
des espagnols et les portugais on va les
mettre Pays Basquistoire qu'ils aient un
peu moins chaud.
Ouais, enfin c'est plus compliqué que ça
he parce que vous avez je veux dire vous
avez une espèce aujourd'hui
votre prisme de lecture concernant la
production alimentaire et le
réchauffement climatique avec tout ce
que ça implique comme stress hydrique,
stress thermique même si l'inria nous
fait des blé qui vont résister jusqu'à
70°gr
un jour et une blague et vous le voyez
comment vous voyez la résilience
alimentaire européenne tenir aussi bien
que la résilience énergétique et
industrielle.
Est-ce qu'il faut qu'on appelle Bruno
Lemire pour nous sauver notre industrie
encore ? Écoutez, résilience
énergétique, le fait est qu'on est moins
dépendant du pétrole et du gaz que la
moyenne. Vous rigolez ? Nous, on est à
60 % de fossile. La moyenne européenne
c'est 70%. Le de gazoile, il est à
combien aujourd'hui ?
Il est à 2 € ou on doit être à au-delà
de 0,9, on doit être à 2,15 € là.
le super 98 et 95.
Il est en règle générale 10 centimes 10
bons centimes en dessous. Le 95 étant
moins cher que le 98. Mais alors avec
l'effet de comment dire
la mesure totale, on se retrouve avec le
95 au prix du 98. C'est assez amusant.
Donc euh
le
résilience alimentaire au
résilience mais je reviens résilience
énergétique, on est en meilleure
position. On éétait pas résilient he
sous le général de Gaulle, on était
dépendant du pétrole et du gaz.
Non non, je le redis parce qu'on
Bernard Zambert qui a débarqué, ils ont
fait hop
voilà. Oui, mais sur l'électricité
Mesmer.
Oui, mais vous avez de tiers de votre
consommation même 70 % à l'époque qui
était du gaz et du pétrole. C'est vous
vous souvenez Mesmer avec
enfin je veux dire Mespermer c'est très
bien mais ça fait ça fait pas rouler les
voitures quand elles sont thermiques.
C'est formidable Mesper.
Mais notre dépendance au gaz et au
pétrole a baissé et a notamment baissé
significativement sous les différents
gouvernement. Donc maintenant, je
reviens à la résilience.
Ça s'appelle une récession ça non ?
Ah non, rien à voir. Ça s'appelle un mix
énergétique a bougé. Ça s'appelle un mix
énergétique qui s'est décarboné et ça
s'appelle une
partie électricité qui a augmenté. La
résilience alimentaire. Résilience
alimentaire, on a euh
un déficit sur les engrais. On avait un
plan de souveraineté en gris qui avait
été lancé en 2024. Donc vous pourrez
interroger madame Jeunevar pour savoir
où il en est.
La ministre de l'agriculture.
Ah ouais. Elle a changé combien de fois
déjà ?
Pardon ?
Elle elle a beaucoup changé ? Non, c'est
toujours la même.
C'est la même depuis septembre 2024.
Ah ouais
ouais. Pas eu le temps d'apprendre
encore son nom.
Euh on a donc on a un sujet de
dépendance sur les engrais.
Elle était la défense avant. Non,
elle était
elle était pas à la défense avant.
Non, pas du tout.
Non non non non. Elle était député du
dou
du doux.
Oui, on a une enfin je en tout cas de la
région
compté quoi.
Exactement. Une grande connaisseuse du
comté. Non mais je crois que c'est du
tout. Je
une grande connaisseuse du comté.
Oui. Du compé.
Alors l'étiquette marron c'est laquelle
?
Ah moi non. C'est elle.
Ah elle pardon.
Ouais pardon. Moi je le mange le compté.
Et vous préférez l'étiquette marron ou
l'étiquette verte ?
Alors là, j'ai un espèce de moi j'aime
bien le 30 plus de 24 points.
C'est parce que vous gagnez beaucoup de
pognons ça.
Non, c'est parce que j'en mange peu.
Combien vous gagnez là ?
Combien je gagne aujourd'hui ? Je reçois
4600 net sur ma feuille de paye poste
prélèvement enfin prélèvement à la
source.
Et vous avez une retraite de ministre ?
J'ai pas de retraite de ministre. J'ai
une retraite au régime général.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez été vous ennuyer
à les faire politique et ministre alors
que ça payé c'est payé quatre fois moins
que votre salaire précédent ?
Ah non, là c'est plus que quatre fois
moins. Maintenant c'est sep fois moins.
Mais c'est pas grave. Euh parce que
c'est passionnant parce que c'est les
politiques. J'ai mis le doigt dans ce
trucl et j'ai trouvé de la
réindustrialisation. J'ai accompagné
10000 entreprises industrielles. J'ai
euh travaillé à rouler sur l'Europe et
la Commission européenne et l'Allemagne
sur le nucléaire. Je vous assure, c'est
extrêmement gratifiant comme métier.
On roulait sur les Allemands.
Ah ouais, c'était très chouette. On
était vraiment on était très joyeux dans
le Talis de retour. Je peux vous dire ce
fameux, je sais plus, c'était en octobre
17 octobre je crois ou 18 17 octobre
2023. Euh j'ai obtenu et c'était un vrai
moment de négociation euh très chouette
euh la sortie des énergies fossiles dans
la COP 28. Alors c'est là où les ennuis
ont commencé d'ailleurs parce que je
pense que les pays fossiles et les
grandes entreprises fossiles se sont dit
"Oh mon dieu, ils sont sérieux."
Et on a eu un
à ce momentlà qu'on a sorti des dossiers
sur papi qui a changé la boîte pour les
gamins, les actions dans l'énergie
fossile et ainsi de suite.
Non, c'est un an avant.
C'est un an avant. Donc
un an après, on vous a sorti des
dossiers. Euh
non, pardon. C'est c'est un an après que
j'ai fait transitioning away fossil
fuels.
Un an après ?
Ouais.
Pourquoi on vous a sorti ça ?
Parce que en fait, j'en sais rien si ce
n'est que ça.
C'est une puissance étrangère. Est-ce
que c'est une puissance étrangère qui a
essayé de vous déstabiliser ?
Est-ce qu'il y a eu une enquête de la
DGSI ?
Non, il y a pas eu d'enquête de la DGSI.
J'ai été j'ai été glissée très très
seule sur ce sujet là. Très très seul.
Vraiment très très seul.
Alors pour ceux qui connaissaient pas,
c'est quoi ? Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Pour ceux qui connaissaient pas, on m'a
accusé euh de ne pas avoir révélé que je
détiendrai de l'argent au travers de mes
enfants mineurs qui dépendraient enfin
qui serait lié une énergie à une à un
pétrolier, deuxème plus grand pétrolier
français. euh et que tout ça était logé
dans des paradis fiscaux. Donc j'avais
vraiment euh c'était tout affreux. Et la
vraie histoire, c'est que mon père a été
salarié d'une entreprise pétrolière dont
il n'était plus salarié à l'époque parce
qu'il a 77 ans. Donc il arrivé à à la
retraite. Je lu avais encore un petit
contrat de conseil comme les gens qui
sont restés 40 ans dans une boîte et qui
donnent un petit peu des conseils sur
l'historique de l'entreprise qu'il avait
évidemment aucun aucune exposition
patrimoniale parce que c'était une boîte
familiale et que la famille avait pas du
tout eu l'intention de partager
ni les commandes ni l'actionnariat de
l'entreprise. Donc il était pas du tout
exposé patrimonialement et que il avait
fait une donation à ses petits enfants
intégré enfin en France. Vous tapez
d'ailleurs sur Google le nom de
l'entreprise et vous trouvez son adresse
en France. Et donc elle est parfaitement
visible, publique et elle paye ses
impôts en France. Mais comme euh c'était
des parts de fonds dont les équipes de
gestion elles-mêmes travaillaient à
l'étranger, c'est devenu des paradis
fiscaux. Donc voilà et c'est
et je pense que
ça a été fait à la fois pour me
déstabiliser en tant que macroniste,
ça
comme à peu près tous les ministres
comme à peu près tous les ministres dont
en fait
une large majorité. Enfin, moi je j'ai
pas eu le début du car. Enfin, j'ai je
pense que je suis la seule ministre à
avoir un communiqué de presse de la
haute autorité de transparence de la vie
politique qui dit qu'il y a pas de
problème. Donc c'est quand même fait de
guerre important. Mais en fait moi tout
y est passé hein. Mon ancien compagnon,
mon nouveau compagnon, mes enfants, mon
papa. Euh
comme j'ai pas une famille plétorique,
je me réjouis pour eux. Ça leur évite
d'y passer mais je pense que ça fait
partie de effectivement la vie
politique. Ensuite, est-ce que à
certains moments j'ai eu de la
déstabilisation à titre personnel parce
que transitioning away fossile fuel ?
Oui, je pense, je sais pas exactement
voir les traces de doigts, mais je pense
que mon activisme pour porter cette
position là a pu peser dans le jeu. Et
je sais pas dire si le nucléaire a pu
peser ou pas, mais
je voilà, ça je sais pas, je sais pas
complètement lire.
En France, on a des bulldogs. Le bulldog
français, c'est un bon chien de garde.
Ouais. Hm. Est-ce que euh on vous a
proposé nos Bulldogs euh pour aller
remonter un peu la piste de qui est-ce
qui essaie de
Non,
c'est normal, c'est pas normal.
Quand il y a une attaque
informationnelle sur un membre du
gouvernement
à tort ou à raison. Quand on a une
attaque, moi ça m'est arrivé quand on a
une attaque d'un device, c'est l'anci
de de l'un de nos outils informatiques,
le téléphone, le ils font très bien leur
boulot, une attaque informationnelle.
Euh,
vous avez eu un vous avez eu un Pegasus
sur votre téléphone ?
Moi, j'ai pas eu Pegasus mais j'ai eu
une autre attaque informationnelle.
C'est Nancy qui l'a géré dans un premier
temps. Ensuite, la DGSI de quel type
peux pas vous dire. Genre des ragou euh
des machins.
Non non, c'est euh une tentative de
rentrer sur euh dans votre téléphone
Ouais. Ouais. Donc c'était pas Pegasus
mais c'est probablement un autre.
Comment vous vous êtes rendu compte de
ça ? Votre batterie se déchargé plus
facilement. Euh est-ce que est-ce que
nos services ont enfin compris qu'il
fallait faire des pots de miel avec les
téléphones des ministres français pour
voir ce qui se passait autour ? Euh
je pense qu'on n'est pas à ce niveau de
voilà.
Je demande juste à notre communauté de
faire remonter les tweets intéressants
pour poser les questions à madame ma
ministre en likant les tweets en
question sous le poste. Les questions
pour ce soir, formulation courte et
efficace
à la suite de notre parce que comme ça
on va pouvoir vous poser quelques
questions avant de vous relâcher.
Est-ce qu'il y a un sujet que vous
aimeriez traiter avec nous avant de de
partir sur les questions des internautes
? Un truc que on n pas abordé là. Ça
fait 2h50
qu'on est en en interview.
Euh,
on n' pas abordé. Alors, je vais mettre
un peu les pieds dans le plat parce que
je pense profondément que c'est un sujet
de souveraineté. Toutes les dimensions
euh
effondrement la biodiversité en fait
impact environnementalite planétaire.
Facile
facile comme ça.
Bah ouais,
l'eau, les matières premières, le
foncier dans
dans l'espace sur Mars.
Voilà. Euh et vous parlez de
souveraineté alimentaire dans la
souveraineté alimentaire vieux.
Voilà. Oui. Soleil vert. Dans la
souveraineté alimentaire,
on sera par Ellisabeth Borne.
Non.
dans la souveraineté alimentaire, vous
avez la partie climatique, sécheresse,
euh punaise diabolique, nouveau
ravageur, nouvelle maladie et cetera,
mais vous avez aussi la partie
affaiblissement des sols, qualité des
sols qui est dramatique
surtout quand on a une crise des engrais
mais que ces engrais eux-mêmes ont une
responsabilité dans l'affaiblissement
des sols.
On reçu nos ingénieurs agronomes qui
nous parlaient de ça. semi hydroponique
à coup d'engrais, ça marche plus trop
bien quand il y a plus les engrais qu' a
le réchauffement climatique.
Exactement. Et par ailleurs, il y a un
vrai travail à enfin si
le trou dans la voilure le trou dans la
voilure pour remettre nos sols à peu
près correct pour éviter de mettre trop
d'intedans et pour pouvoir encaisser
correctement le le réchauffement
climatique dans la mesure du possible.
C'est un trou dans la voilure de combien
d'années ou de combien de pertes de
rendement à l'hectare ?
Je saurais pas le dire. Euh et je pense
que ça ça mériterait vraiment d'être
pesé parce que je pense qu'on surestime
peut-être ce coût,
le coût des engrais ou le coût du
réchauffement climatique ?
Non, le coûpt du de la transition.
C'est-à-dire que le quand vous regardez
et en fait aujourd'hui on a plutôt des
preuves de concept sur des cas
d'espèces. Moi, j'ai euh des
agriculteurs autour de moi qui sont en
train de tester la régénération qui est
à différentes techniques. Ouais, c'est
plutôt c'est des gars d'ailleurs de de
la FDSEA, hein, donc c'est pas des
militants mais c'est juste qu'ils
essayent de voir ce qui marche, ce qui
va repart. Et on voit bien que la
diminution du labour ça fonctionne, mais
il faut quand même un tout petit peu de
chimie pour arriver à à gérer tout ce
qui est avant. Que vous avez un vrai
sujet de couverture des sols. Ça c'est
quelque chose où ils ont eu des bonnes
performances, ils ont plutôt
agréablement surpris. Mais le problème
de l'agriculture, c'est que c'est pas un
process industriel. Un process
industriel, vous avez une boîte qui est
fermée, c'est vous qui définissez les
conditions de la l'expérimentation.
l'agriculture chaque année vous rejo
tardif une année avec un truc de grê et
donc vous pensez avoir mis au point
quelque chose qui fonctionne et en fait
ça fonctionne pas dans d'autres
conditions climatiques.
Vous êtes en train de me dire de mettre
des agricultures au K d'Orsé au
ministère de la défense là. Bah, je
pense que c'est totalement régalien et
pour le coup. Ça c'est un point sur
lequel on converge avec la la ministre
de l'agriculture. C'est régalien
l'agriculture aujourd'hui.
L'alimentation, c'est régalien à deux
titres. C'est un comment on sécurise
notre alimentation au niveau France
Europe. De nous étions un élément de
stabilité dans un d'un nombre de
géographies qui sont des géographies
fragiles. Est-ce qu'on a et on voit que
la Russie peut se retrouver pas si mal
du dérèglement climatique. On leur
laisse prendre la main en stratégie
d'influence parce que quand même celui
qui vous donne à manger, c'est votre
maître hein.
Celui qui nous donne à manger du
pétrole.
Celui qui vous donne à manger du pain
hein.
Du
du pain, des céréales.
Il y a combien de calories fossil pour
combien de calories assimilé ?
Ou là ? Alors là, vous me posez une
colle. Euh c'est quand même une sacrée
clé de voûte, non ?
C'est une calorie assimilée pour 10
calories fossiles.
Oui. OK. Je le vois dans ce sens là.
Mais
notre maître, notre maître c'est qui là
? et Momo Mola d'Iran, c'est Ben des
États-Unis.
Oui, mais parce que comment sait-on
faire une calorie assimilée avec moins
de pétrole ? Et vous revenez à la
question de la sobriété, l'efficacité,
c'est les éléments clés.
Il faut remettre la charrue et les
alors du village sobriété, efficacité,
technologie alternative.
Vous avez déjà fait les vendanges ?
Non.
Question internet. Madame la ministre,
comment se fait comment se fait-il que
la France ne soit pas le Qatar européen
de l'énergie ?
C'est la fin de la question
pour Oui.
D'accord. Euh la France est le seul
pays,
un des seuls pays au monde à être
capable de faire toute une centrale
nucléaire. Je veux dire chaque composant
de centrale nucléaire
avec ou sans les turbines arabelles
avec les turbines arabelles. elles sont
chez nous quand même maintenant.
Elles ont été racheté très cher. Non,
encore une connerie de Macron ça non ?
Ouais bah faut regarder un peu plus près
le deal. C'est pas si c'est pas si
absurde que ça.
Alst vous avez suivi Alstom ?
Alst
j'étais au conseil de la BPI
conseil d'administration et je l'ai
quitté.
Pour ça,
je
n'ai pas de commentaire à faire.
Donc, on sait faire de l' on sait faire
du nucléaire sur toute la base. On est
très bon en gaz, on est bon en
biométhane, on est bon en géothermie, on
n'est pas mauvais en panneau
photovoltaïque, en éolien marin, en
éolien terrestre. Je vais vous préciser
une chose. Oui, nous avons des
composants qui viennent de Chine. Les
différences entre le pétrole et les
composants qui viennent de Chine, c'est
les composants qui viennent de Chine,
ils ont beaucoup goût de durer 30 ans.
Donc vous faites pas un chèque toutes
les semaines pour refaire le plein. Une
fois que c'est en place, 80 % de la
valeur, elle est domestique sur une
installation photovoltaïque ou sur une
installation éolienne et derrière ça
produit pour vous. C'est pas du tout le
même niveau de dépendance. Et
effectivement, on a essayé de remettre
des composants de type PV au panneau
photovoltaïque et cetera en Europe.
Peine un peu, hein, on va pas se
raconter.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi Emmanuel Macron que
vous connaissez mieux que nous,
il rêverait de faire ça je pense ?
Pourquoi il dit pas au français ? Bon
les gars, on est dans la merde. Tout le
monde veut notre peau.
Les Européens, bon c'est un petit peu,
je vais pas dire une petite bande de
débiles, mais bon, il
pas parler beaucoup d'Europe.
Comment
on pas parler beaucoup d'Europe ?
Ouais. Bah la bande de débiles qui sont
pas capables de faire une seule armée,
pas capable de se mettre non on appelle
ça des débiles.
En fait, on est 68 millions. Si on
arrive à hacker les euh 380 millions
restants, on est super fort. Et donc, il
faut hacker les Européens. Il faut faire
une France, une Europe puissante,
goienne. Moi, j'y crois beaucoup.
Comment on fait ça ? stratégie
d'influence, on lâche jamais le siège à
l'Europe. Mais si mais si, on débranche
les Allemands, on leur coupe
l'électricité et maintenant on leur dit
non mais
tu vas danser pour moi.
Ça ça s'appelle faire un rapport de
force. Mais c'est ce que je vous dis le
rapport de force, il est tout cuit. Est
là leur industrie elle est elle est
morte et moribonde. 94 % des industries
énergivor allemandes,
ça c'est sûr que c'est
pense à se barrer.
Ouais. Ouais, c'est vrai.
Donc là, merde avec sa coupe de cheveux
néorac,
on lui dit "Tu fais encore ton malin 2
minutes, tu es pas gentil avec Agnè, on
te coupe l'électricité."
Et je vous revois ce qu' dit Babouche.
Très bien.
Pourquoi Macron ? Pourquoi Macron il
fait pas ça ? Il dit "Écoute maintenant,
tu es très bien gentil, tu vas te
taire." Pourquoi Macron il dit pas "On a
Mayotte, Mayotte c'est chez nous.
Mayotte a du gaz. Mayotte est
l'équivalent du D3 d'ormous dans la
région. On peut faire chier tout le
monde. On a la Guyane, on a de l'or, on
a du pétrole.
On a pas de pétrole en Guyana.
Guyana. Non, à côté. Non,
Guyana, c'est pas la Guyane.
Non, non, pardon. Mais juste à côté,
c'est pas le même le même filon.
Non,
ils ont cherché total. C'est pas des
philanthropes, ils ont pas trouvé. pas
des philanthropilanthropes donc
Ah voilà, on a de l'or,
on a de l'or, on a de l'or.
On a la Martinique, la Guadeloupe, on a
Saint-Bart,
on peut mettre des grandes oreilles par
là aussi.
Hoi
pourquoi on redresse ? Ouais. À
Saint-Bart, c'est un peu des fénias, ils
foutent rien les grandes oreilles là-bas
de fénias, on les retrouve, ils arrivent
même pas à rentrer dans le carry VIP
d'une boîte
pour vous donner le niveau
d'infiltration.
Pourquoi Macron il dit pas maintenant on
va redresser redresser la tête, on va
prendre le contrôle de l'Europe puis on
va s'affirmer en tapant du point sur la
table
parce que les Allemands les Allemands
ils font des stratégies de ils font des
stratégies de merde les Allemands
et on est obligé de se les coltiner
parce que le couple franco-allemand Non
mais quand vous avez le cousin un peu
crétin à Noël vous le mettez au bout de
la table.
Ouais, mais alors d'abord
commercialement c'est notre première
partenaire. Donc quand l'Allemagne
Ouais, enfin quand l'Allemagne va mal,
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle pour le
reste de l'Europe hein. C'est je veux
dire les les économiques sont comme ça.
C'est si vous vous achetez chez eux et
vous leur vendez des trucs, vous êtes
bien content qu'il vous les achète.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec un membre qui
commence à gangrainer ?
Je pense pas qu'il faille couper. On a
besoin par contre c'est vrai que c'est
euh l'intérêt c'est de prendre l'intérêt
leur seule qualité leur seule qualité
c'est qu'ils vont pouvoir nous
concurrencer sur la production de dette.
C'est sûr que notre dette va être un peu
moins plu elle va être un peu moins sexy
sur les marchés. Bon on a l'habitude
mais qu'est-ce qui leur reste aux
Allemands ? Ils ont plus de gaz bon
marché donc leur leur industrie
comment leur industrie hyper énergivore
pour aller faire les malins avec
et leur couplage renouvelable gaz. et a
du plan dans l'aile. Ouais. Ouais. Donc
là, c'est bien le moment de les
Ça c'est bien le moment de discuter de
comment on va collectivement financer du
nucléaire. Je suis d'accord.
Pourquoi Macron il fait pas ça ?
Mais on le fait. Bah je veux dire encore
une fois si on marche
quand on obtient le principe de
neutralité technologique, il est inscrit
dans la loi climat qui vient d'être
votée. Il est inscrit dans la loi
climat.
La question la bataille suivante, c'est
la question des interconnexions et à
quel prix font les interconnexions et
quelles sont les règles du jeu ? Et
c'est la question du pilotage de
l'intermittence. Et ça, on l'a
bruyamment mis sur la table il y a
quelques jours au conseil des ministres
de l'énergie et ça a été euh mis sur la
table de manière plus cibiline mais très
claire depuis 3 ans et on est allé
chercher euh pied à pied les différents
sujets. Après, oui, on a besoin que
l'Europe décide plus vite. Moi, ce qui
m'a désespéré, c'est on lance un plan
hydrogène européen, c'est super. On
était en avance, on a
Pourquoi Macron il a arrêté à Astrid ?
Alors ça je sais pas ça j'ai jamais
réussi à être très au clair si ce n'est
que je sais qu'il y avait une note
commune CA EDF et un 3è acteur qui
expliquait par A + B pourquoi il fallait
arrêter.
Vous savez, on prend pas des décisions
en se disant ou on va arrêter tel truc
sans avoir un peu des des des
éléments étayés. Donc ça correspondait à
une position de place au moment où où
cette position a été prise. pas une
position qui euh
Bruno que vous connaissez un peu mieux
que nous dit à comment il s'appelle qui
est un peu popoche là euh
aidez-moi là l'ancien l'ancien euh
avec non
non euh Medvedef
Medvf ah oui
qui lui dit bon grand on va te mettre
ton économie à genouves ved il a regardé
Bruno il a dit bon il a sifflonné ma
bouteille comment ça se passe il est un
peu concon
vous avez envie d'être Russie là en ce
moment vous
bah à quel endroit
ça a pas l'air de très très bien se
passer. Après je veux dire que
vous avez été en Russie quand la
dernière fois
j'ai alors là je vais avouer et être
très clair
Russie D'accord. Vous êtes informé sur
la Russie par qui par quel intermédiaire
?
Euh des amis franco-russes
où ça ?
Euh
à Saint-Pétersbourg.
Ouais d'accord.
Non
bah je voilà
c'est c'est Disneyland
et et par ailleurs euh on a un certain
nombre d'éléments qui nous remontent qui
tentent à penser que
l'économie n'est pas dans un état
formidable. Alors après, je pense que la
résilience,
il a Nicolas Méan qui vous passe le
bonjour et qui vous dit sans rancune.
C'est ça fait 5è message qu'il me dit
c'est
je sais pas pourquoi il me dit ça
parce queon était parce qu'il a annoncé
que le prix de l'électricité en 2024
allait augmenter de 57 % et que je lui
dit que bah non, il allait baisser de 15
%. Il a baissé de 4 % raison.
Vous êtes sûr ? Ah, j'en suis sûr.
Demande à FA Cheekit. Réveille-toi
réalisateur.
Je Il a fait des tweets
en 2000 euh
parce que c'était au moment des
élections européennes. Oui, c'est ça. Le
2025 donc en 2024 en disant que le prix
2025 allait augmenter de 57 % et nous on
a annoncé qu'il baissait de 15 % et il a
baissé de 15 %. Tarif réglementé 1er
février.
C'était peut-être pas ses chiffres à
lui.
Non, c'était pas ses chiffres.
C'était les chiffres qu'il a communiqué.
Moi je il les avait calculé. C'est à
vous de lui demander sa méthodo. Je
pense que son message était plus
politique. J'en ai pas des
Ouais. Non, il est pas politique pour un
Si si, il y avait des arrières-pensées.
Oui, bien sûr. Mais c'était parce qu'il
aime pas beaucoup les énergies
renouvelables. Mais voilà.
Revenons à notre leader solaire Emmanuel
Macron.
Oui.
Quand est-ce qu'il va arrêter de faire
le dandy là ?
qui va un petit peu expliquer aux
Allemands que on en a r casquette de
leur conneries.
Ben, je pense qu'on a des discussions
euh en fait la perception que vous avez
des des
négociations internationales, c'est la
conférence de presse de sortie. la
conférence de presse de sortie, on est
poli, on est gentil, on se comporte bien
et une des règles du jeu en diplomatie,
c'est d'éliciter de faire perdre la face
aux autres. C'est pour ça que on
évoquait tout à l'heure l'épisode
japonais de Trump, je suis pas sûr qu'on
marque qu'il marque des points sur ces
moments-là. Ça veut pas dire qu'on
n'aime pas des discussions assez uniques
quand les portes sont fermées, hein.
Moi, j'ai eu des discussions très euh
rboratif pour le dire simplement porte
fermée. J'ai failli en venir aux main
avec une commissaire.
D'abord la chaise
et non pas avec une commissaire
d'ailleurs, avec une c'est pire que ça
avec une DG de direction à la Commission
européenne devant le commissaire.
Le sujet c'était quoi ? la pêche
et euh les mesures de renouvellement de
la flotte en outre mer où elle refusait
de nous donner la possibilité de
soutenir le renouvellement des bateaux
en outreem notamment en Guyane au
prétexte que la ressource en poisson
était en diminution alors que nos
bateaux à nous font genre moins de 18 m
quand ils font pas moins de 12 m et que
la ressource est essentiellement pêché
par des bateaux brésiliens et du Surinam
qui sont font 80 m. Et donc c'est un peu
comme si tu expliquais à je sais pas moi
à l'épicerie du coin qui est responsable
d'une politique des cinq plus grandes.
C'est
un peu comme si on expliquait comment
faire une une anticipation de TVA Bruno
Lemer.
Donc en tout état de cause, ce tru-là
était insupportable et c'est vrai que
oui, on a eu des mots, enfin moi j'ai eu
des mots très forts avec elle et je
crois qu'on l'a obtenu la la la
décision. C'était en c'était en
septembre dernier, on a obtenu la
décision derrière mais oui, ça fait
partie des des sujets où il y a de la
tension dans les dans les salles, ce qui
est normal. 27 pays, je peux vous
assurer que chacun arrive en ayant quand
même à cœur de défendre ses intérêts.
C'est-à-dire que à la fois, il faut
qu'on soit fort contre les autres, mais
évidemment chacun on arrive avec notre
casquette, hein. Moi, j'ai le drapeau
français dans le dos. L'allemand il a le
drapeau allemand, le belge il a le
drapeau belle. Quel drapeau ?
Ursula, elle a pu avoir des biais
atlantistes et allemands. Oui, c'est
clair.
Pourquoi vous précisez atlantiste ?
Parce que c'est la manière de le nommer.
Je Mais
a trahi l'Europe avec ses biatlantistes.
Non, je pense pas. C'est plus une
gestion de
de sa barque dans un univers
d'incertitude et d'arriver le sujet
d'Ursula, c'est d'arriver à à aligner
les pays et à pas se à pas se prendre
une motion de censure du parlement. Et
donc nous nous pesons aussi en fonction
de ce que nous pesons au parlement.
Aujourd'hui, quand les groupes d'extrême
droite euh représentent une part
importante au Parlement,
euh de fait euh elle est
c'est un point de d'attention pour elle
et où le P
Est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui peut la
faire chanter Ursula ?
Chanter aux sens propres, je pense pas
parce que je pense que c'est quelqu'un
on va chanter, c'est ça ? Non, mais au
sens propre, au sens est-ce qu'elle
aurait des choses à se reprocher ?
Est-ce que les États-Unis ont des
dossiers sur elle ?
Je pense pas. C'est une femme très très
euh
J'allais dire très sévère, c'est pas le
bon terme, mais assz astique.
Min le ministère de la défense allemand,
on s'en rappelle encore. Question
internet.
Allez-y,
je la découvre avec vous. Ils nous font
d'ailleurs des questions longues comme
le bras. à qui incombe la responsabilité
de la dégradation de la France. Pour
l'interrogation, on évoque souvent le
talent de nos dirigeants, mais ce n'est
cela n'est-il pas simplement le symptôme
d'une population en perte de repère,
incapable de discerner ses propres
intérêts, ceux de la progéniture et de
la nation elle-même ? Pour
interrogation, sommes-nous face à une
dérive politique ou à une forme de
suicide social ? Interrogation.
Euh
bon courage.
Non mais ce qui est sûr c'est que le
monde politique est le reflet de sa
population. des préoccupations du monde
les politiques qu'on mérite.
Bah c'est pas faux en même temps parce
que nous ce qu'on prend comme pression
de l'opinion publique c'est une pression
qui qui est quand même enfin je veux
dire on dit mais vous êtes sensible à
l'opinion publique. Bah oui parce que
c'est le peuple tu vois en fait c'est
quand même leur démocratie c'est quand
même eux qui décident à la fin de la
journée. Donc on ne peut pas dire "Nous
on sait mieux que vous." Vous savez on
sait mieux que vous. On va vous dire ce
qui est bon pour vous. D'ailleurs, on a
pu reprocher parfois au président de la
République de faire ça.
On a pu lui reprocher de dire "Attendez,
moi, j'ai une vision, je vais vous dire
ce qui est bon pour la France."
Ouais. Oui, il a dit il a dit on
traverse la rue, on trouve du boulot
puis il se balade dans les gares, il y a
les sendants, il y a pas les sendants.
Ça c'était les c'était pas lui. C'était
lui il a fait pire lui. Il a dit les
gens qui ne sont rien.
Oui, mais il l'a dit dans un contexte où
c'était justement empathique en disant
vous dites qu'il y a des gens qui ne
sont rien. Donc vous voyez comme on
transforme les choses. Moi je suis une
spécialiste, on a réussi à me faire dire
qu'il fallait pas mettre de masque. À un
moment, je disais qu'il fallait mettre
un masque. J'ai fait très exactement la
phrase, je l'ai repassé au journalistes.
Ils ont mis 12 he à corriger le tweet.
Pourquoi vous avez pas déposé plainte ?
Parce que vous perdez. Parce que vous
perdez. Vous avez déjà déposé plainte
pour diffamation ? Vous perdez.
Il suffit de mettre
unconditionnel une phrase au style
passif. C'est terminé. Vous perdez. J'ai
regardé hein sur euh tous les trucs que
j'ai pris dans la figure. À chaque fois
l'avocat me dit "T'emballle pas, tu y
arriveras pas et en plus tu auras
l'effet où à chaque fois qu'il y aura
une audience, on reparlera du truc et
les gens entendront le problème est pas
la solution." C'est pas la peine. Et
puis vous vous savez combien ça coûte de
vent juge.
4000 balles.
Euh ouais, enfin ça dépend où. Euh et
euh première instance, 2e instance, 3e
instance et combien de temps ? Donc bah
vous prenez des tweets aineux, des
tweets machin vous voilà moi je déclare
à Faros c'est ce que je sais faire en
espérant que ça suit
en croisant les doigts. Bon il y en a un
qui vous a posé une question mais ils
veulent vous faire une blague.
Préférez-vous avoir des dents en bois ou
des jambes en mousse ou une jambe en
mousse ?
Euh
choquer.
OK. Bonsoir madame la ministre. Vous
avez évoqué la crise des gilets jaunes
en début d'interview. N'êtes-vous pas
inquiète d'une résurgence
insurrectionnelle avec des prix actuel
des carburants avec les prix actuels des
carburants et je rajouterai bientôt de
l'alimentation.
C'est euh effectivement une question qui
enfin la colère dans le pays, elle est
elle est
elle est pas négligeable. Moi, je suis
encore une fois, j'habite sur un
territoire qui est assez pauvre par
rapport à la moyenne française.
Je suis élu d'un territoire qui est en
fait va de la rageoie, qui se porte
plutôt bien vers le bassin minier, qui
est qui a un taux de chômage 4 points
au-dessus de de la rageois, quatre ou
cin points au-udessus de la rageoisie.
Donc vous avez 10 km he qui sépare euh
je dirais la borne du bassinier de et
je vois bien que les gens il tirent la
langue. Oui, ça c'est très clair. Ils
veulent des solutions et et ils écoutent
avec
et c'est normal quand on leur dit il y a
des solutions quand quand Marine Le Pen
pardon de faire un peu de politique, je
sais que vous êtes agnostique mais quand
Marine Le Pen dit l'État
Posta,
ça je ça vous appartient quand Marine Le
Pen dit euh les
Vous croyez en Dieu ?
Non
depuis longtemps ?
Oui.
Vous avez essayé ?
J'ai mon grand-père.
qui a voulu beaucoup me baptiser et je
lui dis que non et il m'a dit écoute
vous étiez déjà chiante déjà à l'époque.
Ouais.
Et il m'a répondu et j'ai gardé ça dans
ma tête. Écoute, ce qui compte
finalement c'est que euh tu t'éloignes
pas des principes de l'Évangile. Et je
trouvais que c'était la meilleure
réponse parce que je connais tellement
de gens qui se déclarent catholiques et
qui ne respectent pas. Je rappelle à
ceux qui sont dans un groupe h
assez puissant en ce moment et qui
conteste le euh par exemple le
dérèglement climatique et euh quel
groupe
Boloré euh que le pape François lui-même
conteste le le
Ah oui, vous avez un certain nombre de
de de papiers qui sont quand même très
dans le déni climatique
ou dans la la contestation. Le pape
François a fait euh une des encycliques
les plus euh environnementalistes très
claires, liant le social et
l'environnemental annonçant qui est
limpide annonçant euh annonçant ce qu'on
vit en réalité et euh le pape Léon X et
par reste alors avec des formes un peu
plus arrondies on va dire mais et il est
extrêmement
clair sur le sujet. Donc je préfère
effectivement les gens qui suivent les
orientations que ceux qui
se prétendent de porter ça et n'en
respecte pas le contenu. Voilà, c'est
une question d'éthique.
Est-ce qu'on vous a déjà dit que vous
étiez une fille à papa ?
Oui, bien sûr. Alors que mon papa n'a eu
de cesse de dire que dans la vie, il
fallait être indépendante et savoir dire
merde à son mec et qui m'a fait de moi
une machine de guerre académique dans
cet esprit-là. et que je n'ai jamais
rien dû à mon papa. Pas rien.
Revenons, revenons à la
si ce n'est de m'avoir euh donné cette
cette indépendance et cette liberté.
Revenons à au gilet jaunes et la période
prinsurrectionnelle qu'on est en train
de vivre.
Donc euh
ouais, besoin d'accompagner les gens,
besoin de mettre beaucoup plus de de
collectif, de lien social. Moi, je suis
énormément sur
je sillonne littéralement ma
circonscription tous les weekends, mais
juste pour le côté, on est là en fait,
on est là, on vous entend, on vous on
vous considère, on sait que c'est dur,
on sera là, on s'appelle, voilà ma carte
et cetera. Je pense que rien que ça,
cette espèce d'accusé de réception de on
est bien au courant de ce que c'est que
devoir avoir 30 balles, 50 balles de
plus sur la facture chaque mois, on est
bien conscient que d'avoir un niveau
d'incertitude majeur quand on est
entrepreneur, qu'on a 3 4 5 salariés et
que on se dit non, pas encore une crise
et qu'on est en fin de PGE et qu'on se
dit "J'étais en train de le rembourser
Et en fait, je peux prolonger mais ça va
me faire un incident bancaire. Après, je
vais avoir ma cotation banque de France
dégradée. Après, j'aurai plus personne
qui voudra me payer. Quand on a la
factureur qui vous tire le tapis sur les
pieds, quand vous avez tout ça, bien sûr
qu'on en est conscient.
Quand Macron a essayé de faire ça avec
les cahiers de doléance qu'on termine à
la cave de l'Élysée, là c'était une
opération de com. C'était
Non, c'était vraiment sincère et on en a
tiré quand même pas mal de chos. sur le
moment,
c'est plus que sincère sur le moment,
c'est que on en a fait euh un travail Si
on en a fait
hein, mais plus que la com puisque c'est
ça qui a conduit à l'augmentation de la
prime d'activité. Donc
rétrospectivement, je m'interroge si
c'était la meilleure formule parce que
d'une certaine manière, ça colle les
gens au SMIC, ce qui est pas une bonne
idée, je pense. Mais mais euh mais oui,
on a prime d'activité, on a fait un
certain nombre de mesures chaque énergie
et cetera.
Euh donc non, on en avait tiré des
conclusions assez praticopratiques.
Euh mais en fait le problème de la
politique c'est que vous vous avez
tendance à passer d'un sujet à l'autre
parce que s'impose dans votre actualité
un sujet et l'autre. Et donc c'est cette
question de la continuité de la
constance qui est vraiment le
le plus dur je trouve dans une
démocratie. Pardon ?
Comme dans l'événementiel non ? Un sujet
en est face à un autre un buzz on est
face un autre.
Mais parce que c'est la société du
spectacle. Non, parce que c'est la
société du spectacle et parce que
quand vous regardez euh et que vous vous
informez, ce qui va compter c'est ce qui
fait le buz, c'est pas le fond de cuve.
Ce que retient, vous l'avez très bien
dit, ce que retient les gens de moi,
c'est la magie et c'est mon père et ce
que j'ai fait n'a rien à voir. Et et en
fait et et vous pourriez appliquer ça,
c'est pour ton pays.
Mais oui, et objectivement, je pense que
c'est difficile de trouver quelqu'un de
plus attaché à son pays que moi, vous
voyez. C'est sinon j'aurais pas fait ses
sacrifices persos et et financiers.
Question internet que je découvre avec
vous. Quand on voit les faux
fournisseurs d'électricité qui se qui
sont des census de DF.
Oui, ça c'est vrai.
Pourquoi c'est bien que les Français
payent leur leur leur électricité
beaucoup plus cher que les prix du de
production ? Où va l'argent dépensé par
les Français en payant leur facture
d'électricité pour interrogation ?
Ah bon ? Alors trois parties. D'abord le
prix de production de de DF, il est à 60
€. Aujourd'hui, le prix de
l'électricité, il est assez
régulièrement en dessous de 60 € sur le
nucléaire, hein. Ça c'est comme quoi
finalement le renouvelable, ça fait
baisser le prix de la facture. Deux, euh
vous avez trois parties : le prix de
production, le prix d'acheminement, le
réseau et les taxes. Le prix
d'acheminement, c'est des
infrastructures et c'est des
infrastructures
dont lorsque vous regardez
les grosses infrastructure à venir, vous
avez un gros chapitre adaptation au
changement climatique. Ça, on a tendance
un peu à l'effacer mais ça pèse
plusieurs dizaines de milliards d'euros.
Vous avez effectivement le renforcement
du réseau notamment lié euh aux énergies
renouvelables euh et vous avez la
maintenance classique et l'extension de
sites pour venir approvisionner des gros
sites. J'inquiète qu'on est obligé de
monter
les infrastructures parce que avec enfin
les différentes usines qui sont en train
de s'installer, on on est on n pas les
capacités de livraison vers les
industriels. Donc ça c'est ça les les
gros postes. Et puis le troisème
chapitre, c'est la fiscale. la
fiscalité, vous avez euh une un taux
d'assise et le truc saisissant sur
lequel on s'est battu avec différents
ministres, je pense notamment à Olga
Givni qui était ma ministre déléguée à à
l'énergie fin 2024, euh c'est que le on
a des on taxe deux fois plus
l'électricité que le gaz. Deux fois plus
l'électricité que le gaz. Alors, vous
voyez l'ambiance si là on annonce que on
essaie de commencer à taxer moins
l'électricité et plus le gaz dans le
milestrum du moment. difficile
mais objectivement
c'est fou de taxer plus une énergie
produite en France bas carbone qui fait
de l'enfoir de l'emploi qui souveraine
qu'une énergie qu'on apporte de
géographies qui sont pas ultra
sympathiques qui nous tiennent comme ça
en voilà donc ça c'est la facture de
monsieur
la partie fourniture on on travaille à
la baisser en augmentant sans la
production du nucléaire sur la base
installée hein si vous faites volume
enfin coût comme c'est beaucoup de frais
fix ça baisse tendantiellement plutôt le
prix on le travaille sur la partie
renouvelable justement c'est la mission
les vituo et on travaille sur la partie
réseau où il y a eu un gros exercice de
repassage et d'optimisation du réseau
pour éviter de faire du réseau qui sert
à rien du du s on peut pas être dans une
logique où euh j'ai une infrastructure,
j'ai droit à mon raccordement parce que
c'est pas comme ça que vous optimisez
les prix. Vous pouvez pas empiler les
coûts. C'est ton infrastructure de
production, elle est très bien à
condition qu'elle soit proche d'un
réseau ou queil y ait une rationalité à
tirer un fil parce que il y a un
consommateur pas très loin et qu'on
matche consommation et production.
madame ministre
et donc pour lui dire quand même bah il
paye moins cher que les Italiens et
moins cher que les Allemands et a priori
ça devrait durer.
Il faut pas se comparer au dernier de la
classe.
Ça c'est vrai.
Madame ma ministre
mais on se compare souvent à
l'Allemagne.
L'Allemagne
on s'est longtemps comparé à l'Allemagne
et longtemps en étant petit chose de
l'Allemagne en disant qu'on était
Je sais pas chez vous qui est-ce qui
vous compare à l'Allemagne mais chez
nous on se comparait pas à l'Allemagne.
Revenons à nos moutons. Dans 5 ans.
France, vous la voyez où madame ma
ministre ?
Dans l'incant, je peux vous dire où
j'aimerais la voir.
Non, ça marche pas.
Dans 5 ans 2000 2032,
je vous donne les paramètres
débilitants.
Ouais.
Donald Trump qui met JD Events à la
place, la crise au Moyen-Orient qui part
totalement en sucette. On perd 50 %
Donald Trump. Ça commence par comment se
passent les midtermes ? à quel point il
sélectionne le corps électoral pour
faire en sorte que ça tombe du bon côté
puisque on a une loi qui vient de passer
et qui permet à tout moment de retirer
des gens du corps électoral sans
vraiment d'explication et avec à mon
avis une capacité de recours qui doit
être assez modeste. Donc on est quand
même en train de retirer enfin de
basculer dans quelque chose qui est plus
corvelliant me semble-t-il et comment à
un moment les deux Amériques réagissent
parce que je peux pas imaginer qu'il y
en ait une qui se laisse faire et
ficeler euh comme un rôti sur le plat.
Ce d'autant que la promesse de Donald
Trump d'améliorer la vie, c'est un peu
notre problème du bassin minier que
j'ai, c'est la la vie de des populations
qui ont subi plein fouet, la
mondialisation, laure rouillée et
cetera. Eux, ça s'améliore pas pour eux.
L'inflation, elle a quand même
énormément augmenté.
À un moment, ça devrait quand même un
peu s'agiter en toute logique, non ? Je
donc il y a ça quand même. Je sais pas
s'il installe V derrière. Ce qui est sûr
c'est que Donald Trump dans mon point de
vue lui il a un taux de d'actualisation
qui est très très élevé. Je pense qu'il
il a il voit à très court terme. Donc
comment il construit la suite ? Point
d'interrogation.
La France
La France en 2032
avec un trou un trou de production
alimentaire des rapports
dès 2032 je crois pas
dislocation de l'Union européenne.
Dès 2032 je crois pas. dislocation de
l'Union européenne dans le pire des cas,
dans le meilleur des cas, une
dévaluation massive de l'euro.
En tout cas, il y a il y a un au niveau
français, il y a il y a quelle est la
façon Non, mais je veux dire,
on vit au-dessus de nos moyens, donc
c'est quelle est la Vous voyez,
j'enfonce une porte ouverte. Donc non,
mais le sujet c'est
là, on dit pas enfoncer là, on dit
carrément défoncer la porte ouverte.
Défoncer la porte ouverte. Mais c'est
c'est quoi le mécanisme de correction ?
Est-ce que le mécanisme de correction
qui permet de réatterrir en douceur sur
nos pieds est un mécanisme qui passe par
un plan de route 2027, un président de
la République qui remet les enfin voilà
qui déroule
une remise au terrain ou est-ce que ça
passe par quelque chose
qui est une je pense que ça peut ça
passe plutôt par une attaque des marchés
financiers et et la version
italien Euh, Portugal plus que la façon
insurrectionnelle parce que
genre Pix,
ouais, enfin genre genre
genre font vos tours qui attaquent notre
dettes.
Ouais. Bah aujourd'hui, il y a des
et donc phase insurrectionnelle
derrière.
Regardez ce qui s'est passé avec la
Grèce.
Vous rappelez pas les les flic motard
qui se prenaient des cocktails monotop
dans les casques couvertes ? Mais
rappelez-vous aussi à quelle vitesse en
3 semaines, en quelques mois euh des
décisions qui paraissaient absolument
inattiable ont été pris dans ces
différents pays
en Grèce.
Je pense plus à l'Italie, Portugal,
Espagne. Non mais c'est des gentils.
Nous on est français et on en a gros.
On en a gros mais on a aussi une
certaine fierté, une certaine
on a quand même une certaine fierté. Ça
c'est un levier. On a quand même une
certaine
on a senti quand même une légère
fragilité dans le dans le gouvernement
du temps de comment il s'appelait
Benjamin Griveau. Quand il y a un
Fenwick qui est rentré dans son
ministère, on l'a senti un peu fébrile.
Quand qu'on a senti aussi un peu
Emmanuel Macron un peu fébrile avec
l'hélicoptère sur la pousse de l'hélice.
Alors, je rappelle à à tous ceux qui
nous écoutent mais qui le savent
pertinemment que la pñata Macron ne sera
plus disponible à partir de 2027 et
qu'il va falloir trouver d'autres
éléments de langage pour les
oppositions.
Pour le moment, c'est quand même un truc
assez simple.
Il pleut, il fait chaud, il vente, il y
a la guerre en Iran, il y a la guerre en
Ukraine. C'est la faute du président. Et
ben non, en fait c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça.
D'accord. D'accord. Donc la pignette à
Macron, est-ce que vous pensez qu'elle
va se maintenir au pouvoir sur un
extrême urgence ?
Non non,
ça c'est ça c'est du pur fantasme.
D'accord.
Pur fantasme.
On voudrait quand même un peu la garder
parce que bon en 2027 on va finir par
attraper la trouver quelqu'un d'autre.
Va falloir trouver quelqu'un d'autre.
Il y a pas grand-chose sur le marché.
Non. Qu'est-ce qui reste ?
Bah ild Philippe.
Il reste le bloc central. Non, ça le
bloc central ça fonctionne pas quand on
peut pas faire de la dette bon marché
quand l'énergie est pris les prix
d'énergie sont vous savez autant que moi
je pense qu'on est la proposition de
valeur la plus la plus courageuse si on
regarde nous ce qu'on vote réellement
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée nationale.
Croyez pas en Dieu mais vous croyez au
père Noël ?
Non je crois pas au père Noël. Je
regarde ce qu'on me dépose comme
amendement. Je regarde ce qu'on a
proposé au moment du budget et je
regarde ce que les autres ont proposé.
Moi, j'écoute pas ce que raconte les
gars.
Qui c'est qui qui a validé le budget qui
va se retrouver en revalider le budget ?
Comment elle s'appelle ?
Amilie. Non mais Améie de Monchal, c'est
franchement c'est une des plus
brillantes ministres qu'on a eu ces ces
dernières années.
Votre camp
et non c'est plus que ça. C'est
quelqu'un qui a tenu la boutique quand
elle y était et ce qu'elle a fait sur le
budget c'était quand même pas trivial
dans une assemblée aussi. La question
elle est pas bête ta question. Bonsoir.
10 ans de Macron. Pourquoi autant de
changement de ministre et de politique ?
Interroger le président.
Bah vous l'z vous allez me l'appeler
puis il va ramener son petit popotin
ici. On va discuter d'hom. Euh question
internet. Comment faites-vous pour vous
assurer que les décisions prises ne sont
pas déconnectées de la réalité des
artisans, ouvriers ou petites
entreprises sur le terrain ? Point
interrogation.
Est-ce qu'il est déjà arrivé que vous
souteniez une décision par solidarité
politique virgule en désaccord avec vos
principes pour interrogation ?
Alors euh comment je fais ? J'ai euh mes
signaux faibles que je
précurseur on dit.
Oui. Au précurseur en tout cas moi j'ai
dans ma circonscription
dans enfin voilà un certain nombre de
personnes, je donne très facilement mon
06.
C'est pas vrai parce que nous on l'a
pas.
C'est parce que vous l'avez pas demandé.
On demande jamais le 06, c'est à une
femme.
Et euh et je donne ma Et vous m'avez pas
demandé ma carte. Euh mais sur ma carte,
il y a mon 06 et euh j'ai souvent et
j'avais euh notamment par exemple
pendant le Covid, pendant la crise
énergétique, j'avais des boucles avec
des chefs d'entreprise à peu près de
toute la France, de toute taille et
cetera et en fait en enant une espèce de
voilà dit ce qui m'ont remonté, ce qui
va pas partager et cetera, ce qui permet
d'avoir une espèce de de bruit de fond
de de signaux de remonté terrain euh
parce que les corps intermédiaires
aujourd'hui au niveau parisien
ont leur propre déconnexion avec leur
base et c'est là aussi c'est pas une
critique mais c'est en fait on est sur
si si on ne se parle que dans le
microcosme parisien
on passe à côté de quelque chose et moi
ça m'est arrivé 10 fois notamment sur la
gestion des gilets jaunes de comprendre
qu'en fait j'avais les fédérations de
commerce mais ça redescendait pas
jusqu'au gars qui étaient dans la
mauvaise rue de la manifestation et ça a
commencé à marcher les mesures qu'on
mettait en place pour accompagner
les commerçants, les artisans. Du jour
où j'ai eu un collectif de 16 villes où
c'était les villes qui se faisaient
taper, les commerçants qui faisaient
tapé qui ont gratté à la porte. J'ai
dit, on m'a dit il faut pas les
recevoir, ils pèse rien. J'ai dit si si
on les reçoit. Et en fait bah c'était
peut-être pas beaucoup de commerçants
mais c'était ceux qu'on à qui on avait
besoin de parler parce que c'était ceux
qui se faisaient taper. Donc c'est comme
ça qu'il faut arriver à à faire les
trucs. Donc c'est comme ça que je fais.
Et la deuxième question c'était euh à
côté des commerçants, c'était
la fatigue, hein. Je retiens pas les
question.
Vous voulez que je je vous laisse la
question ? Ouais,
je vais vous la retrouver tout de suite.
Attendez, je remonte, je remonte parce
qu'il y a tellement de questions.
Est-il déjà arrivé que vous souteniez
une décision par solidarité politique en
désaccord avec vos propres principes ?
Vos principes ?
En règle générale, je suis très
silencieuse.
Ah bon ?
Je disparais des plateaux de TV et
cetera quand je suis pas totalement
d'accord. Mais j'ai fait j'ai fait j'ai
été
d'abord j'ai fait confiance, ça c'est
normal dans une équipe. Donc il y a des
décisions qui ont été prises où avec le
recul je me dis "Ah ouais, peut-être je
l'aurais fait autrement et cetera." Mais
j'étais pas si sachante que ça. Donc
c'est peut-être aussi un point de vue un
peu facile. Euh et deux quand j'ai eu
des points de désaccord, bah soit je je
l'ai dit en interne euh
et après une fois que je l'ai exprimé en
interne, vous avez deux pistes hein.
Soit vous l'exprimez en interne et vous
dites "C'est suffisant pour partir."
dites la balance
bénéfice risque, c'est-à-dire ce que je
suis encore capable de faire et de peser
dans le gouvernement versus que je viens
de prendre dans la gueule et positive et
je continue et c'est ça qui fait que
j'ai continué et à un moment j'ai
arrêté.
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ? Oui. Euh
j'ai une nouvelle d'Alan DA qui
s'appelle les haut-parleurs euh qui en
plus et euh disponible directement sur
internet. Donc vous avez même pas besoin
d'aller à la librairie, même s'il faut
soutenir les librairies physiques. Euh
et c'est une c'est une nouvelle qui
prend comme peach la privatisation du
langage. Et donc
le cas non. Ah, c'est mieux que ça avec
C'est que les mots les mots deviennent
euh propriétés de grands groupes qui
vous font payer des royalties quand vous
les utilisez. Puis vous avez des
collectionneurs qui vont acheter à prix
très élevé des mots rares ou des mots
savants et vous avez toute une société
qui se construit comme ça et donc
forcément les pauvres sont privés de
langage et les grandes la world coch
amour va acheter enfin vraiment les les
mots des émotions. C'est fascinant parce
que évidemment c'est un pitch totalement
extrême mais qui est extraordinairement
en miroir de ce qui se passe avec les
gars femmes. Et ce truc a été écrit, je
veux pas dire de bêtises, mais il y a
une bonne dizaine d'années quand même.
Donc c'est et puis c'est d'Amazion. Donc
c'est
c'est le vieillage
le le
le vieillage sur les émotions et
l'expressions des émotions.
Dites-moi,
on ne peut pas ressentir à sa juste
valeur ce que nous ce que
ce qu'on ne peut pas nommer
ce que l'on peut pas nommer clairement.
Mais moi, je pense que c'est un truc
très profond sur l'éducation nationale,
c'est que quand vous avez des gamins qui
arrivent à la maternelle avec un bagage
ou à la fin de la maternelle avec un
bagage de 500 mots versus 3000 mots, ne
vous étonnez pas derrière qu'il ait une
que ces gamins aient une incapacité à
gérer leurs émotions et donc soit obligé
de les exprimer physiquement parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les mots pour les
poser. et et je pense que ce sujet-là de
l'attrition du langage, de l'impact des
écrans, de l'éducation, du vocabulaire
et cetera est un sujet absolument majeur
dans dans notre si vous voulez savoir de
quoi est faite la France dans 5 ans, si
on prend pas ce sujet-là, si on prend
pas le sujet de la solitude, si on prend
pas le sujet de l'alimentation ultra
transformée, je veux dire, on passe à
côté sujet de la solitude. 10 % des gens
qui n'ont aucune aucune interaction, pas
un coup de fil, pas un voisin qui va lui
voir, pas un bonjour, aucune interaction
sociale qui sont morts socialement 10 %
dans notre pays. Ça c'est les vrais
drames dont on ne parle pas et qui sont
dans dans le dans le tréfond de la
société. Si vous voulez qu'en 2032, ce
pays soit vivant et et et continue à
être cette France qu'on aime et et et
auquel on croit, si vous traitez pas ces
sujets, vous êtes morts. Et moi,
j'aimerais qu'on en parle un peu plus.
Alors, c'est génial he la souveraineté,
l'industrie, c'est absolument essentiel.
Mais le lien social, le collectif, les
valeurs, le langage, tout ça, si vous ne
le prenez pas, enfin je voilà je
euh 2è livre, le peuple contre la
démocratie Yasham. Euh moi, j'ai trouvé
ça limpide justement dans la
compréhension de la montée, enfin de
le problème de la défiance en politique.
Je trouve que c'est l'impide de comment
le peuple se sent dépossédé de son droit
à décider
face à une démocratie qui met en place
des gardes-de fous pour protéger les
minorités, pour construire un droit
international et cetera. et euh ce
développement de de de d'une espèce de
peut-être intérêt ou
une baisse de de la
de la réticence vis-à-vis de pouvoirs
plus autoritaires. 3è livre, euh les
voix du géomimétisme.
Ah, j'ai décidé de Alors, ça c'est euh
Gilbert, je retiens mal les noms, donc
je me le reprends mais je vous promets
que je l'ai lu.
Les voix nouvelles du géomimétisme
Pierre Gilbert. Bon, ça paraît un peu
perché mais c'est raconté de manière
totalement passionnante comment la
biodiversité, c'est-à-dire les les
solutions naturelles, enfin comment la
nature, la sophistication de la nature
pour réguler le climat. Et l'idée
derrière, c'est de dire en fait c'est le
biomymétisme, c'est on a des solutions
qui sont ultra sophistiquées dans la
nature et qu'on aurait intérêt à copier,
à reproduire et cetera pour arriver à
lutter contre le dérèglement climatique.
Mais au-delà de l'usage qu'on peut en
faire, ce qui est magique, c'est à quel
point on est des espèces de gros pâte à
pouf en pensant singer la nature avec
notre ingénierie qui est piètre par
rapport à comment le cycle d'un CAC peut
piéger des tonnes de carbone, enfin des
tonnes, des kilos de carbone euh qu'on
qu'on avait absolument pas mesuré il y a
encore quelques années. les régulations
océaniques. Enfin, je c'est assez
magique. J'ai l'air un peu perché quand
je raconte ça, mais je recommande
vraiment. Voilà.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose qui restera
impérissable.
Lisez 30 minutes par jour, quoi qu'il
arrive, qu'il vende, qu'il pleuve, lisez
30 minutes par jour.
Madame ministre Agnagé, merci.
Merci à vous.